ALL RIGHT. LET'S CALL THIS
HEARING OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
TO ORDER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE, MISTER VICE CHAIR. AND
LET'S HEAR FROM SOME MEMBER WOOD
WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT AB 2902.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EFFORTS AND ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. SB 1383
WAS ESTABLISHED, ESTABLISHED A
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK FOCUSED ON
REDIRECTING ORGANIC WASTE TO
LANDFILLS, WHICH REDUCES THE
AMOUNT OF METHANE RELEASED INTO
THE ATMOSPHERE. WHILE THIS
FRAMEWORK CAN BE READILY ADAPTED
TO DENSE URBAN COMMUNITIES, IT'S
BECOME INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT
MORE FLEXIBILITY IS NEEDED FOR
RURAL COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION. CHALLENGES,
INCREASE LOCAL BENEFITS, AND
AVOID COSTLY RATE INCREASES FOR
RURAL RESIDENTS. AB 2902 EXTENDS
THE RURAL EXEMPTION FOR ORGANIC
WASTE COLLECTION AND PROCUREMENT
BY COUNTIES WITH A POPULATION OF
UNDER 70,000 PEOPLE, FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS, BUT
MAINTAINS THE REQUIREMENT FOR
THOSE COUNTIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERY
PROGRAM. THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES
AN ORGANIC WASTE COMPLIANCE
PATHWAY FOR 12 SMALLER COUNTIES,
CONTAINING 70 OF MORE THAN
70,000 RESIDENTS, BUT GENERATING
LESS THAN 200,000 TONS OF SOLID
WASTE ANNUALLY BY ALLOWING THOSE
COUNTIES TO SUBMIT ALTERNATIVE
ORGANIC WASTE MANAGEMENT PLANS
TO CALRECYCLE FOR APPROVAL,
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS IN AB 2902
CONTINUE THE USE OF ORGANICS FOR
LOCAL ANIMAL FEED PRACTICES,
PROMOTE CARBON FARMING, ADJUST
PROCUREMENT TARGETS TO EXCLUDE
POPULATIONS COVERED BY
EXEMPTIONS, AND FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SMALLER SCALE
COMMUNITY COMPOSTING PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL STATE, WITH MANY
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES TO
CONSIDER. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
STRIKING A BALANCE, PROVIDING
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY NEEDED TO CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND ACHIEVE
SB 1383 ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION
OBJECTIVES HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JOHN
KENNEDY, WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE THE SPONSORS OF AB
2902. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. GOOD MORNING, JOHN
KENNEDY WITH CRC HERE SPONSORING
AB 2902. THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK
TO IMPROVE THE BILL. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING 1383 FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW, BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES. WHAT
WORKS WELL IN DENSER URBAN AREAS
REALLY DOESN'T WORK AS WELL IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES. SO WE'VE
BASED THIS PROPOSAL ON YEARS OF
FEEDBACK FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
TRIED TO THREAD THE NEEDLE WITH
SOME RATHER NON-CONTROVERSIAL
BUT IMPORTANT PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES THAT PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
NOT ONLY FOR US AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM, BUT ALSO FOR
CALRECYCLE, WHOSE REGULATIONS
ARE PRETTY RESTRICTIVE RIGHT
NOW, SO THE AUTHOR, REALLY
COVERED MANY OF THE COMPONENTS
OF THE BILL QUITE WELL, THIS
RURAL EXEMPTION, EXTENDING THAT
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT, WE'RE NOT
SEEKING TO EXEMPT OURSELVES FROM
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE'RE NOT
DOING TODAY, BUT WE ARE LOOKING
TO ACTUALLY HELP THE STATE
ACHIEVE ITS ORGANIC REDUCTION
GOALS THROUGH DOING SOME EXTRA
REQUIREMENTS, PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY FOR ANOTHER DOZEN
SMALLER COUNTIES SO THEY CAN
DEVELOP TAILORED, INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS ORGANIC
WASTE AND UNINCORPORATED AREAS,
WE UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE TOOK
SOME AMENDS TO THE BARE PIECE,
AND THE BILL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO TRY AND TO FIND A
WAY TO THREAD THAT NEEDLE. WE
WANT TO AVOID AND MINIMIZE
ADVERSE HUMAN BEAR INTERACTIONS
IN SOME HIGHER ELEVATION AREAS.
AND REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS, LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS OR
ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU ALL HAVE,
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB 2902? GOOD
MORNING, CATHERINE FREEMAN. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MELISSA SPARKS KRANZ WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
A VARIETY OF AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS, APOLOGIES, WE'RE
NOT IN THE ANALYSIS, BUT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS, CHRIS
SCROGGIN ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, ERICA PARKER WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WITH
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS,
MAYBE CLARIFY THEIR CONCERNS?
OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
THOUGHTS? SENATOR DARLING? WELL,
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I
KNOW THAT BOTH OF US REPRESENT A
LOT OF THESE COUNTIES, AND, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T WANT THE PERFECT
TO GET IN THE WAY OF THE GOOD IN
A LOT OF CASES, WE HAVE COUNTIES
WHERE, WE HAVE A HUGE LAND MASS
WITH VERY FEW PEOPLE AND VERY
FEW BUSINESSES OUT THERE TO BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY DO WHAT THE
ORIGINAL LAW INTENDED US TO DO.
ACTUALLY CREATES MORE OF A
CARBON FOOTPRINT AND MORE OF A
PROBLEM THAN IT DOES TO
ALLEVIATE. SO GIVING THIS,
EXEMPTION OR THIS PATHWAY TO, TO
GETTING THERE, I THINK IS GREAT.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
WHEN WE GET A CORE. OKAY, WE'RE
SUPPORTING IT AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE.
AND WE'LL LET YOU CLOSE. I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. I
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LET'S, LET'S HEAR FROM
SENATOR GARCIA, WHO'S HERE. AND
AS HE COMES TO THE FRONT, JUST A
COUPLE THINGS I WANTED TO SAY.
THIS IS, OF COURSE, A, A VERY,
INTERESTING AND UNIQUE BILL, AB
2113 BY SENATOR GARCIA IS THE
POLICY VEHICLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MILL ASSESSMENT
TRAILER BILL. AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE, I KNOW THIS IS
UNUSUAL, THAT AT THE CHAIR MAKES
COMMENTS IN ADVANCE, BUT THIS IS
A SPECIAL CASE IS I THINK, YOU
KNOW, THE BILL IS STILL BEING
NEGOTIATED WITH THE, CONCURRENT
WITH THE BUDGET PROCESS. AND
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE ONGOING,
AND THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE THROUGH THAT PROCESS. AND
I WANT TO THANK THIS AUTHOR, THE
AUTHOR, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, TO GIVE THE PUBLIC A
FORUM FOR DISCUSSION TODAY, THIS
BILL, IN ITS CURRENT FORM,
REFLECTS A GREAT DEAL OF
STAKEHOLDER INPUT WORK BY THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF, A GENUINELY
CHALLENGING SET OF ISSUES AT
PLAY. AND I THINK IT'S TESTAMENT
TO ALL THAT WORK AND THE
COLLABORATION AMONG AND BETWEEN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES, THAT
THE BILL HAS NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION TODAY. SO THAT BEING
SAID, WE ALL KNOW THERE ARE SOME
SERIOUS ISSUES, TO ADDRESS THAT,
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT.
THE IMPLICATIONS ARE ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT FOR THE HEALTH OF
FARM WORKERS, FOR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES, FOR CONSUMERS, FOR
WILDLIFE, FOR OUR ECONOMY, FOR
OUR FOOD SECURITY, LET ME ALSO
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOW YEARS IN THE
MAKING AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION, IT
REFLECTS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WORK BY DEPARTMENTAL STAFF AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHO
ARE SEEKING TO BALANCE MANY
COMPETING PRIORITIES. SO I KNOW
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS HERE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND
WITH THAT, MR. GARCIA, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. I MEAN, I THINK
YOU'VE DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB IN
OUTLINING THE BILL 20 YEARS IN
REALLY DISCUSSION. THE
DEPARTMENT IS IN NEED OF SOME
POLICY REFORMS. THE DEPARTMENT
IS IN NEED OF SOME EFFICIENCIES
TO BE IMPLEMENTED. ALL SIDES,
ALL STAKEHOLDERS FIND COMMON
GROUND THAT THERE IS MUCH TO BE
DONE AT THE DEPARTMENT AND
PERHAPS FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
BUT NONETHELESS, THE DEPARTMENT
NEEDS TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE,
EFFICIENT IN HOW THEY USE THE
RESOURCES, AND THE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
EFFICIENCIES AND IMPLEMENT THE
POLICIES MORE EFFECTIVELY. AND
SO, AS YOU MENTIONED, THE BILL
CONTINUES TO BE A VEHICLE TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN HAD WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE, THIS VEHICLE WAS
INTRODUCED TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO HAVE SOME INPUT VERSUS JUST
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL HAVING
DISCUSSIONS THERE, THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT I THINK WANT
TO COME UP AND, SAY THEIR $0.02,
AND I WANT TO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
THAT SPACE. SO WITH THAT, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THE
ANALYSIS OUTLINES EXACTLY WHAT
THE POLICY BILL DOES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SO FOLKS WHO
WANT TO, WE'VE GOT FOLKS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YEAH.
COME ON UP. YEAH, YEAH, WE GOT
WE GOT WE GOT TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. AND YOU CAN COME UP
TO THE FRONT TABLES HERE. GREAT.
SURE. I CAN GO FIRST. HI, JANE
CELAN, CO-DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND FOR
THE EXCELLENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN
SO FAR, ON BEHALF OF CPR, I JUST
WANT TO SAY OUR TOP PRIORITY IS
A COMMITMENT BY THE DEPARTMENT
TO FINISH AND NOT MERELY
INITIATE A SPECIFIC NUMBER OF
REEVALUATION AND MITIGATIONS OF
PESTICIDES ALREADY PRIORITIZED
BY THE DEPARTMENT, IN MANY
CASES, FOR MORE THAN A DECADE,
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE THAT COMMITS DPR TO
INITIATE FIVE REEVALUATIONS PER
YEAR, FINISH THEM WITHIN TWO
YEARS, MITIGATE IF NECESSARY,
WITHIN ONE YEAR. THE DEPARTMENT
HAS STATED THAT STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS NECESSITATE A
PROCESS THAT TAKES A DECADE OR
MORE. THEY HAVE NOT PROVIDED ANY
STATUTORY EVIDENCE THAT THAT IS
THE CASE, WITHOUT FERM DEADLINES
FOR REEVALUATION AND MITIGATION,
WE WILL OPPOSE THIS BILL. WE
SUPPORT THE EXISTING LANGUAGE
ALLOWING ANY INTERESTED PARTY TO
REQUEST REVIEW OF APPROVED
PERMITS FOR RESTRICTED MATERIAL
PESTICIDES. WE ALSO URGE YOU TO
RETAIN THE PROVISION THAT WOULD
EXPEDITE REGISTRATION OF REDUCED
RISK PESTICIDES, AND ALSO TO
INCLUDE A STRONG DEFINITION OF
REDUCED RISK. AND FINALLY, WE
URGE YOU TO CODIFY DFE'S PLAN IN
THE SPM ROADMAP TO PHASE OUT
PRIORITY PRIORITY PESTICIDES BY
2050. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THOSE, SUPPORT WITH THE WARNING.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, NICOLE
QUINONES, REPRESENTING THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION, OUR
MANUFACTURERS OR OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE MANUFACTURERS OF THE
NONAGRICULTURAL PESTICIDES. SO
THESE ARE THE PRODUCTS USED IN
YOUR HOMES AND HOSPITALS, SUCH
AS DISINFECTANTS, PET CARE
PRODUCTS LIKE FLEA AND TICK
COLLARS, AND LAWN AND GARDEN
PRODUCTS TO NAME A FEW, OUR
MANUFACTURERS CONTRIBUTE ROUGHLY
HALF OF THE TOTAL MILL
ASSESSMENT COLLECTED BY DPR EACH
YEAR, AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CARRYING
2113. IT HAS AFFORDED A MUCH
MORE ROBUST CONVERSATION AROUND
WHAT IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT TAX
INCREASE, AND AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED, WHAT REFORMS
OR EFFICIENCIES COULD BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
IN LIGHT OF THOSE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES, OUR MEMBERS WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT DAILY AND SUPPORT
A WELL FUNCTIONING DPR AND
RECOGNIZE THAT IT WILL TAKE
THOSE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE AT THE
TABLE, AB 2113 HAS DONE A VERY
IMPORTANT JOB OF TRYING TO
BALANCE ALL THE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES FROM THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS. I'LL JUST
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF OUR
PRIORITIES THAT WERE INCLUDED,
RECOGNIZING IT WASN'T EVERYTHING
. NOBODY EVER GETS EVERYTHING,
BUT CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHAT
WHAT WAS INCLUDED, WE'VE
ADVOCATED FOR REGISTRATION
TIMELINES IN STATUTE AND
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THEIR
INCLUSION IN THIS BILL. WE'VE
SEEN THAT IT TAKES, THE TIME IT
HAS TAKEN TO REGISTER NEW
PRODUCTS FOR USE IN THE STATE OR
AMEND EXISTING PRODUCTS HAS
CONTINUALLY INCREASED OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND WE
BELIEVE THESE STATUTORY
TIMELINES WILL DRIVE
IMPROVEMENTS AND PROVIDE MORE
PREDICTABILITY FOR MANUFACTURERS
WHO WANT TO PROVIDE NEW AND
INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO, REGISTERING
NEW PRODUCTS WILL LEAD TO MORE
MILL FEES BEING COLLECTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AND HELPING THEIR
OVERALL FUNDING RESOURCES. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES RELATED TO
REPORTING ON REGISTRATION
TIMELINES, AND BELIEVE THESE
WILL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES HAVE
IMPROVED OPERATIONS AND THEN
LASTLY, 2113 DOES NOT ALLOW DPR
TO RAISE THE MILL IN FUTURE
YEARS AS THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER
BILL PROPOSED THROUGH A
REGULATORY PROCESS, WE STRONGLY
FEEL THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
RETAIN THIS IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION AND ALLOW FOR THESE
ROBUST DISCUSSIONS AGAIN, WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE, BUT IN
RECOGNITION OF THESE KEY PIECES,
WE HAVE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION
TO 2113, AND WE'RE ENCOURAGED BY
THE ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THÀNH ON THIS
BILL AND ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE WILL BE
ACHIEVED TO PROVIDE DPR WITH
NEEDED RESOURCES AND
STAKEHOLDERS WITH NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
TAYLOR, MOTION ON BEHALF OF AN
AGRICULTURAL COALITION THAT'S
RELATIVELY LARGE. OBVIOUSLY, ON
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL, WE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MISS QUINONEZ AND REALLY
OFFER OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF IN FINDING WHAT
IS A VERY CHALLENGING AND
DELICATE BALANCE BETWEEN MANY
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS PROCESS,
BUT THE STARK REALITY IS
CALIFORNIA IS BEHIND. 49 OTHER
STATES HAVE ACCESS TO PRODUCTS
THAT ARE MORE EFFECTIVE, SAFER,
SOFTER THAN WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. VÀ. AND THAT'S
SIMPLY BECAUSE OUR REGISTRATION
SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND THE
APPETITE TO REMOVE PRODUCTS IS
NOT MET WITH THE SAME APPETITE
TO ADD ALTERNATIVES IN THEIR
PLACE. SO EVEN THOUGH THE MILL
IS A TAX ON FARMERS AT A
PARTICULARLY HARD TIME, AT A
TIME WHEN FARMERS CAN'T PASS
THOSE CONSUMER THOSE COSTS DOWN
TO CONSUMERS, WE SEE THIS
PAINFUL INCREASE AS AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FUTURE, AND
IT'S ALSO AN INVESTMENT IN
REEVALUATION, WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND IS IMPORTANT TO
OTHERS AS WELL, SO IN THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS
SOMETHING FOR EVERYONE, IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE, BUT IT DOES HAVE
SOMETHING THAT APPEASES, TO SOME
EXTENT, EVERY STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE WILL MOVE
TO NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, FOLKS WHO WANT
TO COME TO THE MIC TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. OR
WHATEVER. OR COMPLICATED
FEELINGS. PERFECT. THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE AT, JAMIE, ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS, WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR OR THE AUTHOR'S STAFF
, BUT WE TAKE A POSITION OF
SUPPORT WITH AMENDED, AND HOPE
THAT THE AMENDMENTS WILL UTILIZE
MATERIALS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM èC A AND R, AS
WELL AS PROVIDE GREATER BENEFITS
TO FARMERS THAT A PORTION OF THE
MILL FEE GOES TO CDFA FOR THE
BIPS PROGRAM, THE BIOLOGICALLY
INTEGRATED FARMING SYSTEMS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. ABBY
ALVAREZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, THE CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK, THE PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK, CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND ROOTS OF CHANGE
GETTING MUCH CLOSER BUT ALSO
CURRENTLY ALIGNING WITH CPR.
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED POSITION
DENNIS ALBIANI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PEAR GROWERS AND SEVERAL OTHER
AG INTERESTS, WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY NEUTRAL ON THIS
PROPOSAL. THANKS MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS REARDON,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE ALSO
LIKE MR. ALBIANI, ARE NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL. LET ME JUST SAY,
HOWEVER, WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS.
AND WE I CONCUR WITH MISS
QUINONEZ AND MISS ROSHAN ON
THEIR TESTIMONY, BUT I HOPE WE
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT MR.
CHAIR, THOSE OUTSTANDING ISSUES
REGARDING THE WAY WE VIEW IT IS
SORT OF WHAT THAT MILL NUMBER IS
OKAY IN TERMS OF EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. AND THEN SECONDLY
, TIMELINES TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
ENSURE WE GET PRODUCT IN THE
MARKETPLACE TO SORT OF BACKFILL
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD
HISTORICALLY. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS MATTHEW ALLEN
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. WE WOULD ALSO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH MISS ROSHAN
AND MISS QUINONEZ AND APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND STAFF
AND WORKING IN THIS IMPORTANT
AREA. APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
JESSE CUEVAS, ON BEHALF OF THE
TRI CAL GROUP, WE ARE NEUTRAL IF
AMENDED, GENERAL CONCERN IS OVER
THE SIZE OF THE PROPOSAL. WE'D
LIKE TO SEE IT, CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT A MORE
MODEST APPROACH TO INCREASING
THE MILL, BUT APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR INTRODUCING THE BILL AND
HAVING THIS GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY PROCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, AARON NORWOOD. ON
BEHALF OF THE ALMOND ALLIANCE, I
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
MISS ROCHE AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR ON THIS
COMPLICATED ISSUE. AND THERE'S
STILL THINGS WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE, BUT HAPPY TO BE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. TRICIA GERINGER
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. ALSO NEUTRAL.
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU, ARIANA CREDE WITH CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS. ORG ALSO IN
SUPPORT. ALSO IN SUPPORT IS AN
CA AND WE SUPPORT THE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING BRENDA
BASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH MISS ROCHIN. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, VICTOR TORRES
WITH FUTURE LEADERS OF CHANGE
AND IN SUPPORT IN SUPPORT, IF
AMENDED, ALIGNING WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
YANELLI MARTINEZ WITH SAFE SAFE
SCHOOLS AND IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED, ALIGN WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM. THANK YOU.
JONATHAN EVANS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY,
SUPPORTING, IF AMENDED, ALIGNED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PESTICIDE
REFORM, PARTICULARLY REGARDING
THE REEVALUATION PORTION
REEVALUATION OF PESTICIDES LAST
DECADES. CURRENTLY, UNDER DPR,
IT NEEDS TO BE OCCURRING AT A
FASTER RATE. THANK YOU. OKAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS, THOUGHTS
CONCERNS FROM FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE? OKAY. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. YEAH,
THIS IS VERY MUCH A NEGOTIATION
THAT'S UNDERWAY. SO WE'LL TURN
IT OVER TO I JUST HAD A
QUESTION. THE FIRST QUESTION I
HAVE IS SO YOU ARE STILL WORKING
ON AMENDMENTS, GOING TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE OR THERE ARE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE ONGOING.
THERE WERE CONVERSATIONS AS
RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON FINDING SOME
COMMON GROUND ON SOME THINGS
THAT THEY HAD CONCERNS WITH,
SOME THINGS THAT DON'T ALIGN
WITH THEIR BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
AND SO PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
AND, STAKEHOLDERS ARE BEING
ENGAGED AS WELL ALONG THE WAY.
OKAY, IF I MAY, THEN I JUST WANT
TO, AS, AS A FARMER, A FAMILY
FARMER. AND FIRST OF ALL, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR, I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING THIS IN A BILL
AND NOT DOING IT IN A TRAILER
BILL WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. SO I WANT TO PUT
THAT OUT IN THE OPEN FOR FIRST.
AND TO ALL THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
BEEN IN MY OFFICE AND WEIGHED IN
AND, AND HAVE COME TO SOME SORT
OF AN AGREEMENT, WHICH I GUESS
IS GREAT FOR NOW, BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY SOME THINGS THAT I
THINK NEED TO BE SAID, AS
SOMEBODY WHO IS IN THIS INDUSTRY
AND THIS, THIS, THESE FEES AND
REGULATIONS ARE AFFECT MY
BUSINESS VERY MUCH. SO AND SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
OVER THE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
HERE, OVER THE 12 YEARS I'VE
BEEN HERE, THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE SEEN, YOU KNOW, A
NEGOTIATION THAT REALLY, AT THE
END OF THE DAY, IMPACTS FAMILY
FARMS AND THERE ARE A LOT OF,
YOU KNOW, BIG OPERATORS IN THE
STATE THAT CAN ABSORB THAT. AND
THE AND THE HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS
FOLKS CAN ABSORB THAT AND PASS
IT ON. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IN MY IN MY FARM, WE
COMPETE AGAINST FARMS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN CALIFORNIA, WE
HAVE A LOT OF, NOT JUST THIS,
BUT MANY OTHER FACTORS THAT
CAUSE, OUR PRICES TO GO UP AND
OUR COST TO GO UP. AND THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE. AND SO WHAT I SAY
IS, YOU KNOW, WE NEGOTIATE OUR
DEATH EVERY DAY HERE. THAT'S
WHAT WE DO. WE NEVER WIN. WE
NEGOTIATE OUR DEATH. AND SO
WHEN, WHEN THE AGENCIES CAN'T DO
THEIR JOB AND GET IT DONE IN THE
IN THE TIME FRAME THAT WE NEED,
WE JUST TAX MORE PEOPLE AND GIVE
THEM MORE MONEY AND EXPECT
SOMETHING TO HAPPEN DIFFERENT
THAN ACTUALLY GETTING RESULTS.
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
ON THE TABLE. I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY,
BECAUSE I AM DYING FROM A
THOUSAND CUTS, AND SOMEWHERE
THERE HAS TO BE A LINE DRAWN IN
THE SAND THAT SAYS, HEY, WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING TO HELP BUSINESS
STAY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
SPECIFICALLY, FAMILY FARMS. I
KNOW THE FAMILY FARM FOLKS THAT
COME UP AND TESTIFY. I DON'T
KNOW WHO THEY ARE, BUT MY
FAMILY'S BEEN FARMING HERE FOR
93 YEARS, AND WE ARE TRULY A
FAMILY FARM. IT'S MY SONS AND A
FEW EMPLOYEES, AND THAT'S IT.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT
OUT THERE. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO THE AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR AND
ALL OF YOU FOLKS WHO'VE BEEN
WORKING, BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
IT, I'M DYING FROM A THOUSAND
CUTS, AND THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
CUT THAT WILL CAUSE MY FARM, TO
BE LESS COMPETITIVE AGAINST
FARMS FROM MEXICO WHO USE ALL
THESE PRODUCTS, DON'T PAY ANY
AND SHIP THEIR FOOD IN HERE, AND
WE'RE EATING FOOD WITH
PESTICIDES ON THEM. AND WE CAN
TRACE THAT. WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE COMING FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES. SO YOU'RE
PUSHING THE FARMERS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA INTO OTHER PLACES,
AND THEY'RE SHIPPING THEIR FOOD
IN HERE. IT'S NOT AS SAFE AS
WHAT WE CAN DO HERE. SO THERE'S
GOT TO BE SOME OTHER SOLUTION
BESIDES JUST PUSHING US OUT OF
BUSINESS. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS ON THE MR.
VICE CHAIR? NO. YOU KNOW, WE
RESPECTFULLY, YOU KNOW, WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE HIS COMMENTS. HE
SPEAKS FROM A PLACE THAT I DON'T
HAVE A DIRECT, YOU KNOW,
EXPERIENCE, I CAN ONLY JUST SAY
THAT, YOU KNOW, DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION, HAS BEEN
ASKED TO TAKE ON SOME,
RESPONSIBILITIES TO BE MORE
EFFECTIVE, EFFICIENT IN HOW THEY
PROCESS, WHETHER IT BE
APPLICATIONS, WHETHER IT BE HOW
THEY DELIVER THEIR SERVICES. AND
FOR 20 YEARS, YOU KNOW, THEY'VE
BEEN SAYING AND ASKING THAT THE
THEY'VE BEEN LACKING THE
RESOURCES TO DO SO. AND THERE'S
BEEN A UNWILLINGNESS TO MAYBE
DIRECTLY TAKE ON THE ISSUE OF
HOW DO YOU DO THAT? RIGHT. AND
IF THERE HAS BEEN A WILL, IT'S
BEEN AN UNSUCCESSFUL ONE, THUS
FAR. AND I KNOW THAT PARTIES
HAVE COME TOGETHER THIS YEAR.
THANKS TO THE TRAILER BILL THAT
THE GOVERNOR PUT FORWARD, TO TRY
TO FIND SOME COMMON GROUND,
ALBEIT MAYBE NOT A PERFECT
SOLUTION. AND AS YOU MENTIONED
IN THE PRIOR, BILL, LET'S NOT
LET THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF
THE GOOD, WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
BEFORE US THAT THAT HAS ALLOWED
FOR STAKEHOLDERS TO HAVE INPUT.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE LONG LINE OF
NEUTRAL POSITIONS, TO ME, IS A
SIGNAL THAT WE HAVE A REASONABLE
PROPOSAL THUS FAR, TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS,
PERHAPS WE GET TO A CLOSER PLACE
TO FINALIZING THIS PROPOSAL.
YOU'LL COME TO A CONCLUSION THAT
MAYBE THIS IS THE BEST APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS THAT
THE DPR AGENCY AND, AND WE CAN
GARNER YOUR SUPPORT. THAT BEING
SAID, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO, YOU KNOW,
WORK WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY WHO WANT TO REMAIN ENGAGED.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK
OF JOSH AND THE TEAM AT THE SDM
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE BEEN
SPEARHEADING THIS WORK ON ON OUR
BEHALF, ON BEHALF OF THE
INDUSTRY, THE STAKEHOLDERS. WE
NEED TO GET THIS DONE THIS YEAR,
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THE BUDGET
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE DEPARTMENT,
BUT BECAUSE, STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM HAVE AGREED
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM THERE.
AND AND THERE'S A COMMON GROUND
THAT WE HAVE SOME PROPOSAL
BEFORE US THAT CAN SOLVE SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL END THIS BILL WILL
GO TO AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
ASSUMING IT GETS OUT TODAY. SO,
THERE'LL BE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT ON THE ISSUE, AS IT
MOVES ALONG. BUT I'LL CERTAINLY
BE SUPPORTING IT, TODAY. AND
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. AND SO
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE YOUR, YOUR
WORK ON THIS. ALL RIGHT. LET'S
INVITE SOME MEMBER CONNOLLY TO
COME TO THE, TO THE DÍAS. HE'S
HERE TO PRESENT ITEM TEN, WHICH
IS AB 1864. THAT WAS THE DATE OF
THE ABRAHAM LINCOLN'S REELECTION
TODAY, 1864. AND MY BIRTHDAY.
OH, YOUR BIRTHDAY. WELL, THAT'S
MORE THAT'S, YOU KNOW, ALMOST AS
IMPORTANT. ALL RIGHT. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING,
WE'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK AND INPUT ON THIS
BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. CHILDREN
ATTENDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
DAYCARES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
INTENDED TO BE PROTECTED BY A
REGULATION THAT CURRENTLY
RESTRICTS THE MOST DROUGHT PRONE
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS. DURING THE SCHOOL
DAY, FROM 6 A.M. TO 6 P.M,
MONDAY TO FRIDAY. IN PRACTICE,
THIS REGULATION IS OFTEN
UNENFORCEABLE, WHILE NOTICE OF
NOTICES OF INTENT AND WE'LL CALL
THOSE NOISE THIS MORNING MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER BEFORE USING
PESTICIDES CLASSIFIED AS
RESTRICTED MATERIALS, AND MUST
INCLUDE THE METHOD OF
APPLICATION, OFTEN, THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED ISN'T
SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE METHOD
TRIGGERS REGULATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THE APPLICATION
METHOD LISTED ON THE NÓI IS
QUOTE GROUND, IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER THAT MEANS A GROUND RIG
SPRAYER, WHICH HAS A DISTANCE
RESTRICTION OR A HAND PUMP
SPRAYER WHICH DOES NOT FURTHER
THE EXACT LOCATION OF
APPLICATIONS CANNOT BE VERIFIED
UNDER CURRENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND EXACT START AND
END TIMES ARE OFTEN INACCURATELY
REPORTED. AB 1864 SEEKS TO MAKE
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS BY
REQUIRING ANNUAL PERMITS TO
INCLUDE METHOD OF APPLICATION
AND SPECIFIC SITE IDENTIFIER
LOCATION, AND FOR USE REPORTS TO
INCLUDE METHOD AND TIMING OF
APPLICATION TO PROVIDE
CORROBORATION THAT LAWS ARE
ADHERED TO. THIS BILL REQUIRES,
IN ADDITION TO DFARS EXISTING
MATERIALS AND DISTANCE
RESTRICTIONS AND REGULATIONS,
THAT WHEN PESTICIDES CLASSIFIED
BY THE US EPA AS CANCEROUS AND
HARMFUL TO THE REPRODUCTIVE AND
NERVOUS SYSTEMS ARE GOING TO BE
APPLIED USING DRIFT PRONE
METHODS, AGRICULTURAL BUSINESSES
MUST PROVIDE NOTICE IN ADVANCE
THE APPLICATION METHODS
RESTRICTED BY THIS BILL AND BY
CURRENT DPR REGULATIONS ARE
AIRCRAFT AIR BLAST SPRAYERS,
SPRINKLER KAMLAGER, CHEMIGATION
EQUIPMENT AND FUMIGANTS. THE
DANGERS OF PESTICIDE EXPOSURE
AND PESTICIDE DRIFT ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED. TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT, PESTICIDE EXPOSURE IS
LINKED TO A WIDE RANGE OF HEALTH
HARMS, INCLUDING CANCER, AUTISM,
ASTHMA, ADHD, BRAIN TUMORS AND
MORE. THE NATIONAL PESTICIDE
INFORMATION CENTER AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
RECOGNIZED CHILDREN ARE MORE
SENSITIVE TO THE EFFECTS OF
PESTICIDES EXPOSURE THAN ADULTS,
A STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
NATIONAL LIBRARY OF MEDICINE
RECOGNIZES PESTICIDES ARE KNOWN
TO HAVE DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECTS
ON BLACK, INDIGENOUS, AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR AS WELL AS COMMUNITIES
OF LOW INCOME AND WEALTH. THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE, NARROWLY
TAILORED BILL THAT SEEKS TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
AWARENESS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND DOES NOT BAN THE
APPLICATION OF PESTICIDES.
FINALLY, AB 1864 ALSO ENSURES
EQUITY BY EXTENDING THE SAME
PROTECTIONS TO CHILDREN,
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF IN
PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND DAYCARES ARE ALREADY
AFFORDED. SO I'LL NOW PASS IT
OFF TO MY TWO WITNESSES, JANE
SELLIN, CO DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM, AND VICTOR TORRES,
REPRESENTING FUTURE LEADERS OF
CHANGE. JANE, THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JANE STEELE AND
CO-DIRECTOR OF THE STATEWIDE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM. I THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP FOR AUTHORING AB
1864, WHICH IS A CRITICAL STEP
TOWARD ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTED FROM AGRICULTURAL
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE AT SCHOOL.
THIS BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE IN
THE SIX YEARS SINCE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION IMPLEMENTED
RESTRICTIONS ON CERTAIN
PESTICIDE APPLICATION METHODS
NEXT TO SCHOOLS DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY, GROUND TRUTHING BY
OUR COALITION HAS REVEALED SOME
SERIOUS ISSUES WITH
ENFORCEABILITY. THOSE ISSUES CAN
BE ADDRESSED BY SIMPLE REPORTING
CHANGES. PESTICIDE EXPOSURE AT
SCHOOL IS A SERIOUS AND
UNDERREPORTED ISSUE, AS YOU WILL
HEAR FROM CO-SPONSOR VICTOR
TORRES, EVEN AN ACUTE ILLNESS AT
SCHOOL THAT WAS REPORTED AND
RESULTED IN A HOSPITAL VISIT WAS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE STATE
PESTICIDE ILLNESS DATABASE, AND
WE BROUGHT COPIES OF THAT REPORT
AND HOSPITALIZED ASIAN. GLAD TO
SHARE. WE KNOW THAT CHRONIC
EXPOSURE IS AN ISSUE AT SCHOOLS
BECAUSE DFE'S OWN AIR MONITORING
NETWORK CONFIRMS THE PRESENCE OF
MULTIPLE PESTICIDES IN THE AIR
AT EACH OF ITS MONITORING
STATIONS, MOST OF WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN SCHOOLS. INDUSTRY HAS
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN OF
NOTIFYING THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSION BEFORE APPLYING
PESTICIDES KNOWN TO CAUSE CANCER
, REPRODUCTIVE OR NERVOUS SYSTEM
HARM. NEXT TO SCHOOLS USING
USING AERIAL, AIR BLAST OR OTHER
HIGHLY DRIFT PRONE METHODS.
CITING THE SHEER NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS INVOLVED. THIS
CONCERN SPEAKS TO THE ALARMING
SCALE OF EXPOSURE SUFFERED BY
RURAL CHILDREN EVERY DAY. AND TO
BE CLEAR, THIS PROVISION IMPOSES
NO RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF
THESE CHEMICALS BUT ENHANCES THE
ABILITY OF AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS TO ENSURE THAT
APPLICATIONS ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REGULATION BEFORE THEY
HAPPEN. INDUSTRY ALSO CLAIMS
THAT THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD
AFFECT HUNDREDS OF ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS. IN FACT, THE BILL
ADDS ONLY 54 HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS
OUT OF OVER 1000 REGISTERED FOR
USE IN CALIFORNIA. ONLY WHEN
USED NEAR SCHOOLS, ONLY WHEN
USED IN THE MOST DRIFT PRONE
APPLICATION METHODS. INDUSTRY
HAS VOICED CONCERN ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL COST AND WORKLOAD OF
IDENTIFYING PRIVATE SCHOOLS. WE
BELIEVE THE NUMBER OF IMPACTED
PRIVATE SCHOOLS IS SMALL, AND
CDE HAS STATED THAT THEY WILL
PROVIDE SCHOOL ADDRESSES AT NO
COST, WHICH CAN THEN BE
INCORPORATED INTO THE EXISTING
GIS MAPPING CONTRACT USED TO
LOCATE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
DAYCARES. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'LL PASS ON MY
TESTIMONY. 54 GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS VICTOR
TORRES AND I AM 17 YEARS OLD AND
A NEW GRADUATE OF GREENFIELD
HIGH SCHOOL IN MY HOMETOWN IN
THE HEART OF THE SALINAS VALLEY.
GREENFIELD I AM A CO-FOUNDER AND
THE SALINAS VALLEY. SORRY. I AM
A CO-FOUNDER OF FUTURE LEADERS
OF CHANGE BASED IN GREENFIELD
AND WATSONVILLE. I AM HERE TODAY
TO BRING AWARENESS ABOUT THE
DANGER OF PESTICIDE APPLICATION
NEAR OUR SCHOOLS. I MYSELF WAS A
VICTIM OF PESTICIDE DRIFT AT THE
AGE OF TEN AT MY LOCAL MIDDLE
SCHOOL. NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THEIR HEALTH IN A
PLACE OF LEARNING. NO CHILD
SHOULD HAVE TO BE RUSHED TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM FOR SOMETHING OUT
OF THEIR CONTROL. WE NEED BETTER
PROTECTIONS AROUND SCHOOLS, BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO KNOW THE
EXACT LOCATION OF EACH OF THE
PESTICIDE APPLICATION, HOW THE
PESTICIDES ARE APPLIED, AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THAT EVERY NOTICE
OF INTENT OR NOI BROUGHT TO
COMMISSIONERS IS EXAMINED
THOROUGHLY BEFORE APPROVAL. THIS
WOULD IN FACT, GUARANTEE THAT NO
OTHER TEN YEAR OLD HAS TO
EXPERIENCE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HAVING SUCH DANGEROUS CHEMICALS
APPLIED NEAR THEIR SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE MANY HAZARDOUS
PESTICIDES THAT ARE NOT
CLASSIFIED AS RESTRICTED
MATERIALS, AND SO CURRENTLY NO
NÓI IS REQUIRED. WHEN I WAS A
VICTIM OF PESTICIDE DRIFT, THERE
WERE EIGHT DIFFERENT PESTICIDES
INVOLVED AND NOT ONE OF THEM WAS
RESTRICTED. EVEN THOUGH FOUR OF
THE EIGHT ARE KNOWN TO TRIGGER
ASTHMA. ANOTHER OF THE EIGHT
ALSO RESTRICTED WAS DACTYL OR
DCPA. THE US EPA NOW SAYS
ALLOWABLE LEVELS OF DCPA ARE
1500 TIMES MORE HARMFUL TO
DEVELOPING BRAINS THAN IS
CONSIDERED SAFE. HALF OF ALL
DCPA USE IN CALIFORNIA IS IN MY
COUNTY, MONTEREY COUNTY. THERE
ARE 29 GROWERS WHO PLAN TO APPLY
DCPA WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF 65
SCHOOLS IN MONTEREY COUNTY IN
THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR. WE ARE
THE FUTURE LEADERS OF CHANGE IN
THE COMMUNITY, AND I ASK YOU ALL
TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO US
TO NOT ONLY LEARN, MEET WITH
PEERS, BUT TO ALSO ENJOY OUR
CHILDHOOD IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON WHAT I ASSUME
IS YOUR FIRST TESTIMONY HERE
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE. IS THAT
OR MAYBE NOT, THIS IS MY THIRD
TIME HERE. WOW. WOW. ALL RIGHT,
WELL, YOU'RE A YOU'RE A PRO NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO WANT
TO WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS, MATT
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, ABBY ALVAREZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, THE CALIFORNIA FOOD AND
FARMING NETWORK, THE PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK, THE CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM AND CLEAN
WATER ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS ISABEL
RAMIREZ, AND I SUPPORT AB 1864.
THANKS MORNING, NOEMI. CHICO I'M
A PARENT AND EDUCATOR AND MEMBER
OF SAFE ACT SAFE SCHOOLS AND
SUPPORT OF AB 1864. GOOD
MORNING, JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA
CLUB, CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NANCY BIERMAIER,
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MARIANA CREED WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS. ORG AND SUPPORT. ALSO
THOSE IN SUPPORT ARE NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND CA
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO FACTS BEYOND
PESTICIDES, YARDS, MARTIN MARIN
AND MOMS ADVOCATING FOR
SUSTAINABILITY. THANK YOU BILL.
ALSO, ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP SUPPORTS LIZ TORRES, ABE
CUATRO GRACIAS, MÁS MARTINEZ
WITH SAFE ACT SAFE SCHOOLS.
GREENFIELD CITY COUNCILWOMAN IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB 1864. ALL
RIGHT. MELISSA ROMERO,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, EVERYBODY,
LET'S HEAR FROM OPPOSITION FOLKS
WHO WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS. COME
ON UP. YOU CAN SIT IN THE FRONT
TERM. APOLOGIES. I MIGHT BE UP
HERE QUITE A BIT. THIS THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING, TAYLOR ON
BEHALF OF A COALITION OF
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS, WE'D
LIKE TO THANK STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH ANALYSIS. AND TO THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS AVAILABILITY TO
HEAR OUR CONCERNS. AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY, BUT UNFORTUNATELY, WE
ARE OPPOSED AT THIS TIME. 1864
REQUIRES A GROWER TO SUBMIT A
NOTICE OF INTENT TO THEIR COUNTY
AG COMMISSIONER IN ADVANCE OF AN
APPLICATION OF A PROPOSITION 65
LISTED PRODUCT USING CERTAIN
METHODS WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF
A SCHOOL ZONE. THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC TO OUR COALITION FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE STRICTEST PESTICIDE LAWS
IN THE NATION, AND HAS UNIQUE,
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS ON USE
NEAR SCHOOLS. EVERY APRIL,
GROWERS WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF
A RADIUS OF A SCHOOL GIVE A
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION A LIST OF
PRODUCTS THEY MAY APPLY THAT
YEAR, AS WELL AS THE AG
COMMISSIONER. THE LAW PROHIBITS
FARMERS FROM USING CERTAIN
METHODS OF APPLICATIONS AND
PESTICIDES BETWEEN 6 A.M. TO 6
P.M, MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY, OR
ANY TIME CHILDREN ARE PRESENT.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THESE LAWS THAT
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A SINGLE
DOCUMENTED INSTANCE OF
AGRICULTURAL RELATED PESTICIDE
EXPOSURE TO SCHOOL CHILDREN
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
REGULATIONS. THAT'S NOT OUR
DATA. THAT'S DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION, AND MANDATED
REPORTERS AND MANDATED REPORTERS
INCLUDE ER, DOCTORS, TEACHERS,
PEDIATRICIANS. IF UNDERREPORTING
HERE IS THE ISSUE. THE BILL DOES
NOT RECTIFY THAT. IRONICALLY,
WHERE PESTICIDE ILLNESSES OF
SCHOOLCHILDREN HAVE BEEN
REPEATEDLY FOUND IS ON CAMPUS
WHEN THEY'RE USED BY UNTRAINED
PEOPLE WITHOUT OVERSIGHT. SO
IT'S CONCERNING TO US THAT AB
1864 IS BASED ON THE PREMISE
THAT AG PESTICIDE EXPOSURE TO
CHILDREN IS RAMPANT AND
UNREGULATED. THE BILL'S ALSO
PREDICATED ON THE PREMISE THAT
PROP 65 LISTED PRODUCTS, WHICH
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
NOTIFICATION, ARE SERIOUS
THREATS TO OUR CHILDREN. THE
ANALYSIS DOES AN EXCELLENT JOB
HIGHLIGHTING THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN HAZARD, WHICH IS THE
BASIS FOR PROP 65, AND RISK,
WHICH IS DFE'S BASIS FOR
PESTICIDE ENFORCEMENT. HAZARD IS
THE POTENTIAL FOR SOMETHING TO
HARM YOU, BUT RISK IS THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THAT HAZARD
ACTUALLY CAUSING HARM. RISK IS
THE BASIS OF OUR REGULATORY
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S THE
SAME CRITERIA THAT WE USE FOR
AIR QUALITY AND WATER QUALITY.
SEA LEVEL RISE RISK LETS US
DRIVE OUR CAR TO WORK EVERY
MORNING AND DRINK COFFEE
PESTICIDAL PRODUCTS THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE A KNOWN RISK ARE
KNOWN AS RESTRICTED USE
MATERIALS, WHICH DO REQUIRE
NOTICE OF INTENT TO BE FILED
WITH AN AG COMMISSIONER. WE
BELIEVE 1864 APPLYING THE SAME
PARADIGM OVER NEW PRODUCTS,
OBLIGATE UNNECESSARY WORK ON
FARMERS USING THE SAME PRODUCTS
THAT A QUARTER MILE AWAY THAT
HOMEOWNERS ARE USING RIGHT NEXT
DOOR OR GROUNDSKEEPERS ARE
USING, OR TEACHERS ARE USING ON
CAMPUS IN SHORT, OUR COALITION
OBJECTS TO NEW PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT DON'T CAUSE AN
ACTUAL RISK WITHOUT DATA TO
SUPPORT THAT. BUT WE DO AGREE
THAT USE REPORTING CAN BE
IMPROVED AND THAT DATA CAN BE
IMPROVED FOR THE NOTICE OF
INTENT REQUIREMENT FOR
RESTRICTED USE PRODUCT,
INCLUDING SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM ON
THAT PORTION OF THE BILL. AND
WHILE WE DON'T AGREE WITH THE
SPONSORS ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS, WE THINK
GREATER INFORMATION SHARING IN
TERMS OF NOTICES OF INTENT FOR
RESTRICTED USE MATERIALS CAN
CORROBORATE THAT THE REGULATIONS
ARE BEING PROPERLY ENFORCED. SO
FOR THESE REASONS, WE'RE OPPOSED
. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC. I'M STEVE SCHERER, YUBA
COUNTY AG COMMISSIONER. I ALSO
SERVE AS THE PESTICIDE
REGULATORY AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR THE CALIFORNIA AG
COMMISSIONER'S ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING OUR 55 COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONERS AND THEIR WORK
PROTECTING PEOPLE AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AB 1864 SIMPLY
CREATES EXTRA PAPERWORK FOR
GROWERS AND COUNTY ENFORCEMENT
STAFF AND DOES NOT FURTHER
PROTECT OUR SCHOOLCHILDREN,
SCHOOLS, CHILDREN OR OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE MAIN EMPHASIS
OF THIS BILL IS TO REQUIRE A
NOTICE OF INTENT FOR MATERIALS
THAT ARE ALREADY PROHIBITED TO
BE APPLIED DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
UNDER THE CURRENT REGULATIONS.
THEREFORE, THE ULTIMATE OUTCOME
OF THE PROVISION IS SIMPLY
INCREASED PAPERWORK, BOTH FOR
THE GROWER AND FOR MY
ENFORCEMENT STAFF. ALL OUR
ENFORCEMENT STAFF THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FOR APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY HEAVILY RESTRICTED AND
MUST OCCUR OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
HOURS, AS DISCUSSED EARLIER, IT
ISN'T JUST A MATTER OF MORE WORK
FOR OUR STAFF IN THE FIELD. IT'S
THE MATTER OF DOING THE RIGHT
WORK AND HAVING MY STAFF IN THE
OFFICE REVIEWING THIS PAPERWORK
TAKES THEM OUT OF THE FIELD TO
DO ENFORCEMENT WORK. WHERE
THAT'S REALLY THE IMPORTANT PART
WHERE WE'RE PROTECTING THE
VULNERABLE PORTIONS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, SPECIFICALLY
SCHOOLS. FROM THE INTRODUCTION
OF THIS BILL, WE'VE ASKED FOR
DATA TO SUPPORT THE SPONSOR'S
CLAIM OF HUNDREDS OF VIOLATIONS
OF THE CURRENT REGULATIONS, WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THAT TO DATE.
OUR INSPECTION DATA FROM THE AG
COMMISSIONER'S INCLUDES 30,000
INSPECTIONS BY OVER 500
INSPECTORS STATEWIDE. AND WE
HAVE NOT BEEN NOTING THOSE
VIOLATIONS OUT IN THE FIELD, WE
DO NOT HAVE DATA TO SUBSTANTIATE
THE CLAIMS MADE BY THE SPONSORS
OR PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL, NOR
HAVE WE RECEIVED DATA TO
CORROBORATE CLAIMS TO THE
CONTRARY. IN CONCLUSION, WHILE
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
PRIORITIZE AND PROTECT SCHOOLS
AND CHILDREN, IN ALL THE BILL
ACTUALLY DOES IS BURY LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT STAFF AND PAPERWORK
AND PLACE ADDITIONAL
RESTRICTIONS ON GROWERS WHO ARE
ALREADY COMPLYING WITH THE
STRICTEST REGULATIONS IN THESE
SENSITIVE LOCATIONS. IT REMOVES
OUR INSPECTORS FROM THE FIELD
AND TASKS LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO FOOT THE BILL,
ALL WHILE NOT INCREASING THE
SAFETY TO OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN,
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE REALISTIC
IN YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL AND OPPOSE THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, FOLKS, YOU WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS OR VOICE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IF THEY CAN COME TO THE
MIC AND EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
. GOOD MORNING, JOHN MOFFATT ON
BEHALF OF THE MILK PRODUCERS
COUNCIL WITH OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS. WE ALSO ARE OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED ON THE BILL.
MARGIE LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, BRENDA
BASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE OPPOSED, UNLESS
AMENDED. DENNIS ALBIANI, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION PARA GROWERS,
SEVERAL OTHER AGRICULTURAL
INTERESTS WE OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS CHRIS REARDON,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE WITH THE AUTHOR,
BOTH IN THE LAST HOUSE AND HERE
TODAY. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
BILL AS WELL. BUT WE'RE, OPPOSED
UNLESS IT WAS AMENDED. MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, TRICIA GERINGER
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANKS ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL BRING THE BILL BACK
TO COMMITTEE, JUST IF THE BILL
DOES GET OUT TODAY, IT'S GOING
TO GO TO THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE, WHERE I KNOW THERE'LL
BE A ROBUST DISCUSSION OF A LOT
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION. BUT
WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO HAVE IT
HERE, TOO. SO, MR. VICE CHAIR.
WELL, THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SO I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS. THERE'S BEEN SOME,
OBVIOUSLY SOME FIRST OF ALL, I
WANT TO THANK THE AG
COMMISSIONERS FOR FINALLY COMING
TO THE COMMITTEE. I SO I HAVE A
APPLICATORS PERMIT IN MY FARM
OPERATION. I WORK WITH MY AG
COMMISSIONER EVERY DAY WITH
NOTICE OF INTENT. WE HAVE A
CONTINUING TRAINING. THERE'S A
LOT GOES ON IN THIS SPACE. AND
THANK GOD I DON'T HAVE A SCHOOL
WITHIN A QUARTER OF A MILE OF MY
FIELD. BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID,
I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
SHOWING UP. I DID GET RECEIVE A
LETTER FROM MY AG COMMISSIONER
COALITION SAYING HOW MUCH WORK
IS GETTING PUSHED DOWN ON THEM
FROM REGULATIONS THAT COME FROM
THE STATE, AND IT IS A DIFFICULT
JOB. SO THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
WITNESSES EXPERIENCE AND WHAT'S
BEEN REPORTED, BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY THE CRUX OF THIS
BILL. AND THEN I WANT TO ALSO
TALK ABOUT THE PROP 65, SPACE
THAT WE BOTH TALKED IN. SO MAYBE
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL COULD
TALK ABOUT, THE EXPERIENCE WHERE
YOU HAD SOME SOMEBODY GOT SICK,
BUT THERE'S NO OBVIOUS REPORTING
OF THAT. SO WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING
ON THERE, SO VICTOR WAS THE. I
DON'T CARE WHO ANSWERS IT. I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN
ANSWER BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN I.
I'D BE HAPPY TO, WITH ALL
RESPECT, PUSH BACK ON A LOT OF
THE TEXT. YEAH, WELL, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THAT HOPEFULLY IF
THE CHAIR ALLOWS WE WILL HAVE
THAT. THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE
HEAR FROM OUR WITNESSES FIRST.
SO I COULDN'T TELL YOU WHY THIS
THIS DRIFT INCIDENT IS NOT
REPORTED IN THE PESTICIDE
ILLNESS DATABASE. BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT'S THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG AND THAT PEOPLE,
CHILDREN THAT ATTEND RURAL
SCHOOLS CAN TESTIFY THAT THERE
ARE FREQUENTLY THEY ARE
FREQUENTLY EXPOSED TO
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDES DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY, JUST RECENTLY AT
MODESTO CHRISTIAN SCHOOL, 25
KIDS WERE TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF A PESTICIDE DRIFT
THAT WAS NOT ON CAMPUS. IT WAS
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDE USE.
THAT'S A PRIVATE SCHOOL NOT
PROTECTED BY THIS REGULATION.
THIS BILL WILL CHANGE THAT AT
LEAST. AND AS I SAY, WE BROUGHT
THE REPORTS FROM VICTOR'S DRIFT
INCIDENT. HIS PARENTS DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT. THEY WENT TO
THE AG COMMISSIONER. IT WAS
INVESTIGATED. HE WENT TO THE
E.R, HE WAS HAVING A FULL BLOWN
ASTHMA ATTACK THAT COULD HAVE
KILLED HIM. AND IT WAS DUE TO
EXPOSURE TO PESTICIDES ON CAMPUS
USED IN AGRICULTURAL FIELDS
NEARBY. OKAY. NOW TO THE
OPPOSITE. WELL, I'D LIKE TO SAY
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
DOING A USING MAYBE A SPRAY RIG
TO SPRAY ALTERNATIVE PRODUCTS,
NOT PESTICIDES LIKE WATER.
SOMETIMES THAT'S MISINTERPRETED
AS A PESTICIDE INCIDENT. I CAN'T
SPEAK TO VICTOR'S CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT EVERY
TEACHER, EVERY E.R. DOCTOR,
EVERY EMT, EVERY PEDIATRICIAN,
E.R. DOCTORS ARE ALL MANDATED
REPORTERS FOR PESTICIDE ILLNESS.
SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHY YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCE WASN'T PROPERLY
REPORTED. BUT I WANT TO
REITERATE, NOTHING IN THIS BILL
FIXES THAT PROBLEM. THIS DOESN'T
BETTER EDUCATE MANDATED
REPORTERS ON WHAT THEIR
STANDARDS ARE. IT DOESN'T AUDIT
THE PESTICIDE ILLNESS AND INJURY
REPORTING SYSTEM THAT'S IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS WHAT THE
DATA DPR USES TO DERIVE TO
CREATE THESE REPORTS. SO
NOTICING DOES NOTHING FOR OUR AG
COMMISSIONERS TO ENFORCE WHEN
VIOLATIONS MAY BE PRESENT. AND I
THINK THAT'S OUR CONCERN. YEAH.
SO AS TAYLOR SAID, EVERY TIME
SOMEONE GOES TO THE DOCTOR AND
SAYS THEY HAD A PESTICIDE
RELATED EXPOSURE OR ILLNESS, IT
IS REPORT IF THEY'RE MANDATED TO
REPORT THAT TO THE PEST
DEPARTMENT, OUTSIDE REGULATION.
AND AS A AG COMMISSIONER, IF
THAT HAPPENED IN MY COUNTY, I
INVESTIGATE THAT EVERY ONE OF
THOSE IT COULD BE A HOUSEHOLD
BLEACH, WHICH IS ALSO A
PESTICIDE. RIGHT. TO A CHILD. WE
INVESTIGATE THOSE AS WELL AS
ANY. SO, MR. TORRES'S ILLNESS
HAPPENED BEFORE OUR CURRENT
REGULATE PESTICIDE USE NEAR
SCHOOLS. REGULATION WAS IN
PLACE, THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR
ABOUT SIX YEARS, RIGHT? EIGHT
YEARS. SO ANYWAY, HIS HAPPENED
BEFORE OUR CURRENT REGULATIONS
AND BEING AG COMMISSIONER BEFORE
THAT, WE ALREADY LOCALLY
RESTRICTED APPLICATIONS AROUND
SCHOOLS. SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, IF IT WAS HAPPENING
WE WOULD BE HEARING ABOUT IT. I
PERSONALLY WOULD KNOW ABOUT IT,
OR MY COLLEAGUES IN ANOTHER
COUNTY WOULD KNOW THAT THERE WAS
A DRIFT OUT OF SCHOOL, AND IT
WOULD PROBABLY MAKE THE LOCAL
PAPERS. AND AS WE KNOW, IT'S NOT
MAKING LOCAL PAPERS. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SAID THAT YOU
WANTED TO I'D LIKE TO GET THE
CRUX OF IT. SO WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY
NO DATA THAT SAYS THIS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED. NO DOCTOR SAID THIS
WAS A PESTICIDE DRIFT. THIS WAS
PESTICIDE. YEAH. MAY I MAY I
SHARE THE REPORT? SORRY. WHO'S
IT FROM THOUGH? THIS. THIS IS
THE AG COMMISSIONER'S REPORT
FROM VICTOR'S INCIDENT, WHICH
WAS BEFORE THE REGULATION BUT IS
NOT IN THE PESTICIDE ILLNESS
DATABASE. SO THE PROBLEM IS THEN
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THIS BILL
CHANGE THAT THIS THIS BILL? I
MEAN, IT'S NOT GOING TO RESTRICT
USE. NO, IT'S NOT GOING TO
RESTRICT IT IN ANY WAY. BUT IT
WILL ALLOW AG COMMISSIONERS TO
KNOW BEFORE ONE OF THESE
PESTICIDES IS GOING TO BE USED
RATHER THAN AFTER, SO THAT THEY
CAN DEPLOY INSPECTION TEAMS AS
APPROPRIATE NEXT TO SCHOOLS
WHICH ARE HIGHLY VULNERABLE
SITE. WOULD THE SERGEANT BE
WILLING TO HAND THIS OUT TO
MEMBERS? THANK YOU SO MUCH. YEAH
SO LET ME JUMP IN. AND I TOO,
APPRECIATE KIND OF THE
DISCUSSION THAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON ON THIS BILL. THERE ACTUALLY
HAS BEEN A LOT OF AGREEMENT
AROUND IT. SO LET'S SET THE
CONTEXT, NUMBER ONE, WE HAVE
AGREEMENT FROM THE INDUSTRY Kò
THAT THERE SHOULD BE MORE
SPECIFICITY AROUND
NOTIFICATIONS, AS TO TYPE OF USE
AND, AND, AND WHATNOT. SO
SECONDLY, I THINK WE DO HAVE
AGREEMENT. NOW LET'S APPLY THIS
TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS WITH ADEQUATE
NOTIFICATION TO FARMERS ABOUT
WHERE THOSE PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE.
SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THE, KIND OF WHAT IS
SUBJECT TO THE NÓI REQUIREMENT
AT THIS POINT, I WOULD PUSH BACK
ON ANALOGIZING THESE LARGE SCALE
SPRAY METHODS, WHICH CREATE
AERIAL RISKS TO SOMEONE, A
NEIGHBOR NEARBY SPRAYING THEIR
LAWN. FRANKLY, I WOULD ALSO PUSH
BACK, AS I DID IN AN EARLIER
HEARING, ON THE MAIN DEFENSE
SEEMS TO BE THE PAPERWORK BURDEN
THAT IS UNPERSUASIVE IN THE FACE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH RISK. HERE WE
DO HAVE DOCUMENTATION. I WAS
SURPRISED TO HEAR THE TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING THAT, SOME SORT OF
REQUEST HAS BEEN MADE THAT WE
HAVE NOT COMPLIED WITH, I
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE KNOWLEDGE
OF THAT, SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS THERE'S A SET
OF RESTRICTED, TOXINS RIGHT NOW.
AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
EXPANDING THAT, TO FAIRLY
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES, IDENTIFY BY
THE US EPA AS CARCINOGENS, AS,
AS MISS CELAN TESTIFIED, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT APPROXIMATELY 54
NEW, TOXINS HERE, WE'RE
CONTINUING THIS WILL GO TO THE
AG COMMITTEE. WE'RE CONTINUING
THE DISCUSSIONS, INCLUDING ONE
OF YOUR COUNTERPARTS, IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHO'S WORKING WITH US,
WE'RE BETTER UNDERSTANDING THE
CONCERNS, AND WE COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS THIS HOPEFULLY
MOVES FORWARD TO THE AG
COMMITTEE AS WELL. SO IF WE CAN
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME, WE'D BE HAPPY TO.
OKAY. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. SO THE INCIDENT
FOR I BELIEVE IT'S VICTOR WAS
BEFORE THE REGULATIONS WERE PUT
INTO PLACE, SO THAT AT THIS
POINT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN. WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD KNOW WHERE
WE'RE AT OR WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
GOOD REPORTING NUMBER. THOSE TWO
THINGS IT SHOULDN'T. BUT AND
WITH THE REPORTING FIXES, I
THINK IT WON'T, YEAH. THE OTHER
THE OTHER QUESTION WAS ABOUT,
PROP 65 OR WHAT'S BEEN ADDED. SO
I'D LIKE TO GET A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION ON WHAT IS IN
THOSE. WHAT IS WHERE'S THAT AT?
BECAUSE THAT'S CRITICAL TO
KNOWING WHERE THE ACTUAL
INCIDENTS COMING FROM. SO YEAH,
GO AHEAD. THE CHAIR'S
PERMISSION, WHILE IT IS 54
ACTIVE INGREDIENTS, EACH ACTIVE
INGREDIENT IS FORMULATED INTO
TENS OR HUNDREDS OF PRODUCTS. SO
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THOUSANDS
OF NEW PRODUCTS THAT WE ARE
REQUIRING A FARMER TO PUT A
NOTICE OF INTENT IN 24 TO 48
HOURS IN ADVANCE FOR THE SAME
EXACT PRODUCT THAT'S BEING
APPLIED ON CAMPUS OR RIGHT NEXT
TO CAMPUS. I THINK, ONCE AGAIN,
I'LL GO BACK TO THE COMMENTARY
THAT PROPOSITION 65 IS A HAZARD
CATEGORIZATION DPR USES THAT
HAZARD CATEGORY AND THEN APPLIES
LABEL RESTRICTIONS LIKE USE
RESTRICTIONS, PPE, TIMES OF
DAYS. THAT APPLICATION CAN
HAPPEN. SO IT'S RISK OR I'M
SORRY IT'S HAZARD PLUS EXPOSURE
EQUALS ACTUAL RISK. SOMETHING
LIKE THAT'S DESIGNATED AS A
CARCINOGEN BY US EPA I COULD
HAVE IT'S POTENTIALLY IT'S A
CARCINOGEN. I'D HAVE TO DOUSE
MYSELF IN THAT PRODUCT TEN HOURS
A DAY, EVERY DAY FOR 60 YEARS TO
HAVE A POTENTIAL RISK OF CANCER
EXPOSURE. EVERY PRODUCT HAS
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EXPOSURES.
REALISTICALLY AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHERE THIS IS A PARADIGM
SHIFT OF THE REGULATORY SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND NATURAL RESOURCE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION FROM A
RISK BASED APPROACH, WHICH
CONSIDERS CONTEXT TO A HAZARD
BASED APPROACH, WHICH DOES NOT,
WHICH IS REALLY THE BASIS OF
WHAT OUR OPPOSITION IS ABOUT IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MAY I MAY
I JUST RESPOND ABOUT THE HAZARD
VERSUS RISK? THE BILL DOES
ADDRESS RISK AS WELL BECAUSE IT
ONLY WOULD REQUIRE AN NÓI WHEN
APPLIED NEXT TO A VULNERABLE
SITE, A SCHOOL WITH THE MOST
RAFEAL METHODS, AERIAL AIR BLAST
THAT THOSE KIND OF METHODS. SO
YOU TAKE A HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL
AND YOU USE IT IN A RISKY WAY.
SO AND IT DOESN'T RESTRICT IN
ANY WAY. IT JUST REQUIRES NOTICE
TO THE AG COMMISSIONER THAT
THAT'S ALL. WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THE ARGUMENT THAT THAT THESE
PESTICIDES CAN BE USED BY THE
SCHOOL ITSELF WITHOUT ANY NOTICE
TO THE WELL, THEY'RE NOT
SPRAYING THEM FROM AN AIRPLANE.
THAT WOULD BE ONE THING, THEY'RE
NOT AIR BLASTING THEM. THEY TEND
TO BE SPOT TREATMENTS, I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY'RE THE EXACT SAME.
IF ALL OF THESE CHEMICALS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE USED ON
CAMPUS, I KIND OF DOUBT IT AND
ACTUALLY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT, WHICH
REQUIRES NOTICE IN ADVANCE TO
PARENTS BEFORE THEY USED, SO IT
IS IT IS A PRETTY DIFFERENT
SITUATION. OKAY. IF I MAY JUST I
WANT TO MAKE A LAST COMMENT JUST
SO I WON'T BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK IN THIS AREA. I
ACTUALLY HAVE A APPLICATORS
PERMIT. I DO THIS AND I'VE BEEN
VERY FRUSTRATED AND I'VE BEEN ON
EC FOR EVER THE WHOLE TIME I'VE
BEEN HERE. I USED TO LOVE THIS
COMMITTEE, BUT I'M NOT LIKING IT
MUCH TODAY FOR SURE. BUT HERE'S
THE DEAL. AT THE END OF THE DAY.
SO WE I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ANYBODY GET SICK. WE HAVE TO DO
OUR NÓI. AND THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF RESTRICTIONS. WHAT HOW MUCH
AIR MOVEMENT IS THERE? THERE'S A
WINDOW OF TIME THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY APPLY. AND THAT WINDOW
GETS NARROWER AND NARROWER AND
NARROWER. AND PRETTY SOON YOU'RE
OUT OF TIME AS YOUR CROPS
GETTING DESTROYED BY APHID OR
SOMETHING. RIGHT. SO IT IS HARD,
VERY HARD AT THE SAME TIME, WE
HAVE THE CUSTODIAN AT THE SCHOOL
GOING OUT, BUYING OVER THE
COUNTER ROUNDUP AND JUST GOING
AND DOING IT. AND THERE'S NOBODY
NO RESTRICTION FOR THEM AT ALL.
THERE'S NO TIMING, THERE'S NO
ANYTHING. SO IT'S BEEN A VERY I
THINK IT'S MORE TARGETED TOWARDS
THE PERSON WHO'S TRYING TO DO IT
RIGHT, WHO'S REALLY REGULATED.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, I HAVE MY
AG COMMISSIONER WHO IS, IS, DOES
ALL KINDS OF TASK AND IS
REQUIRED TO WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
FIT IN THOSE WINDOWS AND THEY'RE
AND THEY'RE ALSO TRYING TO GO
OUT AND MONITOR AT THE SAME
TIME. SO WHEN YOU WHEN YOU PUSH
BACK ON THE PAPERWORK, LOOK
THERE OVERLOADED BECAUSE WE PASS
A LOT OF LAWS HERE THAT THEY
HAVE TO GO DO IT. AND WE DON'T
GIVE THEM ANY MORE MONEY TO GO
DO IT. WE DON'T GIVE THEM ANY
MORE STAFF, WE JUST PUSH IT ON
TO THEM. SO THEY'VE ACTUALLY
WRITTEN A LETTER PUSHING BACK TO
DPR AND DSC. FINALLY, I'M HAPPY
FOR THEM BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
BURNING THEM AND SOMETIMES YOU
CAN'T GET THE JOB DONE. THEN
WE'RE GOING TO END UP WITH
SOMETHING REALLY BAD HAPPENING.
SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL. I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT OF
WORK IN THIS AREA, AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
PRODUCER IS ALWAYS ON THE HOOK.
HE'S SOMEBODY WE CAN REGULATE,
WE SOMEBODY WE CAN FIND,
SOMEBODY WE CAN TARGET, BUT WE
DON'T TARGET THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
THEIR BACKYARD ARE SPRAYING ALL
KINDS OF STUFF, NOT ON THE
LABEL, NOT AT THE RATE THEY
SHOULD. AND IT'S GETTING INTO
OUR WATER SYSTEMS. IT'S GETTING
INTO ALL KINDS OF STUFF. AND
IT'S LIKE THEY GET A PASS, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AFTER THE
FARMER AND WE'RE GOING TO HAMMER
HIM. LOOK, I DON'T WANT ANYBODY
GETTING SICK. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO THIS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO WEATHER DICTATES A LOT.
AND ALSO IF YOU CAN'T SPRAY FOR
THREE DAYS BECAUSE OF WEATHER,
YOUR CROPS GETTING DESTROYED AT
THE SAME TIME, BECAUSE WE HAVE
KIDS IN SCHOOL AND WE DON'T WANT
TO HURT ANYBODY, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE TO GET OUR JOB DONE
AND WE ARE REGULATED HEAVILY. I
WANT YOU TO HEAR THAT. SO AND
LITTLE THINGS MATTER, RISK
VERSUS WHATEVER IT MATTERS. IT
MATTERS HUGELY IN WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO OUT THERE. SO I
JUST WANT TO PUT IT OUT THERE
AND I WANT TO SAY MY LAST
COMMENT IS THEY'RE SHIPPING THIS
STUFF IN FROM MEXICO WITH ALL
KINDS OF STUFF ON IT. BECAUSE
OUR FARMERS ARE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA. THEY LITERALLY ARE.
AND THEY'RE SHIPPING THOSE
PRODUCTS IN HERE. WE EAT EVERY
DAY. THEY LOOK BEAUTIFUL, BUT
THEY'RE COVERED IN PESTICIDES
AND HERBICIDES THAT WERE THAT
ARE ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO STRIKE A
BALANCE HERE. THAT IS COMMON
SENSE THAT WORKS, KEEPS PEOPLE
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE, BUT NOT JUST
BURDEN THE GUY THAT ACTUALLY HAS
THE PERMIT, BECAUSE THERE'S A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT DO A LOT OF BAD THINGS THAT
NOBODY EVEN KNOWS ABOUT, BUT WE
SEE IT ELSEWHERE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, WHY DON'T WE GIVE THE
AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THIS AND
CLOSE? YEAH AND I OH. I'M SORRY.
YEAH. OF COURSE. YEAH. PLEASE. I
DIDN'T KNOW IF I WANTED TO ASK
AFTER THAT BEAUTIFUL SPEECH
THERE. SENATOR SO I JUST WANT TO
IF YOU COULD CLARIFY, DURING YOU
STARTED TALKING ABOUT SOME
THINGS THAT YOU AGREED WITH IN
THE OPPOSITION. AND I KNOW THAT
WAS ALSO IN THE ANALYSIS
REGARDING SOME ON THE
NOTIFICATION THAT WHAT'S BEING
NOTIFIED IS REALLY NOT
ADDRESSING THE CRUX OF THE
ISSUE. AND I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY, ARE YOU GOING TO BE
ADDING THAT IN YOUR BILL RELATED
TO THE TIME THAT THE APPLICATION
IS THE TIME THAT THE PESTICIDES
IS BEING, INTRODUCED AND SO
FORTH? I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID. I'M
NOT CLEAR ON MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE QUESTION. SO EARLIER YOU YOU
SPOKE ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU AGREED WITH. YES. THE
OPPOSITION, ONE OF THEM WAS
RELATED TO MAYBE, PERHAPS
CHANGING WHAT IS INCLUDED IN THE
NOTIFICATION AND THE NÓI. AND I
JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT I
WAS ACTUALLY COMMENTING THAT THE
OPPOSITION THÀNH, JUST TO BE
CLEAR, AGREES WITH A LOT OF THE
BILL ALREADY. THERE'S REALLY ONE
AREA OF DISAGREEMENT LEFT, AND
THAT IS OVER THE SCOPE OF THE
PRODUCT SUBJECT TO THE NÓI.
MAYBE FOR MAYBE I'M
MISUNDERSTANDING. IS YOUR BILL
CHANGING? WHAT IS GOING TO BE IN
THE NÓI? YES. OKAY. JUST SAYING.
IN EFFECT, IT'S DOING THREE
THINGS. ONE IS REQUIRING MORE
SPECIFICITY AS TO WHAT,
REGARDING, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
METHOD, AS STATED IN THE NÓI, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S A NO
DISAGREEMENT ON IMPROVING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NUMBER
TWO IS APPLICABILITY TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. I BELIEVE WE HAVE COME
TO AGREEMENT ON THAT
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WILL NOT
BE, FARMERS OR THE AG COMMUNITY
THAT HAS TO IDENTIFY WHERE THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL IS. BUT ONCE
KNOWN, THEN IT IS THE THIRD
PIECE AND THERE IS NOT AGREEMENT
YET, AT LEAST AS IS THE
SUBSTANTIVE IS THAT WILL THIS
WILL APPLY TO CURRENT LAW IS
RESTRICT DID TOXINS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS EXTEND IT TO
EFFECTIVELY INCLUDE US EPA
IDENTIFIED CARCINOGEN. WE
BELIEVE THAT JUST THE FIRST ONES
THAT I YEAH I GOT IT. THANK YOU.
OKAY OKAY. SO WHY DON'T WE GIVE
YOU THE CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE VICE CHAIRS COMMENTS
AND THEN AS YOU CLOSE. YEAH. AND
AGAIN I WHAT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT IS WE'RE NOT BANNING THESE
SUBSTANCES. SO SO WHETHER OR NOT
PRODUCTS ARE COMING IN FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY, WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO TILT THE BALANCE ON
THAT. WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS GIVING THE PUBLIC INFO AND
DECISION MAKING CAPABILITY ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF, TOXIN ARE BEING
LARGE SCALE APPLIED AND NEAR
SCHOOLS, AND JUST MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE ARE BEING IDENTIFIED,
AND THAT PEOPLE CAN MAKE CHOICES
ACCORDINGLY. SO I APPRECIATE
SOME OF THE ANALOGIES. I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE VERY APPLICABLE,
WE'LL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS WITH
THE COMMISSIONER'S, INFORMATION
THEY HAVE OR DON'T HAVE. WE HAVE
NOT HAD THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO
THE EXTENT THAT HAS BEEN, REP
PRESENTED HERE TODAY, AND
FURTHERMORE, WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH, INTERESTED PARTIES
ON, WHAT ARE THE TOXINS THAT
SHOULD BE INCLUDED? I MEAN, IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S DIFFERENT
WAYS OF LOOKING AT THAT, THAT
SEEMS TO BE BEHIND SOME OF THE
CLAIMS OF BURDEN, ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT 54 OR ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
10,000? THAT'S A BIG SPREAD, SO
WE'LL CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
TO TRY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND IN
THE REAL WORLD, HOW THAT LOOKS
WITH THAT, I'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY TO
CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION. WELL
THANK YOU. YOU HAD ME AT THE
NUMBER 54, WILL WILL, WE'LL
WE'LL TAKE WE'LL TAKE A VOTE ON
YOUR MEASURE WHEN THE, WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
IT, I SEE CONGRESSWOMAN FRIEDMAN
HERE TO PRESENT, MAYBE 1963 AND
A B 22 2022, 2552. THE
PESTICIDE. YES. JUST LET'S KEEP
TALKING. PESTICIDES, I GUESS
THIS IS WHY VICE CHAIR IS NOT
LIKING THE DAY TO DAY. ALL
RIGHT. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS STARTING ON PAGE
NINE. COMMENT THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. PARAQUAT, FIRST
MANUFACTURED IN 1962, IS A
HIGHLY TOXIC HERBICIDE OR
WEEDKILLER USED IN ALMONDS,
PISTACHIOS AND WALNUT ORCHARDS
AND ON GRAPES AND COTTON.
PARAQUAT IS SPRAYED TO BURN DOWN
OR CLEAR FIELDS BEFORE PLANTING
AND THROUGHOUT THE GROWING
SEASON TO MANAGE WEEDS BETWEEN
CROP ROWS, AND MUCH OF THIS
CHEMICAL ENDS UP IN THE SOIL FOR
YEARS, BUT IT CAN EVENTUALLY
REACH NEARBY COMMUNITIES VIA
DUST OR DRIFT WHEN STRONG WINDS
OCCUR. THIS POSES AN INCREASED
RISK TO PEOPLE LIVING AND
WORKING NEAR FIELDS WHO ARE
EXPOSED TO PARAQUAT. HOWEVER,
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST AT RISK
ARE AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WHO
MIX, LOAD OR APPLY. PARAQUAT AND
ENTER AREAS AFTER PARAQUAT HAS
BEEN APPLIED. RECENT COMMON PEER
REVIEWED SCIENCE HAS CONFIRMED
THAT EXPOSURE TO PARAQUAT
GREATLY INCREASES THE RISK OF
DEVELOPING PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
PARAQUAT IS BANNED IN MORE THAN
60 COUNTRIES, INCLUDING THOSE
WITH LARGE AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES LIKE THE UNITED
KINGDOM, CHINA, BRAZIL, AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE EUROPEAN UNION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOLLOW THEIR
LEAD. WHY SHOULD WE CONTINUE TO
USE THIS PESTICIDE THAT'S BEEN
AROUND SINCE 1962? AB 1963 IS
STRUCTURED SO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN COMPLETE ITS
INVESTIGATION OF THE CURRENT
SCIENCE ON PARAQUAT BEFORE ANY
PROHIBITION OF ITS USE WOULD
OCCUR. THAT'S OVER A YEAR AND A
HALF FROM TODAY. WE CAN DO
BETTER BECAUSE ALTERNATIVES TO
PARAQUAT EXIST TODAY, AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DISCUSSES IN
DETAIL FINDINGS THAT PRODUCTION
DATA CONSISTENTLY FAILED TO SHOW
ANY NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF BANNING
PARAQUAT ON AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTIVITY, SEE CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION IS EMPHASIZING THAT
WE NEED TO BE USING LESS
PESTICIDES AND HERBICIDES IN
THEIR NEW PLANNING EFFORT,
TITLED SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT, INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT IS A STRATEGY THAT
FOCUSES ON LONG TERM PEST
PREVENTION THROUGH BIOLOGICAL
CONTROLS, HABITAT MANIPULATION,
AND OTHER APPROACHES. I AGREE
WITH DPR THAT WE NEED TO BE THE
LEADER IN ELIMINATING HIGHLY
TOXIC PESTICIDES LIKE PARAQUAT.
FURTHERMORE, THE PESTICIDE
INDUSTRY ALWAYS PROUD OF THEIR
ABILITY TO INNOVATE, SHOULD STEP
FORWARD AND AGREE TO STOP
PRODUCING THIS PRODUCT AND
PRODUCE FAR LESS TOXIC WEED
KILLERS. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB 1963 IS BILL ALLARD WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
AND JONATHAN EVANS WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
AND I WOULD REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAY
PROCEED, GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. MY NAME
IS JONATHAN EVANS. I'M THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH LEGAL
DIRECTOR AT THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. THERE IS
ROBUST SCIENCE CONNECTING
PARAQUAT TO PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
SERIOUS HUMAN HEALTH HARMS
SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. WHICH IS WHY IN
2022, MY ORGANIZATION, ALONG
WITH CALIFORNIA'S PESTICIDE
REFORM, REQUESTED THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION REEVALUATE
THE STATE'S APPROVAL OF PARAQUAT
AND SUSPEND AND CANCEL ITS USE,
SUBMITTING A WEALTH OF PEER
REVIEWED LITERATURE AND SCIENCE
DOCUMENTING THE THREATS OF
PARAQUAT. UNFORTUNATELY, TO
DATE, DPR HAS YET TO PROVIDE A
SUBSTANTIVE RESPONSE. PARAQUAT
IS ACUTELY TOXIC AND ALSO HAS
LONG TERM CHRONIC EFFECTS. IT
HARMS PEOPLE BOTH WHEN THEY'RE
EXPOSED TO A SINGLE DOSE AND
REPEATEDLY OVER TIME, TO LOWER
DOSES. INGESTION OF PARAQUAT,
EVEN JUST A TEASPOON, CAN CAUSE
ILLNESS, ORGAN FAILURE, AND EVEN
DEATH. EPA ITSELF HAS A WEBSITE
ENTITLED PARAQUAT DICHLORIDE.
ONE SIP CAN KILL. RESEARCH
PUBLISHED IN 2011 FOUND THAT
FARMWORKERS WHO SPRAYED PARAQUAT
WERE TWO AND A HALF TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DEVELOP PARKINSON'S
DISEASE, AND THE LONGER THEY USE
THE HERBICIDE, THE STRONGER THE
CONNECTION. OAN EARLIER THIS
YEAR, UCLA STUDY FOUND THAT
PEOPLE LIVING OR WORKING NEAR
THE MOST INTENSE PARAQUAT
APPLICATIONS IN OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY WERE MORE LIKELY TO
DEVELOP PARKINSON'S DISEASE. AND
A 2019 META ANALYSIS, THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR SUMMARIZING THE
SCIENCE ON A PARTICULAR TOPIC,
FOUND THAT ACROSS 13 STUDIES,
OCCUPATIONAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURE TO PARAQUAT INCREASED
THE RISK OF PARKINSON'S DISEASE
BY 64. THE EPA AND PARAQUAT
MANUFACTURER CLAIM THAT PARAQUAT
CAN BE SAFELY USED WITH PROPER
RESTRICTIONS. HOWEVER, EPA
OPENLY ACKNOWLEDGES THAT RISKS
TO FARMWORKERS PERSIST DESPITE
RESTRICTIONS, RESTRICTIONS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE
OKAY. HEY, BILL, I'M BILL ALLIO
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP SPONSORING THE
LEGISLATION, FIRST ON THE
SCIENCE. IS IT STRONG ENOUGH? WE
THINK IT IS, IF YOU WANT TO GIVE
RODENTS PARKINSON'S DISEASE IN
THE LAB, YOU GIVE THEM PARAQUAT.
IT WORKS, THE OPPONENTS ARE
SAYING THERE IS NO PROOF THAT
PARAQUAT CAUSES PARKINSON'S
DISEASE. BUT DO WE HAVE PROOF
THAT SMOKING CAUSES CANCER? LUNG
CANCER? EVERYONE KNOWS MY
GRANDFATHER SMOKED. HE WAS 96.
HE DIDN'T DIE OF LUNG CANCER.
THERE'S A STRONG CORRELATION.
THÀNH. SAME WITH PARKINSON'S AND
PARAQUAT. IT'S A CORRELATION,
NOT PROOF THAT IT CAUSES ON
ALTERNATIVES. WE HEARD WITH
CHLORPYRIFOS A FEW YEARS AGO,
THE INDUSTRY CAME IN AND SAID
THIS IS THE END OF INDUSTRY FOR
CITRUS AND GRAPES AND WHATEVER
THEY'RE DOING FINE. WITHOUT
CHLORPYRIFOS. I THINK THEY CAN
DO FINE WITHOUT PARAQUAT, IT'S A
HIGHLY RESTRICTED PESTICIDE.
THAT'S WHAT DPR TERM'S IT. AND
SO THEREFORE USE RESTRICTIONS.
AS SENATOR DAWLEY WAS TALKING
ABOUT ARE IMPORTANT ABOUT WIND
AND LOCATION AND ALL THAT.
HOWEVER, VIOLATIONS KEEP
OCCURRING, NATIONALLY, WE HAVE A
LIST OF VIOLATIONS THAT THIS
MICHAEL J. FOX FOUNDATION
SUBMITTED AND THAT SHOWS,
WIDESPREAD PLACE INSTANCES WHERE
FARMWORKERS WERE EXPOSED IN
CALIFORNIA. EWG IS IN THE
PROCESS OF COMPILING IT IN THE
COUNTIES WHERE IT'S USED MOST
HEAVILY. WE'RE FINDING PLACES
WHERE IT RAN DOWN INTO THE
BOOTS. GLOVES WEREN'T USED,
GOGGLES, ETC. SO EVEN THOUGH
IT'S HIGHLY RESTRICTED,
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN AND THIS IS
HIGHLY TOXIC. SO IF YOU GET A
LITTLE BIT HERE AND A LITTLE BIT
THERE, YOU MAY NOT GET
PARKINSON'S. YOU WON'T IN A YEAR
OR TWO. BUT TEN YEARS FROM NOW,
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE CONCERN.
FINALLY, I WANT TO SAY THIS
ISN'T A PERMANENT BAN ON
PARAQUAT. IT'S SUSPENDS ITS USE
UNTIL THE DEPARTMENT COMPLETES A
SCIENTIFIC REEVALUATION. THEN
THE BILL, THE AUTHOR. WE ALL
WILL STAND BY WHAT THEY DO. THEY
CAN PUT MORE RESTRICTIONS ON,
CONTINUE A BAN, MAKE IT
PERMANENT OR DO NOTHING. IT'S UP
TO WHAT THEY DO. SO WE'LL HAVE
TO TRUST THE SCIENCE THAT DPR
DOES. I NOTE THAT PER THE
EARLIER BILL ON THE MILFY,
HOPEFULLY THE DEPARTMENT GOES A
LOT FASTER ON REVIEWING THIS
PESTICIDE AND ALL THE REST. AND
ALSO GETTING ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE SAFER. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
I HAVE FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ABBY ALVAREZ
, ON BEHALF OF THE PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK, CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE AND CLEAN WATER
ACTION. AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. VICTOR TORRES, ON
BEHALF OF FUTURE LEADERS OF
CHANGE, IN FULL SUPPORT. ISABEL
RAMIREZ WITH US IN SUPPORT.
NOEMI CHICO. SAFE, ACTIVE
SCHOOLS AND FULL SUPPORT. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS NATE SULLIVAN. MAP
OF THE MICHAEL J. FOX FOUNDATION
FOR PARKINSON'S RESEARCH AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARIANA,
CO-LEAD WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS. ORG AND SUPPORT. ALSO
THOSE IN SUPPORT ARE NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND CA
ECO SUSTAINABILITY. PEACE
ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO FACTS, SONOMA
SAS, BEYOND PESTICIDES, YARD
SMART AND MARIN AND MOMS
ADVOCATING FOR SUSTAINABILITY.
THANK YOU. HELLO, MY NAME IS
TORRES AND SUPPORT JENNY
MARTINEZ WITH SAFE SCHOOLS. ALSO
GREENFIELD CITY COUNCILWOMAN IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, YES. OUR
FRIENDLY OPPOSITION WITNESS.
COME UP AGAIN. COME ON UP. NICE
TO SEE YOU BOTH. RIGHT? YEAH
ONCE AGAIN. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN PLANT HEALTH AND A
COALITION EXPRESSING RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO 1963 ENSURING
CALIFORNIA WORK FORCE,
ENVIRONMENT AND COMMUNITIES ARE
SAFE ARE OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. PARAQUAT IS ONE OF
THE MOST HIGHLY STUDIED ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS EVER. U.S. EPA HAS
EVALUATED THOUSANDS OF STUDIES,
INCLUDING PUBLISHED TOXICOLOGY
AND EPIDEMIOLOGICAL LITERATURE
ON PARAQUAT EXPOSURE AND ADVERSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES. BECAUSE OF THAT
DATA, PARAQUAT IS A RESTRICTED
USE PRODUCT, MEANING, AS WE
DISCUSSED BEFORE, IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
AND IS SOLD IN LIMITED
QUANTITIES BEYOND THAT
DESIGNATION, IT CAN ONLY BE
APPLIED BY A LICENSED APPLICATOR
WITH HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
TRAINING. A PERMIT IS REQUIRED
PRIOR TO USE, AND COMMISSIONERS
ARE PRESENT DURING TYPES OF
APPLICATIONS. PPE IS EXTENSIVE
REENTRY INTO THE FIELD AFTER AN
APPLICATION IS SEVERELY
RESTRICTED, AND THE PRODUCT IS
EVEN CONTAINED IN A CLOSED LOOP
SYSTEM THAT PREVENTS EVEN THE
APPLICATOR FROM ACCESSING THE
MATERIAL. THESE ARE ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT ALL OTHER RESTRICTED
USE AND LABEL REQUIREMENTS ARE
SET TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. CUMULATIVELY,
THESE RESTRICTIONS AND MORE MAKE
PARAQUAT ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY
REGULATED PRODUCTS IN THE WORLD,
AND AS OUR SCIENTIFIC
DISCOVERIES AND OUR CAPACITIES
EXPAND AS THE SPONSORS HAVE
MENTIONED, FEDERAL AND STATE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ADAPT.
IN 2019 AND 2020 TO ADDRESS
INCIDENTAL INGESTION, OAN MAJOR
NEW RESTRICTIONS WERE PUT IN
PLACE, AND IF ANY SCIENTIFIC
DATA THAT'S NEW IS DEVELOPED ON
PARAQUAT, IT CAN BE SUBMITTED TO
US. EPA AND DPR ANYTIME. AND IF
DPR FINDS THEM TO BE VALID, DPR
AND US EPA HAVE A MANDATORY DUTY
TO FURTHER RESTRICT USE. ALL OF
THESE IS TO SAY THAT THERE IS A
SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE, AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT USE THAT SYSTEM.
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ALLEGE A
CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PARAQUAT AND PARKINSON'S DISEASE
. AND WHILE THE SPONSORS IN THE
ANALYSIS CITE A META ANALYSIS OF
13 CASE STUDIES TO SUPPORT THEIR
CLAIM, U.S. EPA HAS STUDIED 1200
STUDIES AND FOUND CONCLUSIVELY
THE CLAIM IS NOT ACCURATE.
ACCORDING TO A 2024 U.S. EPA
REVIEW RELEASED IN RESPONSE TO A
PETITION. QUOTE. AFTER A
THOROUGH REVIEW, THE AGENCY HAS
CONCLUDED THAT THE WEIGHT OF
EVIDENCE WAS INSUFFICIENT TO
LINK PARAQUAT EXPOSURE FROM
PESTICIDE USE TO PARKINSON'S
DISEASE IN HUMANS. THIS
CONCLUSION IS SUPPORTED BY,
AMONG OTHER THINGS, THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH SPONSORED
STUDY OF 66,000 PESTICIDE
APPLICATOR APPLICATORS AND THEIR
SPOUSES OVER 25 YEARS.
ADDITIONALLY, IN MARCH, A
FEDERAL JUDGE DISMISSED THE
PLAINTIFFS EXPERT WITNESS
TESTIMONY, CITING THE CAUSAL
THEORY HAS NOT BEEN ADOPTED OR
INDEPENDENTLY VALIDATED IN A
PEER REVIEWED ANALYSIS, AND THE
EXPERTS METHODOLOGY WAS, QUOTE,
UNCLEAR, INCONSISTENTLY APPLIED,
NOT REPLICABLE, AND AT TIMES
REVERSE ENGINEERED, UNQUOTE.
EVEN WITH SCIENTIFIC DEBATE
PENDING, 1963 DOESN'T DIRECT DPR
TO REVIEW DATA AND LET SCIENCE
DICTATE IF AN ACTION IS
WARRANTED, AND IT BANS FIRST AND
SAYS STUDY SECOND, AS WE ALSO
DISCUSSED, MR. GARCIA'S BILL,
JUST RESOURCE THE DEPARTMENT, TO
DO EXPANSIVE WORK AND
NEGOTIATIONS WILL ABSOLUTELY
INCLUDE AN ANNUAL TARGET FOR
REEVALUATIONS AND MITIGATIONS.
OUR COALITION BELIEVES IN
SCIENCE AND THAT OUR AGENCY IS
FULL OF TOXICOLOGISTS AND
BIOCHEMISTS. VOIGTS,
ENDOCRINOLOGISTS AND BIOLOGISTS
ARE BEST SUITED TO OPINE ON THE
SCIENCE, AND IT'S THE
LEGISLATURE'S PURVIEW TO DIRECT
THEM TO DO THAT WORK, EVEN WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS, 1963 IS STILL, FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE, AN UNSCIENTIFIC
, UNSUBSTANTIATED BAN. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE MR. CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
REARDON, CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU,
IN CALIFORNIA, PARAQUAT IS A
VERY EFFECTIVE WEED CONTROL AND
RESISTANCE MANAGEMENT TOOL. IT'S
USED ON A VARIETY OF CROPS,
SIGNIFICANT CROPS INCLUDING
ALMONDS, WALNUTS, CITRUS,
COTTON, CORN, TOMATOES, PEPPERS,
AND POTATOES. THE APPLICATION OF
PARAQUAT IS STRICTLY REGULATED
TO ENSURE THAT THE SAFETY OF
APPLICATORS, BYSTANDERS,
CONSUMERS, AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
SOME OF THE KEY PROTECTIVE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND
GUIDELINES INCLUDE RESTRICTED
USE MATERIAL. PARAQUAT IS
CLASSIFIED AS RESTRICTED USE
MATERIAL IN CALIFORNIA THAT
MEANS ONLY CERTIFIED APPLICATORS
WHO HAVE BEEN TRAINED AND
LICENSED CAN PURCHASE AND APPLY.
PARAQUAT CONTAINED PRODUCTS,
APPLICATORS MUST FOLLOW STRICT
GUIDELINES REGARDING APPLICATION
RATES AND TIMING SPECIFIED ON
THE PRODUCT LABEL. THIS INCLUDES
ENSURING THAT PARAQUAT IS
APPLIED ONLY WHEN WEATHER
CONDITIONS ARE SUITABLE, AND
WHEN THERE IS A MINIMUM RISK OF
DRIFT. BUFFER ZONES ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO MINIMIZE POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE TO SENSITIVE AREAS SUCH
AS RESIDENTIAL AREAS, SCHOOLS,
WATER BODIES, ORGANIC CROPS. THE
SIZE OF BUFFER ZONES DEPENDS ON
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FACTORS,
INCLUDING WEATHER CONDITIONS,
PROXIMITY TO THESE SENSITIVE
AREAS. PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT APPLICATORS MUST WEAR
PPE AS SPECIFIED IN THE PRODUCT
LABEL IS TYPICALLY INCLUDES LONG
SLEEVED SHIRTS, LONG PANTS,
CHEMICAL RESISTANT GLOVES,
GOGGLES, OR FACE SHIELDS TO
PROTECT AGAINST POTENTIAL SKIN
AND EYE EXPOSURE. ANYONE
APPLYING PARAQUAT IN CALIFORNIA
MUST UNDERGO SPECIFIC TRAINING
AND OBTAIN CERTIFICATION AS A
PESTICIDE APPLICATOR. THE
TRAINING COVERS SAFETY,
HANDLING, APPLICATION
TECHNIQUES, EMERGENCY PROCEDURES
, AND ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP.
ALSO, APPLICATORS ARE REQUIRED
TO KEEP DETAILED RECORDS OF
PARAQUAT APPLICATIONS, INCLUDING
DATES, LOCATIONS, APPLICATIONS,
APPLICATION RATES, WEATHER
CONDITIONS, AND ANY ADVERSE
EFFECTS OBSERVED. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE, MR. CHAIR,
MEMBERS, THAT INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT IS, MANY OF YOU KNOW,
AS A CORNERSTONE OF MODERN
AGRICULTURE, EMPHASIZING THE USE
OF MULTIPLE APPROACHES FOR PEST
CONTROL WHILE MINIMIZING
MINIMIZING ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
PARAQUAT, WHEN USED JUDICIOUSLY
AS PART OF THIS IPM STRATEGY,
CONTRIBUTES TO THIS GOAL BY
REDUCING THE RELIANCE ON MORE
PERSISTENT HERBICIDES AND
PROMOTING BIODIVERSITY ON FARMS.
THEN LASTLY, I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE AS WELL IS AND WE TALKED
ABOUT IN A PREVIOUS BILL, IS
ALTERNATIVES. RIGHT NOW, IT
TAKES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME IN CALIFORNIA TO GET A NEW
REGISTRATION TO DEAL WITH SOME
OF THESE ISSUES. AND SO LET'S
MAKE SURE BEFORE WE JUST THROW
OUT AN EFFECTIVE PRODUCT THAT
HAS ENORMOUS IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE, THAT WE
HAVE ALTERNATIVES THAT ACTUALLY
WORK. SO THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, FOLKS, YOU
WANT TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. HELLO, MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS, MATTHEW ALLEN WITH
WESTERN GROWERS, WE'RE ALSO
OPPOSED AND WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS MADE BY MISS ROCHE AND
MR. REARDON. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, LOUIS BROWN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COTTON
GROWERS AND GINNERS ASSOCIATION
IN WESTERN AGRICULTURAL
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. LINDSAY CARTER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS AND
SEALERS ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. MARGIE LEE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF FOOD PRODUCERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. BRENDA BASS, WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND OPPOSITION. ROB
SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. KIRK
WILBUR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. DENNIS ALBIANI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SEED
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA PEAR
GROWERS, AND SOME SEVERAL OTHER
AG ASSOCIATE IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICIA GERINGER, AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AARON
NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOND
ALLIANCE. ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THE ITEM IS BACK BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW, THIS
THIS IS ONE OF THESE. WELL, ONE
OF THESE THINGS WHERE, THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION AT THE EPA, AND
THEY HAD AN INTERIM DECISION
THAT THEY WHERE THEY FOUND THAT
THERE WASN'T A STRONG ENOUGH
CONNECTION BETWEEN PARAQUAT AND
PARKINSONS TO PROHIBIT THE USE
OF THE PRODUCT. BUT THEY'RE
COMING OUT WITH A FINAL DECISION
IN JANUARY. YOU KNOW, I. IS ONE
OF THESE THESE THERE'S CERTAINLY
A LOT OF SCARY EVIDENCE THAT
WE'VE BEEN PRESENTED, BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THERE'S A REAL IMPACT
ON THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY.
AND I KNOW THAT'S GOING TO BE A
BIG TOPIC OF CONVERSATION AT THE
AG COMMITTEE. IF THE BILL PASSES
OUT TODAY. BUT, THIS IS A HARD
BILL, ACTUALLY, IN MANY
RESPECTS, BECAUSE I THINK, YOU
KNOW, YOU WANT TO, YOU WANT TO
BECAUSE OF HOW TAINTED BECAUSE
OF THE SITUATION AT THE EPA AND
I BUT THE FLIP SIDE IS, I GUESS,
THIS WOULD THIS BILL WOULD
SUNSET AT THE COMPLETION OF THE
DPR PROCESS. SO IF THEY DECIDE
THAT THEY WANT TO GO AHEAD WITH
CONTINUING USE OF THE PESTICIDE,
THEN, THE STATE'S POLICY WOULD
REVERT BACK TO THE EPA'S
DECISION. ALL RIGHT, QUESTIONS?
THOUGHTS? SO LET ME ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SINCE WE SEE SENATOR
NGUYEN HERE, DO YOU WANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? SENATOR
ALAN, HERE. ALAN, HERE. DALLY
HERE. DALLY HERE. GONZALEZ.
HURTADO MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
HERE. NGUYEN NGUYEN HERE.
SKINNER OKAY, SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM. FINALLY TOOK US AN HOUR
AND A HALF, BUT LET'S LET'S OPEN
UP THE FLOOR TO QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, THOUGHTS? YEAH. WELL,
OBVIOUSLY IT'S YOU KNOW, AG0
TODAY SO FAR, I THINK PROBABLY
GOING TO BE ZERO AGAIN. BUT THIS
BILL, FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S SOME
DISCREPANCY ON WHETHER IT REALLY
CAUSES PARKINSON'S DISEASE OR
NOT. I THINK THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS I LOOKED AT, THERE'S
BEEN SEVERAL DIFFERENT STUDIES.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I KNOW MICHAEL
J. FOX MAY THINK THAT, BUT BUT
THE SCIENCE HASN'T DETERMINED
THAT YET, AT LEAST FROM WHAT I
CAN SEE HERE, ALSO, THIS IS A
BAN UNTIL MICHAEL J. FOX PAID
FOR THAT UP ON THE WALL, THIS IS
A BAN UNTIL REEVALUATED IF THEY
EVER REEVALUATE IT. SO I THINK
THAT'S PRETTY AGGRESSIVE. IT'S
PRETTY STRONG TO TAKE SOMETHING
AWAY THAT, YOU KNOW, AND THEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME ACTION,
MAYBE BY EPA, YOU KNOW, LATER
THIS FALL. SO I THINK IT'S
PREMATURE NUMBER ONE, I THINK WE
SHOULD WAIT. SO I'M NOT GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD JUST
WAIT AND THEN SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
AND ALSO THEN I THINK ON TOP OF
THAT, IF THE BILL BEFORE PASSES
AND WE KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME ACTION WITH DPR AND FUNDING
AND THEN THEY'LL HAVE SOME
RESOURCES TO MAYBE TAKE ON SOME
OF THESE. SO FOR ME, IT'S A NO.
YEAH. OKAY. THOUGHTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE OTHER
MEMBERS. OKAY, YOU KNOW I'M I'M,
I DO SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
THE VICE CHAIR. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO GO TO AGRICULTURE
AND THERE'S GOING TO DO THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A REAL ROBUST
DISCUSSION OF THE IMPACTS ON THE
INDUSTRY. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WEIGH, THE, THE, THE
HEALTH CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
RAISED. BUT THE SCIENCE IS STILL
BEING INVESTIGATED AND, AND, YOU
KNOW, I GUESS LET ME LET ME JUST
TURN TO THE AUTHOR TO, TO JUST
KIND OF MAKE THE CASE FOR US AS
TO, AS TO, THE URGENCY OF THIS
NOW WITH THE, YOU KNOW, WITH,
WITH THE WITH THE EPA
INVESTIGATION PENDING, I THINK
IT'S, WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
YEARS HOW EASY IT IS TO THROW
DOUBT ON, ON EVIDENCE THAT WE
SEE OF CORRELATION THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY DID IT FOR MANY YEARS.
WE SEE THIS COMMONLY WITH
CHEMICALS THAT ARE IN DISPUTE,
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT FARM
WORKERS WHO USE PARAQUAT HAVE
MORE THAN TWICE THE AMOUNT OF
PARKINSON'S THAN FARM WORKERS
WHO DON'T. WE KNOW THAT THE EPA
BANNED THE USE OF PARAQUAT ON
GOLF COURSES DURING THEIR LAST
REVIEW, I GUESS IMPLYING THAT
IT'S TOO DANGEROUS FOR GOLFERS,
BUT IT'S OKAY FOR FARM WORKERS.
THIS BILL IS TAKES A VERY
MEASURED APPROACH. THE BAN
DOESN'T START OR THE MORATORIUM
DOESN'T START UNTIL 2026. AND IF
EPA ACTS BEFORE THEN, THIS BILL
MIGHT BECOME A NECESSARY. BUT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO ON ONE SIDE OR
THE OTHER, IF YOU HAVE A
DISPUTE, DO YOU DO DO YOU ACT
THE WAY THAT IS THE MOST
PROTECTIVE TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED, WHICH IS
THOSE FARM WORKERS? DO YOU ON
THE SIDE OF PROTECTION GIVEN THE
ENORMOUS IMPACTS OF PARKINSON'S
DISEASE, OF THAT KIND OF
NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE, OR DO YOU
ON THE SIDE OF ALLOWING THE USE?
REMEMBER THIS PRODUCT'S BEEN
BANNED IN OVER 60 COUNTRIES,
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE ROBUST
AGRICULTURAL SECTORS THAT ARE
HEALTHY. SO WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES. AND MY
FEELING IS THAT GIVEN THAT THERE
IS A SCIENTIFIC DISPUTE AND A
LOT OF SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
SHOWING HARM, AND BY THE WAY,
THE FACT THAT, SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY WAS NOT ALLOWED IN ONE
CASE REALLY DIDN'T HAVE TO DO
IT, HAD TO DO WITH ONE
PARTICULAR WITNESS. AND WE CAN
SHOW THAT THAT THAT WAS ONE
WITNESS WHOSE EVIDENCE WASN'T
ALLOWED. BUT MANY BUT BUT
HUNDREDS OF CASES WERE ALLOWED
TO GO FORWARD. AND MANY, MANY
OTHER WITNESSES AS WELL. SO IT'S
NOT AT ALL CONCLUSIVE AS TO THE
EVIDENCE THAT'S OUT IN THE
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE. IF YOU DO
A LOOK, THIS THIS MATERIAL HAS
BEEN HEAVILY STUDIED, SHOWING A
VERY LARGE LINK. THAT'S WHY
THERE IS SO MUCH PROTECTIVE GEAR
THAT HAS TO BE USED WITH THIS.
SO SO IT'S A DANGEROUS CHEMICAL.
EVERYBODY ADMITS THAT THE
QUESTION IS, ARE WE USING IT
SAFELY ENOUGH TO BE PROTECTIVE
OF FARM WORKERS? THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE GETTING PARKINSON'S
RIGHT NOW AT HIGH RATES, WHEN WE
DID THIS BILL A FEW WEEKS, A FEW
WEEKS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY, WE
HAD AN OWNER OF A FARM WHO CAME
IN, WHO HAS PARKINSON'S, WHO
SAYS SHE REGRETTED NOT KNOWING
HOW SERIOUS THIS WAS, THAT SHE
NOW HAS PARKINSON'S, AND SHE
BELIEVES IT'S FROM THE USE OF
THIS PRODUCT ON HER FARM. SO I
JUST I FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT
GIVEN THAT THERE IS THIS DISPUTE
AND THE GRAVITY OF THIS ILLNESS,
THAT WE SHOULD ALLOW FOR THIS
PAUSE, WHICH DOESN'T TAKE EFFECT
FOR ANOTHER COUPLE OF YEARS,
MAYBE IT'LL PUSH EPA TO WORK. SO
I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE. AND
YOUR POINT, I MEAN, GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE EXPECTED TO
FINALIZE THEIR DECISION IN
JANUARY OF 25 OR PERHAPS EARLIER
, YOUR BILL DOESN'T EVEN KICK IN
UNTIL JANUARY OF 26. SO,
ASSUMING THAT I MEAN, THAT
ACTUALLY GIVES A LOT OF RUNWAY
SO THERE WON'T BE ANY, THERE
WON'T BE ANY IMPACT, ASSUMING
THAT THE EPA IS ON IS ON TRACK.
IF THEY, YOU KNOW, IF THEY DO
DECIDE TO NOT PROHIBIT. IS THAT
RIGHT. SO YEAH. OKAY. YEP, YEP.
SORRY MR. VICE CHAIR, I JUST
WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW, WITH THAT
LOGIC, WHY DON'T WE JUST BAN
EVERYTHING? EVERYTHING? WHY BY
2026, WHY DON'T WE JUST SAY,
HEY, WE KNOW NO FARM WORKER IS
GOING TO BE EXPOSED TO ANY
PESTICIDE? THERE'S A REASON WE
DON'T DO THAT, BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY DO REALLY NEED SOME OF
THESE THINGS. MOST OF THEM. BUT
SOME PESTICIDES ARE MORE
DANGEROUS THAN OTHERS? SOME
PESTICIDES ARE MORE DANGEROUS
THAN OTHERS. YES, BUT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE PROP 65,
WHICH IS NOBODY PAYS ATTENTION
TO ANYMORE BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
LABELED RIGHT. REALLY AT THE END
OF THE DAY. I MEAN, I THINK THIS
IS PROBABLY GOT A LABEL ON IT
SOMEWHERE. WATER, FOR GOD'S
SAKES. THERE'S A REASON FOR
THESE THINGS. IT IS. WE HAVE TO
HAVE SOME COMMON SENSE TO OUR
APPROACH HERE. LOOK I DON'T WANT
ANY FARM WORKERS TO GET SICK OR
DAMAGED. WE HAVE VERY STRICT
PROTOCOLS IN CALIFORNIA, MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE. AND WE
ALSO PRODUCE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE. BUT WE'RE LOSING THAT.
WE'RE LOSING THAT EDGE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE ARE SO
REGULATED. SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY, YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE, FOR
EXAMPLE, IT'S THE MINIMUM WAGE
BATTLE. WHY DON'T WE JUST MAKE
IT $100 AN HOUR? BECAUSE THERE'S
A REASON WE DON'T MAKE $100 AN
HOUR, BECAUSE EVERYBODY GO OUT
OF BUSINESS. THERE'S A REASON WE
NEED THESE PRODUCTS TO BE
COMPETITIVE, TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, TO NOT PUSH AGAIN ON ALL
OF OUR AG PEOPLE TO A DIFFERENT
COUNTRY WHERE THEY USE ALL THESE
THINGS. NOW, I KNOW THAT 60
COUNTRIES ARE BANNING THIS
STUFF, BUT THEY'RE WE WAIT ON.
WE NEED MORE TIME. THIS IS, I
THINK, A VERY AGGRESSIVE THERE
IS OBVIOUSLY THE EPA IS DOING
SOME STUFF. SO I JUST WANT TO
PUSH BACK A LITTLE BIT AND SAY,
YOU KNOW, IF THAT'S THE IF
THAT'S THE METHODOLOGY Kò, THEN
WE SHOULD JUST BAN EVERYTHING
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS. I'D LIKE
TO TAKE IF WE COULD JUST LOOK
AHEAD SIX MONTHS, IF WE BANNED
ALL THIS STUFF AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA, IT WOULD
BE DISASTROUS. WE NEED THESE
PRODUCTS. WE NEED TO DO IT IN A
SAFE WAY, AND WE DO THAT
ALREADY. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT FOR THE RECORD. I MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT SEEKING TO
BAN EVERY PRODUCT WITH THIS
BILL, BUT WE'LL YEAH, I GUESS
THAT ON THE RECORD. ALL RIGHT.
SO SENATOR DOLE IS IN SUPPORT OF
BANNING ALL, ALL PESTICIDES. YOU
HEARD IT HERE. ALL RIGHT. SO I
BELIEVE YOU'LL PROBABLY DO IT
ALL. YEAH SENATOR MENGIBAR, I
THINK, HAS MOVED THE BILL. LET'S
GIVE THE AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU, WELL, THIS
IS A CHEMICAL THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN BANNED IN MANY, MANY
COUNTRIES. AND, YOU KNOW, IN
OTHER COUNTRIES, THEY HAVE
PROCESSES WHERE THEIR REGULATORS
TRY TO ENSURE THAT PRODUCTS ARE
SAFE BEFORE THEY'RE BROUGHT TO
MARKET. AND THIS COUNTRY DOESN'T
WORK THAT WAY IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE ALLOW FOR THE USE OF A LOT OF
CHEMICALS THAT DO A LOT OF HARM,
AND IT TAKES ACTION, LEGAL
ACTION FROM PEOPLE LIKE ERIN
BROCKOVICH AND OTHERS TO
SOMETIMES TO SHOW PROOF AND THEN
TO GET THINGS TAKEN OFF THE
MARKET. AND WE HAVE SEEN OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THE RESULT OF
THAT WITH ALL OF OUR WATER BEING
MORE EXPENSIVE, BECAUSE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO HAVE TO PAY TO
FILTER OUT CHEMICALS AND PFAS
AND LOTS OF OTHER THINGS THAT WE
KNOW HAVE AN EFFECT ON HUMAN
HEALTH. BECAUSE WE DID WAIT A
LONG TIME AND PEOPLE SAID IT'S
TOO EXPENSIVE AND WE NEED THESE
THINGS. IF WE HAD PROCESSES THAT
REALLY ENSURED THAT PRODUCTS
WERE SAFE BEFORE THEY GOT TO
MARKET, WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO BE
SITTING HERE IN THESE HEARING
ROOMS OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
TRYING TO LOOK AT THESE
MATERIALS ONE AFTER ONE BY ONE.
SO I DO THINK THAT THERE'S A
FAILURE OF FEDERAL REGULATORS,
AND I DO THINK THAT IT IS UPON
US MANY TIMES TO BE PROTECTIVE
OF OUR COMMUNITY, BECAUSE WE
HAVE SEEN IN MANY CASES WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN VERY SICK
BECAUSE OF THINGS THAT THE
FEDERAL EPA AND FEDERAL LAWS
HAVE ALLOWED TO BE PUT INTO OUR
PRODUCT STREAM. AND I WILL USE
THAT AS MY CLOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YOU GUYS,
YOU WANNA STAY UP HERE FOR THE
FOR THE RODENTICIDE ONE? YEAH.
OKAY YOU MIGHT AS WELL STAY. ALL
RIGHT? PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
SENATORS ALLEN A ALLEN. AYE.
DALI. NO DALI. NO. GONZALEZ.
HURTADO MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE.
NGUYEN NO. NGUYEN. NO. SKINNER
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS OUT ON. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. IT IS PESTICIDE DAY
HERE AND EQ COMMITTEE. SO LET'S
NEXT HERE, THIS IS A
RODENTICIDE. OF COURSE, IS
DIFFERENT. ANOTHER BILL TO MAKE
MY GOOD FRIEND, SENATOR DOLLY
HAPPY. I AM GOING TO PASS SOME
PHOTOS AROUND, IF THAT. IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU TO THE
MEMBERS ON THE DAIS. SO I'LL
START WITH SENATOR DOLLY. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU TALK A BIT
MORE. SO THIS IS A MAP, A BUFFER
MAP. THERE'S A BUFFER MAP AS
WELL THAT SHOWS IN SENATOR
HURTADO'S DISTRICT WHAT THIS
WOULD LOOK LIKE IN TERMS OF THE
BUFFER ZONE. SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT. AND SO
LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. FIRST OF ALL, EXPOSURE TO
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES,
WHICH IS BASICALLY RAT POISON, A
CERTAIN CLASS OF RAT POISON CAN
RESULT IN BOTH LETHAL AND
SUBLETHAL EFFECTS ON NON-TARGET
WILDLIFE, INCLUDING SEVERE SKIN
DISEASES AND DECREASED IMMUNE
SYSTEM RESPONSES. ANTICOAGULANTS
WORK BY STOPPING THE BY STOPPING
CLOTTING AND SO ANIMALS THAT ARE
POISONED WITH ANTICOAGULANTS
BASICALLY BLEED OUT INTERNALLY.
NOW THESE THESE CHEMICALS ARE
USED WIDELY. THEY CONTINUE TO
RESULT IN UNREASONABLE NUMBER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INCIDENCES, WITH
OVER 3000 HUMAN POISONINGS IN
2021 AND AT LEAST 2300 OF THESE
INVOLVING CHILDREN UNDER SIX
YEARS, ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF POISON CONTROL
CENTER. AB 2552 ADDS THE TWO
REMAINING FIRST GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES,
KNOWN AS FCRS CHLORINE SOFTENING
AND WARFARIN, TO THE EXISTING
RODENTICIDE MORATORIUM TO BETTER
PROTECT WILDLIFE FROM
UNINTENTIONAL RODENTICIDE
POISONINGS WHILE MAINTAINING
EXCEPTIONS FOR ITS USE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH, WATER SUPPLIES, AND
AGRICULTURE. SO I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPACT
AGRICULTURE, EXCEPT IN ONE
INSTANCE, WHICH IS IF YOU HAVE A
FARM THAT IS NEXT TO A
DESIGNATED WILDLIFE HABITAT
ZONE. SO NOT JUST SOME FOREST,
BUT A FOREST THAT IS A PUBLICLY
OWNED FOREST LIKE A LIKE A STATE
PARK, THAT'S A WILDFIRE. THAT'S
A WILDLIFE HABITAT. SO IT HAS TO
MEET THOSE TWO CRITERIA. THEN
YOU HAVE A BUFFER BETWEEN WHERE
YOU CAN USE THESE CHEMICALS ON
YOUR FARM AND WHERE THE CRITTERS
FROM THAT WILDLIFE AREA ARE SORT
OF MOVING INTO YOUR FARM A BIT.
THE REASON WE BROUGHT THIS MAP
IS TO SHOW YOU WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE IN AN AREA THAT HAS BOTH A
LOT OF AGRICULTURE AND A LOT OF
THESE STATE PARKS. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RINGS AROUND THE PARK
THAT'S THE BUFFER AREA WHERE IN
AN AGRICULTURAL AREA, YOU
COULDN'T USE THE CHEMICALS. SO
IT'S NOT, YOU KNOW, HUGE AMOUNTS
OF FARMLAND. IT'S THAT THAT
BUFFER. AND THAT'S ONLY IN AN
AREA WHERE YOU HAVE THOSE
WILDLIFE AREAS, ALREADY IN, IN
SORT OF IN LAW. SO THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION ENACT
STRONGER PERMANENT RESTRICTIONS
ON AFCARS TO LIMIT UNINTENDED
WILDLIFE POISONINGS, MAKING
THESE CHEMICALS A RESTRICTED
MATERIAL. SO THAT YOUR AVERAGE
JOE CAN NO LONGER GET THEM AT
HOME DEPOT, WHICH IS A REAL
PROBLEM GIVEN HOW TOXIC THESE
ARE. AND YES, US EPA IS
UNDERGOING ITS PERIODIC REVIEW
OF RODENTICIDES, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT PROCESS IS
AGAIN TOO SLOW AND BEHIND
SCHEDULE. NOW, I LIVE IN A,
URBAN AREA WITH A LOT OF
WILDLIFE, URBAN INTERFACE ZONE,
A LOT OF BIG CATS, BEARS,
COYOTES, PEOPLE CONSTANTLY
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE PRESENCE OF
THESE ANIMALS WHO ARE VISIBLY
POISONED, OFTEN DYING AROUND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE SEE DEAD
OWLS AND DEAD HAWKS FREQUENTLY
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD, COYOTE WITH
WHAT LOOKS LIKE MANGE. THAT IS
RODENTICIDE POISONING. WHEN P-22
WAS CAPTURED, THEY TESTED HIS
BLOOD, AND HE HAD EXTENSIVE
AMOUNTS OF LIVER DAMAGE FROM
RODENTICIDES FROM EATING
POISONED RATS. WE ALSO HAVE THE
FAMOUS PHOTO OF HIM WITH THE
RODENTICIDE INDUCED MANGE WHERE
HE LOOKED SO SICK. OUR WILDLIFE
IS ALREADY AT THE BREAKING POINT
IN MANY OF OUR AREAS, AND NOW WE
ARE POISONING THEM. AND THERE'S
REALLY NO REASON BECAUSE THE
BEST WAY OF PREVENTING VERMIN IN
THESE AREAS IS ACTUALLY APEX
PREDATORS LIKE HAWKS AND
COYOTES. AND IF WE POISON THEM,
WE THROW THE WHOLE SYSTEM OUT OF
BALANCE. AND WE HAVE SEEN
EVIDENCE FROM STUDIES THAT WERE
DONE. THERE WAS A STUDY, I
BELIEVE, IN IRVINE, WHERE THEY
TESTED RODENTICIDE IN WATER, IN
A WATER DAM AGAINST PUTTING IN
SOME OWL AND, HAWK BOXES. AND
GUESS WHAT? ONE THE OWL AND THE
HAWK BOX AREA. THE THE RODENTS
WERE MUCH LESS FOR THAN IN THE
AREA WHERE THEY WERE USING THE
POISON, BECAUSE THEY WERE A
BETTER WAY OF KILLING THE, THE
PESTS. AS THE LA TIMES RECENTLY
HIGHLIGHTED, A NEW MOUNTAIN LION
WAS JUST FOUND IN GRIFFITH PARK.
WE WELCOME HIM OR HER AND WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
THAT BIG CAT A BETTER LIFE THAN
P-22 ENDURED THROUGH OUR
CONSTANT POISONING OF HIM. THERE
ARE A WIDE RANGE OF SAFER, MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVES TO THESE DANGEROUS
RODENTICIDES AVAILABLE FOR USE
TODAY. AND THESE ARE CHEMICALS
I'M NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT THE
ALL OWLS AND THE HAWKS. I'M
TALKING ABOUT ACTUAL POISONS
THAT ARE SAFER, THAT DON'T
BIOACCUMULATE IN THE SECONDARY
IN THE RATS AND POISON OTHER
ANIMALS. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
THIS AFTERNOON IS DOCTOR REBECCA
GULLEY, A SMITH FELLOW AND
POSTDOC AT UC DAVIS, AND
JONATHAN EVANS, AN ENVIRONMENTAL
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH LEGAL
DIRECTOR AND SENIOR ATTORNEY
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. AND I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR ALLEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR REBECCA GULLEY. I AM A
CONSERVATION SCIENTIST
INVESTIGATING THE SUBLETHAL
IMPACTS OF RODENTICIDES IN
CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE. THE
CALIFORNIA ECOSYSTEM PROTECTION
ACT OF 2020 RESTRICTED SECOND
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANTS.
HOWEVER, NECROPSIES PERFORMED BY
CDF W IN 2023 SHOWED ONGOING
WIDESPREAD POISONING OF
ANTICOAGULANTS. OVER 73% OF
WILDLIFE TESTED POSITIVE FOR
SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANTS, AND OVER 57%
TESTED POSITIVE FOR FIRST
GENERATION OAN, INCLUDING
CHLOROFORM, ACETONE, AND
WARFARIN. WHEN THESE POISONS
DON'T DIRECTLY KILL WILDLIFE,
THEY MAKE THEM SICK AND WEAK.
SUBLETHAL DOSES OF
ANTICOAGULANTS HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH LOWER IMMUNE
FUNCTION, INCREASED PARASITE AND
PATHOGEN LOAD, LOWERED EGG
HATCHING, AND LOWERED FLEDGING
SUCCESS FOR MOST WILDLIFE.
NATURAL HABITAT IS WHERE THEY
NEST AND REPRODUCE AND OFFSPRING
ARE PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE TO
THESE POISONS. THE HABITAT
BUFFER ZONE IS SCIENCE BASED. IT
CORRELATES TO THE HOME RANGES OF
COMMONLY AFFECTED WILDLIFE, SUCH
AS GREAT HORNED OWLS. BARN OWLS.
GRAY FOXES, AND RED TAILED
HAWKS. THIS IS CRUCIAL AS
DESPITE THE RESTRICTIONS, WE ARE
STILL SEEING WIDESPREAD EXPOSURE
TO ALL ANTICOAGULANTS. THE USE
OF THESE ANTICOAGULANT ALSO POSE
A PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN. IN A
2021 STUDY BY MURRAY AND
SANCHEZ, IT WAS FOUND THAT
POISONED RATS WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE LIKELY TO BE INFECTED WITH
LEPTOSPIRA THAN NON POISONED
RATS. RODENT FERTILITY CONTROL
SUCCESSFULLY REDUCES RODENT
NUMBERS, BUT IT DOES NOT DISRUPT
THEIR IMMUNE SYSTEM LIKE POISONS
DO. IN A 2022 STUDY BY WRAY AND
PISCINA, PUBLISHED IN 18 MONTH
LONG STUDY THAT SHOWED RAT BIRTH
CONTROL AT A CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL FACILITY USED THIS,
AND THEY HAD A REDUCTION OF OVER
94% OF RAT ACTIVITY. THIS THIS
WAS NOTED BY THE FARM MANAGERS
TO BE SOMETHING THEY HAD BEEN
UNABLE TO ACHIEVE PRIOR. THE
ADDITION OF RODENT FERTILITY
CONTROL TO EXCLUSION AND BETTER
SANITATION PRACTICES WILL AID IN
A MORE SECURE FOOD SUPPLY. THERE
ARE ALTERNATIVES TO POISON, AND
WITH THIS BILL, CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE TOWARDS A MORE
BIODIVERSE FUTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, JONATHAN EVANS,
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH LEGAL
DIRECTOR AT THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES,
INCLUDING THOSE COVERED BY THE
POISON TREE WILDLIFE ACT OF
2024, ARE SOME OF THE MOST
SCIENTIFIC, STUDIED AND
WIDESPREAD WILDLIFE POISONS AND
COAGULANTS HAVE A UNIQUE MODE OF
TOXICITY THAT MAKES THEM
PARTICULARLY LETHAL TO OTHER
ANIMALS HIGHER IN THE FOOD CHAIN
BECAUSE THEY BIOACCUMULATE AND
CREATE A CUMULATIVE BODY BURDEN
IN WILDLIFE. HIGHER UP IN THE
FOOD WEB. THE POISONING IS
WIDESPREAD. AS DOCTOR GULLY
ALLUDED TO IN 2023, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE STUDIED ALL OF THE
NECROPSIES IT COULD OBTAIN IN
TERMS OF POISONED WILDLIFE, AND
ANTICOAGULANTS ARE FOUND IN OVER
88% OF BIRDS OF PREY LIKE HAWKS
AND OWLS, 80% OF LARGE GAME
MAMMALS, 86% OF BOBCATS,
INCLUDING THE VAST MAJORITY OF
MOUNTAIN LIONS, AND OVER 90% OF
GRAY FOXES. THE POISON FREE
WILDLIFE ACT WORKS STEPS
STEPWISE WITH PREVIOUS BILLS TO
ADD THE REMAINING ANTICOAGULANTS
TO THE EXISTING MORATORIUMS OF
AB 1788 AND AB 1322, ALLOWING
INDUSTRY TO INNOVATE AND MORE
FULLY ADOPT SUSTAINABLE
APPROACHES OVER SEVERAL YEARS,
AND REDUCING THE CUMULATIVE
THREATS TO NON-TARGET WILDLIFE.
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS WE SAW
WITH AB 1788, AB, AB 1322 THAT
REMOVING THESE ANTICOAGULANTS
WOULD RESULT IN PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS AND PLAGUES OF RATS HAVE
PROVEN UNTRUE, AND WE'LL HEAR
THE SAME ARGUMENTS TODAY.
IMPORTANTLY WE DON'T NEED THESE
DANGEROUS RODENTICIDES. THAT'S
WHY WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE ISSUE
ARISE WITH, WITH RODENT
INFESTATIONS THAT ARE CAUSING
PROBLEMS. SAFER, COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVES ARE READILY
AVAILABLE, NECESSARY, AND
FREQUENTLY USED ALREADY IN BIRTH
AND PEST CONTROL. SEALING
BUILDINGS AND ELIMINATING FOOD
AND WATER SOURCES ARE A
NECESSARY FIRST STEP. FERTILITY
CONTROL HAS PROVEN HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING RODENT
POPULATIONS, AND IS ALREADY IN
USE BY MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS. IN
CALIFORNIA, LETHAL RODENT
CONTROL STRATEGIES THAT INVOLVE
SNAP TRAPS AND ELECTRIC TRAPS
CAN THEN BE IMPLEMENTED FOR
UNDERGROUND RODENTS. YOU CAN
ALSO USE CARBON MONOXIDE, CARBON
DIOXIDE, AND IMPORTANTLY, THERE
ARE OVER 100 DIFFERENT
RODENTICIDE PRODUCTS. SOME
DISCUSSED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. ACUTE TOXICANTS THAT
WOULD STILL BE AVAILABLE AND
DON'T POSE AS GREAT OF A THREAT
TO CALIFORNIA ECOSYSTEMS. IF
THIS BILL PASSES, THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE SAFER. WE
SHOULD BE USING THEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND REDUCING
ANTICOAGULANTS, I URGE, AND I
VOIGTS I VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I
JUST WANT TO REINFORCE THAT
AGRICULTURE IS EXEMPTED. IT'S
JUST IT'S A 25 FOOT BUFFER ZONE
ONLY IF YOU'RE NEXT TO A
DESIGNATED WILDLIFE HABITAT
AREA. NOT ALL PARKS. IT HAS TO
BE A WILDLIFE HABITAT AREA.
LET'S HAVE LET'S HEAR FROM FOLKS
WHO WANT TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. MELISSA ROMERO,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
SUSAN MATTINAT HERE ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GIVE A
COURTESY TO FOR SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO, KAYLA
ROBINSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT, THANKS.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MATT
ROBINSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL, AS WELL AS THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES IN
SUPPORT. THANKS. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, PAUL GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF 1000 OAKS
AND SUPPORT BILL ALLIO EWG IN
SUPPORT K¾T JONES FROM JELLY'S
PLACE ANIMAL RESCUE AND ADOPTION
STRONG SUPPORT. NHIÀU. ON BEHALF
OF RAPTORS RESOLUTION AND
CO-SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. HI. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JERRY
FORGAS. I'M A PASSIONATE BIRD
WATCHER AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF WISDOM GOOD WORKS, AND
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING, JULIA SAXBY,
CONCERNED CITIZEN AND LAW
STUDENT, REPRESENTING THE ANIMAL
LAW AND ADVOCACY PROGRAM AT
BERKELEY LAW. STRONG SUPPORT
CARLA WEST ON BEHALF OF WILDLIFE
REFUGE AND STRONG SUPPORT I
ARIANA CREED WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS ORG AND SUPPORT. ALSO
THOSE IN SUPPORT ARE NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND CA
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO FACTS,
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, SONOMA SAS BEYOND
PESTICIDES, YARD SMART MARIN AND
MOMS ADVOCATING FOR
SUSTAINABILITY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. SEE, I TOLD YOU YOU
COULD HAVE STAYED. ALL RIGHT, I
SWEAR, I WORK ON OTHER ISSUES.
I'M FIGURING THE MORE I'M HERE,
MAYBE YOU GOT TO GIVE ME ONE.
YEAH, ONCE AGAIN, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. LAST TIME,
TAYLOR ROSEN, ON BEHALF OF THE
RODENTICIDE TASK FORCE IN A
SERIES OF AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS AND OPPOSITION TO
AB 2552, OUR OPPOSITION IS BASED
ON A SERIES OF FACTORS. FIRSTLY,
BECAUSE WE HAVE ROBUST
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES AND
ENFORCEMENT PROCEDURES FOR
ILLEGAL SALE, USE AND POSSESSION
OF PESTICIDES, INCLUDING
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES, AND
REPORTING WITH AG COMMISSIONERS,
DPR AND STRUCTURAL PEST
LICENSING BOARD. WE BELIEVE
IMPOSING ADDITIONAL CIVIL
PENALTIES AS PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL IS UNNECESSARY. WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS ARE BETTER VERSED IN
PESTICIDE ENFORCEMENT AND
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE AND VERIFY
COMPLAINTS VERSUS LOCAL CITY
ATTORNEYS, SECONDLY, WE OBJECT
TO THE BILL AS AN ABDICATION OF
THE PROCESS IN PLACE FOR
PESTICIDES TO BE PROHIBITED OR
USE LIMITED DPR HAS A PROCEDURE
IN PLACE TO REVIEW WILDLIFE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS, INCLUDING
ON NON-TARGET SPECIES AND WHEN
LEGITIMATE INFORMATION IS
PRESENTED, DPR IS OBLIGATED TO
REVIEW AND MITIGATE OR CANCEL
PRODUCTS. THE SPONSORS ARE WELL
SUITED TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THAT PROCESS, BUT HERE WE HAVE
LEGISLATION WHICH SEEMS TO BE
THE THEME OF TODAY'S HEARING, I
WANT TO CORRECT THE RECORD. ALL
PESTICIDES ARE BANNED FOR USE IN
CALIFORNIA UNTIL THEY'RE
REGISTERED FOR USE AND DEEMED
SAFE. AND RATHER THAN PRESENT A
BILL THAT OBLIGATES DPR TO
REREVIEW THAT DATA OR NEW DATA
AND ISSUE A NEW DETERMINATION TO
THE LEGISLATURE OR THE PUBLIC BY
A CERTAIN DATE, WHICH HAS BEEN
DONE ON RODENTICIDES
HISTORICALLY AND YIELDED RESULTS
. AB 2552 BANS THESE PRODUCTS
OUTRIGHT ONCE AGAIN, WE BELIEVE
OUR AGENCIES ARE BEST SUITED TO
OPINE ON SCIENCE AND IT'S THE
LEGISLATURE'S PREROGATIVE TO
DIRECT THEM TO DO THAT WORK,
FINALLY, WE'D LIKE TO HIRE,
HIGHLIGHT SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH
THE AGRICULTURAL EXEMPTION THAT
HAS BEEN ERODED FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IN THIS BILL, WHEN
THE ORIGINAL SECOND GENERATION
BAN WAS CONTEMPLATED AND EVEN
THE AUTHOR CARRIED A BILL LAST
YEAR UNTIL OAN, THE
AGRICULTURAL EXEMPTION WAS
MAINTAINED IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCE
. REYES. THIS IS BECAUSE KEEPING
OUR FARMS AND OUR FOOD
FACILITIES FREE FROM RATS IS NOT
JUST GOOD BUSINESS SENSE, IT'S A
PUBLIC HEALTH NECESSITY. RATS
DESTROY INFRASTRUCTURE, SPREAD
FECES AND URINE AND CARE AND
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES THAT WE
CAN'T OTHERWISE CONTROL, AND TO
BE CLEAR, THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
STATES AND THE BILL ANALYSIS
CONFIRMS THAT THE AGRICULTURAL
EXEMPTION IS FOR ALL
ANTICOAGULANTS. SO WE'RE NOT
JUST TALKING ABOUT WARFARIN AND
CHLOROACETONE. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL OF THE OTHER
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES THAT
ARE THERE AS WELL, WHICH WOULD
NO LONGER BE ELIGIBLE FOR USE ON
YOUR FARM, RANCH, COLD STORAGE
OR FOOD PROCESSING FACILITIES
WITHIN A HALF A MILE OF A PARK
OR A WILDLIFE REFUGE. WE'VE
PROVIDED YOUR OFFICES, OUR
VERSION OF MAPS THAT ARE
STATEWIDE THAT SHOW WHERE
PROHIBITION WOULD BE LIMITED,
WOULD BE LIMITED TO, AND WHAT WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY
NOT BE MANY NATIONAL FORESTS AND
SENATOR HURTADO'S DISTRICT.
THERE DEFINITELY ARE. AND
SENATOR DALI'S AND THE ENTIRE
COUNTY FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE. AND
SENATOR DALI'S DISTRICT WOULD BE
BANNED FOR USE FROM THESE
PRODUCTS. AND THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODS LIKE RAT FERTILITY
CONTROL, REMOVING DEBRIS,
RESTRICTING RODENT ACCENTS THAT
HAS BEEN SUGGESTED ARE NOT IN
THE REALM OF REALITY IN FARMING
OR ALREADY HAS HAPPENED. AND
EVEN THE NON COAGULANT CHEMICAL
ALTERNATIVES AREN'T ALL
REGISTERED FOR AGRICULTURAL USE
AND COME WITH SIGNIFICANT TRADE
OFFS, WHICH THE ANALYSIS NOTES
NEUROTOXICITY, NON-TARGET
SPECIES EXPOSURE, PRODUCTS
WITHOUT ANTIDOTES AND AS
EVIDENCED BY THE HISTORY ON THIS
ISSUE, WE HAVE NO CONFIDENCE
THAT EVEN THOSE PRODUCTS WON'T
BE TAKEN AWAY BY THIS
LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR. WE
REQUEST A STOP TO THE WHACK A
MOLE APPROACH OF REMOVING
PRODUCTS. ONE ACTIVE INGREDIENT
AT A TIME THAT KEEP US SAFE AND
LET THE SCIENCE LEAD US. SO FOR
THESE REASONS, WE REQUEST A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU DENNIS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SEED
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA GROWERS,
BUT ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
WAREHOUSE ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA WAREHOUSE ASSOCIATION
IS THE RICE DRYERS AND, HANDLERS
OF RICE PRODUCTS. AND SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT'S INCONVENIENT
ABOUT BEING IN AGRICULTURE AND
BEING IN RICE COUNTRY, AS ONE
EXAMPLE, IS THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
IN THE PARK NATURE INTERFACE,
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ACT, THAT'S
WHERE WE GO. WE ACTUALLY FEED
QUITE A BIT OF THE HABITAT AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA
. SO THE RICE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN,
YOU KNOW, VERY WELL PRAISED FOR
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL,
TRANSFORMATION OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES. AND YET THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY STILL AN IN THAT
INTERFACE. AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THESE RICE WAREHOUSE DRYERS,
WHICH, WHICH WOULD BE EXEMPT BY
THE BILL, EXCEPT FOR THE HALF
MILE AROUND, A WILDLIFE
SITUATION, AND THAT'S WHERE
THERE ARE REFUGES ALL OVER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE PROMOTE
THEM. THERE IS YOU KNOW, DUCK
HUNTING FACILITIES THAT ARE
OWNED AND MANAGED AND OPERATED
BY THE STATE AND THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE ENTITIES. AND SO THAT'S
WHERE IT STARTS TO BECOME VERY,
SIGNIFICANT INTO THE IMPACT ON
THOSE SPECIFIC ENTITIES. USING
RICE AS AN EXAMPLE, THE OTHER
ISSUE I'D LIKE TO BRING FORWARD
IS THE FURTHER WE RESTRICT THE
MATERIALS OUTSIDE OF
AGRICULTURE, FOR INSTANCE, THE
LESS AVAILABLE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE AND THE LESS AVAILABLE THAT
THAT KNEW THAT ENTITIES WILL
COME IN AND TRY TO GET MORE
BENIGN PRODUCTS REGISTERED THAT
MAY HAVE A SMALLER DOSE OR A
DIFFERENT, DIFFERENT
FORMULATION, BECAUSE IF THEY CAN
ONLY USE IT IN THESE TWO LITTLE
NARROW SECTORS OF THE INDUSTRY,
Kò, THAT'S THEIR ENTIRE MARKET.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS SIGNIFICANT
MORE RESTRICTIONS AND BARRIERS
TO ENTRY INTO THE MARKET FOR NEW
PRODUCTS. AND FINALLY, I'D JUST
LIKE TO BRING UP THAT, YOU KNOW,
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE. AND
THAT'S THE WAY THEY'RE
CATEGORIZED DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
FIRST GENERATION AND SECOND
GENERATION. AND, YOU KNOW, MR.
BLUM CARRIED THIS AND WE WORKED
WITH HIM CLOSELY. AND HIS, YOU
KNOW, HIS POLITICAL CORPSE IS
NOT EVEN AN ENTIRE SESSION
THROUGH. AND WE'RE BACK TO THE
OTHER ONES THAT COME FORWARD.
AND SO, WE THERE WAS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WENT INTO THOSE
PREVIOUS ONES THAT, THAT BAN THE
ONE, ELEMENT OF ANTICOAGULANTS.
AND SO, AGAIN, WE NEED TO LOOK
TO THE SCIENCE, LOOK TO DPR.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE THERE FOR.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE SCIENCE
PERSONS. AND FOLLOW THAT LEAD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HOPEFULLY
HIS CORPSE ISN'T SUFFERING FROM
MANGE. FAIR ENOUGH. JUST AN
OVERBURDENED COURT IN NORTHERN
LA COUNTY. YOU CAN STAY UP HERE
IF YOU WANT. LET'S JUST HEAR
FROM, FOLKS WHO WANT TO WEIGH IN
IN OPPOSITION. EXPRESS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS BROWN,
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION IN
OPPOSITION. I'M NOT GOING TO LET
YOU GUYS ESCAPE THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT. MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ALSO OPPOSED. THANKS
THANK YOU. KIRK WILBUR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. PATRICIA GERINGER,
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
. GOOD MORNING, MICHAEL MILLER,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. MARGIE, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION CHRIS RIORDAN,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU, OPPOSED.
GEORGE QUINTO WITH THE ALMOND
ALLIANCE, ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. LINDSAY CARTER,
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION, OPPOSED. DOMINIC
DEMAR HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS OF
CALIFORNIA. DISRESPECTFULLY. NO.
JUST KIDDING. RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. I SAW THE BIG RADISHES.
YES. YEAH. RESPECTFULLY ALL
RIGHT, DISCUSSION FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THIS IS I JUST WANT
TO ASK ONE QUESTION. I NOTICED
WHEN THE ASSERTION WAS MADE THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO IMPACT NEARLY
ALL OF SENATOR DAHLE COUNTY. I
SAW SOME OF YOU SHAKE YOUR
HEADS. I JUST WANTED TO GET SOME
CLARITY ON. OBVIOUSLY THIS THIS
MAP IS INTERESTING. IT'S A VERY
PARTICULAR PART OF THE STATE,
WOULD LOVE TO MAYBE ASK ABOUT TO
CLARIFY, YOU KNOW, STATE LAW
CAN'T CONTROL FEDERAL LANDS.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS CONTROL
OVER FEDERAL LANDS. THIS WE
CANNOT AS A LEGISLATURE, STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, CONTROL WHAT
HAPPENS THERE. WE HAVE NO
AUTHORITY OVER THAT. SO THAT'S
CLEARLY, PATENTLY WRONG. BUT HOW
? BUT BUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
REFUGES, I SHOULD PROBABLY KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THIS. BUT I CAN I
CAN CLARIFY WHAT THOSE WILDLIFE
HABITAT AREAS ARE DEFINED UNDER
THE BILL. SURE. WILDLIFE HABITAT
AREA UNDER THE BILL MEANS A PARK
OR WILDLIFE REFUGE MANAGED BY A
STATE AGENCY, REGIONAL
GOVERNMENT OR QUASI GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCY, OR BY A SPECIAL
DISTRICT. ONLY THING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS JURISDICTION
OVER NATIONAL WILDLIFE REFUGES.
NATIONAL PARKS. BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT AREAS. NATIONAL
FORESTS ARE NOT COVERED BY THIS
BILL, SO THE WILDLIFE HABITAT
AREA IS JUST THINGS THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS CONTROL
OVER. AND IT'S AND IT'S, YOU
KNOW, SUBAGENCIES. AND ALSO THE
BUFFER ZONE WOULD ONLY BE AROUND
THOSE WILDLIFE HABITAT AREAS
THEMSELVES. SO THERE WOULD NOT
BE BUFFER ZONES AS THE BILL IS,
IS DRAFTED NOW AROUND THOSE
FEDERAL LANDS BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF OVERSIGHT. THE STATE CAN
PROVIDE. LET ME JUST PUSH BACK
ON THAT. WHY? WHY ISN'T IT THE
WHAT? WE STILL HAVE REGULATORY
POWER OVER THE LAND THAT'S NEAR
FEDERAL LAND. CORRECT. AND THAT
IS A DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD. AND
DISCUSSION THAT'S ONGOING WITH
THE COMMITTEES. BUT TO DATE, THE
BILL AS DRAFTED DOES NOT HAVE
THAT LANGUAGE OF BUFFER ZONES
AROUND FEDERAL AREAS. IT'S A
LARGE AREA. YOU KNOW, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF CONCERNS RAISED. AND SO
THAT'S PART OF THE NEGOTIATION.
SO I MEAN, IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS NATIONAL RECREATION
AREA, WE HAVE THERE'S NATIONAL
PARK SERVICE LAND. THERE'S STATE
LAND. SO YOUR YOU'RE ABLE TO
APPLY THE RODENTICIDE NEXT TO
THE NATIONAL PARK SERVICE LAND
IN THE MOUNTAINS, BUT NOT THE
STATE PARK LAND AS DRAFTED UNDER
THIS BILL. I MEAN, WE THE
WILDLIFE HABITAT AREA, IT
DEPENDS ON WHETHER THERE MAY BE
OVERLAP AND WHAT SPECIFICALLY
THE JURISDICTION IS. SO IF
THERE'S A THERE'S A, A LOCAL
SPECIAL DISTRICT, YOU KNOW,
ADJACENT TO THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS THAT WE, THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE CONTROL OVER
THAT. BUT JUST AS THE BILL IS
DRAFTED RIGHT NOW, IT DOES NOT
HAVE THE BUFFER AROUND FEDERAL
LANDS. #UST WANT TO
THAT, JUST TO BE CLEAR, THERE'S
114 OTHER PESTICIDES THAT CAN BE
RODENTICIDES THAT CAN BE USED IN
THESE BUFFERS. THE BILL ONLY IS
BANNING THE ANTICOAGULANTS. SO
IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE SAYING YOU
CAN'T USE RAT KILLER IN THESE
BUFFERS. WE'RE SAYING DON'T USE
THE RODENTICIDE BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT'S PARTICULARLY HARMFUL TO
NON-TARGET WILDLIFE. SO I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR. THIS IS NOT A
BAN ON RAT POISON IN THESE
BUFFERS. ONLY ON RODENTICIDE.
RAT POISON ONLY ON ANTICOAGULANT
RAT POISON. OKAY. YES. SENATOR
HURTADO, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN
LEARNING A LITTLE BIT. I MEAN,
IT'S THIS MAP SEEMS VERY
TARGETED, AND ACTUALLY, IT'S
MAJORITY OF MY SENATE DISTRICT
AND SO I KNOW THAT THE ARGUMENT
WAS MADE THAT IT WAS MORE SO,
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT THIS
THIS MAP TELLS ME THAT IT'S A
LOT OF MY DISTRICT AND, AND I
HEARD FROM TESTIMONY TODAY THAT
A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
FACING COME FROM COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE NOT IN THIS AREA. SO
I'M JUST I'VE NEVER HEARD FROM
MY CONSTITUENTS OF THESE SIMILAR
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE, TRYING TO
ALLEVIATE HERE. AND SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY THE
NEED HERE, WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD?
HAVE YOU HEARD, I MEAN, BECAUSE
IT JUST IT SEEMS A LITTLE. WE
JUST WANTED TO SHOW WHAT THE
BUFFER LOOKED LIKE IN AN
AGRICULTURAL AREA BECAUSE
AGRICULTURE IS EXEMPTED. SO IF
WE HAD DONE A MAP FOR OUR AREA,
WE DON'T, YOU KNOW, MY DISTRICT,
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH AGRICULTURE,
SO IT WOULDN'T HAVE GIVEN
THERE'S NO BUFFER. I MEAN,
THERE'S NO BUFFER AROUND A FARM
IN MY DISTRICT. WE WERE TRYING
TO SHOW A TYPICAL WE HAVE DONE
THE MAPPING FOR SENATOR DALY'S
DISTRICT. WE CAN SHOW YOU THAT
IT LOOKS THE SAME IN TERMS OF
THE AMOUNT OF AREA THAT IT'S
COVERING, BECAUSE IN IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS, PEOPLE WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND WITH THE BUFFERS HOW
MUCH AGRICULTURAL LAND IS
ACTUALLY IN THE BUFFER. THAT'S
WHY WE PICKED AN AREA THAT WAS
HEAVILY AGRICULTURAL. IT'S YOUR
DISTRICT. WE CAN PROVIDE THIS TO
SENATOR DALY. WE CAN PROVIDE FOR
ANYBODY. BUT THE ISSUES ARE THE
SAME. ANY PLACE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE WILDLIFE
ENCOUNTERING ANTICOAGULANTS,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF POISONINGS. AND WHAT'S
WHAT IS AROUND THESE BUFFERS IS
ARE THESE WILDLIFE HABITAT AREAS
AROUND THEM? SO WHAT'S AROUND
THESE? THIS IS THE WILDLIFE
HABITAT AREA. SO YOU HAVE
WILDLIFE THERE. YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE BIG CATS. YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE OWLS. YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A HIGH PREPONDERANCE OF WILDLIFE
BECAUSE THEY ARE HABITAT AREAS.
SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO SHOW HOW
MUCH LAND IS HOW MUCH
AGRICULTURE, WHAT THE BUFFERS
LOOK LIKE IN YOUR DISTRICT. BUT
THE IMPACT IS DIFFERENT FROM,
YOU KNOW, YOUR DISTRICT, FOR
EXAMPLE. WELL, THE IMPACT FROM
FROM ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES
IS THE SAME ANYWHERE THERE'S
WILDLIFE. YEAH. I MEAN, I, I'VE
NEVER HEARD A COMPLAINT FROM ANY
CONSTITUENT IN MY DISTRICT. SO
THAT'S I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO GET AT IS THAT IF
YOU'VE HEARD ANY, ANY CONCERNS
COMING OUT OF, YOU KNOW, THIS
PARTICULAR REGION, SO WE HAVE,
COUNTY BY COUNTY DATA THAT I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH
YOU, I THINK BAKERSFIELD. IS
THAT IN YOUR DISTRICT? YEAH, WE
DO HAVE A LOT OF, POISONING
NECROPSIES COMING IN FROM CDF W
THEY GET REPORTED EVERY YEAR,
AND I HAVE A HUGE SPREADSHEET
THAT I'M HAPPY TO SHARE WITH
PEOPLE. SO I CAN GIVE YOU THE
EXACT NUMBERS. I DON'T KNOW IT
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD, BUT WE
DEFINITELY HAVE, WILDLIFE
GETTING POISONED IN BAKERSFIELD
AND CONFIRMING THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN KIT FOX, ISN'T IT?
SAMKIN KIT FOX IS A LOVELY
ENDANGERED SPECIES IN YOUR
DISTRICT. WE HAVE CONFIRMED
NECROPSIES OF MORTALITY TO KIT
FOX FROM ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES. SO IT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S OCCURRING EVERYWHERE. THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, SENATOR FRIEDMAN'S
DISTRICT DOESN'T HAVE AS MUCH
AGRICULTURE. SO AND ALL THE
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL USES
ARE PROHIBITED WITH UNDER THIS
BILL AS WELL. SO THAT WOULD BE
IN YOUR TOWN AS WELL AS IN THE
TOWN THAT YOU REPRESENT AS WELL
AS OTHER OTHER TOWNS. YES. IN
OTHER WORDS, IN MY DISTRICT,
IT'S MORE OF A BAN BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE EXCEPT FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IS EXEMPTED,
WE'RE TRYING TO, BUT BUT
AGRICULTURE IS EXEMPTED FROM OUR
BILL, SO THE FARMS CAN ALL STILL
USE THE ANTICOAGULANTS IN YOUR
DISTRICT. THIS IS SHOWING YOU
THE AREAS WHERE THEY COULDN'T
USE IT. AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
SHOW THAT IT'S NOT A HUGE AMOUNT
OF PROPERTY. YOU KNOW, GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF AGRICULTURE IN THE
AREA. I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT. I OBVIOUSLY WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL. I WITH
ALL THE THINGS I SAID BEFORE,
BUT ONE THING I DID WANT TO SAY
IS WHEN WE DID THE BILL CAME
THROUGH LAST TIME WITH,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLUM, ONE OF THE,
ONE OF THE THINGS WAS THAT I
KNOW IS VERY PREVALENT IN MY
DISTRICT IS, ILLEGAL MARIJUANA
GROWS WHERE THEY USE A TON OF
THIS STUFF THAT IS NOT LEGAL.
AND THEY'RE NOT. SO WE HAVE FOR
OUR AGRICULTURAL STORAGE
FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE, I HAVE
TO WE GO, WE GET A PERMIT, WE GO
DO ALL THE SAME THINGS WE DID
WITH OUR APPLICATORS PERMIT FOR,
ANTICOAGULANTS, BUT THE USE OF
ILLEGAL ANTICOAGULANTS IS HUGE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND
THERE'S REALLY NO WAY TO KNOW
UNTIL YOU TILL THEY GO OUT AND
ENFORCE, WHICH IS A COUNTY
PERSON THAT DOES CODE
ENFORCEMENT VIOLATION,
TYPICALLY. BUT IN MANY OF OUR
CASES, WE FOUND REALLY I MEAN,
BAGS OF ANTICOAGULANTS THAT
WEREN'T EVEN SOLD IN CALIFORNIA,
THEY'RE COMING FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
USING IT THERE IN OUR WATERSHED.
AND, AND SO I JUST WANT TO, FOR
THE RECORD, GO. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO THIS THIS IS GOING TO GO
AFTER PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO GO GET
PERMITS, NOT PEOPLE THAT THAT DO
IT ILLEGALLY. TO GO AFTER THEM
TO, OKAY. YEAH. WELL, WE NEED TO
WE THERE'S A LOT OF ENFORCEMENT
WE NEED TO DO UP IN, MARIJUANA
GROW COMPANY. GOOD COUNTRY.
YEAH, YEAH. SERIOUSLY OKAY.
WELL, ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
THOUGHTS OR MOTION FROM MEMBERS,
OKAY. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THIS IS A DO PASS TO
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER WILL LET YOU CLOSE. THANK
YOU. AND THE REASON FOR THIS
BILL IS BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE BEEN DOING WORK ON
RODENTICIDE, WE ARE STILL SEEING
A LOT OF POISONINGS, UNINTENDED
POISONINGS THROUGH NECROPSIES.
AND WE THINK THAT WE'VE STRUCK A
REALLY GOOD BALANCE BY EXEMPTING
AGRICULTURE. REALLY, THE FIGHT
IS OVER. THIS LITTLE RINGS THAT
YOU SEE ON THERE. AND GIVEN THAT
THERE'S 114 OTHER LETHAL,
RODENTICIDES THAT CAN BE USED,
WE THINK THAT THIS IS VERY
REASONABLE, VERY SENSIBLE, NOT
GOING TO DRIVE ANYBODY OUT OF
BUSINESS. THAT'S NOT A THIS
SHOULDN'T BE A HARDSHIP. BUT IT
COULD, YOU KNOW, GIVEN THAT
WE'RE ABUTTING HABITATS WHERE
WE'VE TOLD ANIMALS COME AND LIVE
HERE, HERE'S YOUR HABITAT, AND
THEN WE'RE BRINGING THIS REALLY
TOXIC POISON IN WHERE THESE RATS
STUMBLE INTO THE FOREST NOW, AND
THEY'RE SICK AND THEY GET EATEN
AND THEY POISON THESE OTHER
ANIMALS. AND WE KNOW THAT
THROUGH NECROPSIES, THROUGH
BLOOD TESTS. DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
FILL. THIS IS OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
SORRY. THAT'S OKAY. THIS IS, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS UNNECESSARY. IT'S SORT
OF LOW HANGING FRUIT OF ANIMAL
PROTECTION. AND I WOULD REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU,
BUT NOT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TELLS THEM TO GO LIVE
THERE. THEN THAT'S A YOU KNOW,
WE ARE VERY OPEN TO DO, YOU
KNOW, TO PUTTING A BUFFER AROUND
THE FEDERAL FOREST. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THAT. BUT,
YOU KNOW, AS OF NOW, IT IS NOT
COVERED UNDER THIS BILL. YEAH.
I'D LOVE IT IF WE COULD JUST
ALSO LOOK AT SOME OF THE NATURAL
NATIONAL RECREATION AREAS WHERE
THERE IS THIS MIXED OWNERSHIP,
THERE'S VERY LIMITED USE ON
FEDERAL LANDS. THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH, OF COURSE, OF COURSE,
BUT BUT THE BUT THE ADJACENT TO
FEDERAL LANDS IS I MEAN, I CARE
ABOUT THOSE LANDS TOO. SO
ANYHOW, IT'S BEEN MOVED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB 2552. DO PASS TWO. SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I. DALI.
NO. DALI. NO. GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HURTADO. NO MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
NGUYEN. NGUYEN. NO. SKINNER ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SO WE'VE GOT A
COUPLE MORE MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
ALL RIGHT. SO MEMBER TANG, SORRY
TO ROPE YOU BACK, BUT YOU'RE OUR
YOU'RE OUR NEXT AUTHOR. SO WELL,
I LEARNED SOMETHING TODAY ABOUT
PESTICIDES, SO IT'S HELPFUL, IF
IT'S OKAY WITH YOU, MR. CHAIR,
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT AB 347. OH,
REALLY? YEAH OH. STATEWIDE OF
NATIONAL. MR. VICE CHAIR, IT'S
VERY ANXIOUS TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, SO. WELL.
OKAY, GOOD. ALL RIGHT. IT FEELS
GOOD SOMETIMES. LET'S, LET'S
JUST CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH YOUR
FORBEARANCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OKAY. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF FIVE ITEMS. NUMBER
SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE, 14, 15, 16,
17, AND 19. SENATORS ALLEN, A,
ALLEN I, DALLI, DALLI I,
GONZALEZ, HURTADO, HURTADO I,
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NGUYEN
NGUYEN I, SKINNER. ALL RIGHT. SO
SENATOR DALLI IS ON THE RECORD
VOTING. I HERE WE GO. LET'S GO
TO ITEM TWO. THAT'S AB 347, MORE
TOXICS. THERE WE GO. YEAH.
GREAT. THAT IS THIS COMMITTEE.
RIGHT. SO FIRST LET ME THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. WE ARE ACCEPTING ALL
OF THEM EXCEPT FOR THE AMENDMENT
ON COOKWARE, WHICH WE WERE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE ON. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR, YOUR PATIENCE
ON THAT ISSUE. SO, AB 347 WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
AND SUBSTANCE CONTROL TO TEST,
ENFORCE AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH ALL EXISTING LAWS
REGULATING THE USE OF PFAS
CHEMICALS AND FOOD PACKAGING,
COSMETICS, JUVENILE PRODUCTS AND
TEXTILES. WE PASSED NUMEROUS
LAWS ON PFAS AND GETTING PFAS
OUT OF PRODUCTS, AS WELL AS
REGULATING PFAS. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DTSC HAS THE
AUTHORITY AND THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY TEST PRODUCTS AND MAKE
SURE THERE'S COMPLIANCE, THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY ESTABLISHES A
REGISTRATION AND TESTING PROCESS
FOR THE COVERED PRODUCTS WITH
THE FEE REQUIRES DTSC TO PUBLISH
A LIST OF ACCEPTED METHODS. IT
PERMITS DTSC TO TEST PRODUCTS
FOR COMPLIANCE. IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES AN ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS AND ESTABLISHES A BASE
ENFORCEMENT FUND AND A VAST FINE
ACCOUNT. AND ALSO. LASTLY, IT
ASKS DTSC TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
STAKEHOLDERS, APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE WITH THIS
BILL. AND AGAIN, THIS BILL IS
MERELY TAKING ALL THE GOOD WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS, MAKING SURE THERE'S A
CLEAR ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM AND
THAT THE AGENCY IS EMPOWERED TO
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE TASKED, SOMEONE IN THE
STATE TO GO DO WITH THAT RESPECT
HAS ASKED FOR I VOTE ON AB 347,
NO WITNESSES, JUST, MOVING ON
FROM THERE. GREAT, ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL AT THE MIC. ERIKA
PARKER WITH CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE NO CONCERNS THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. NO CONCERNS THIS
TIME. OKAY SUPPORT, I ASSUME.
ARIANA CREED WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS .ORG IN SUPPORT. ALSO
THOSE IN SUPPORT OR NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND CA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS, ACTIVISTS
AND ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO FACTS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND JUSTICE
SONOMA SAS BEYOND PESTICIDES,
YARD SMART MARIN AND MOMS
ADVOCATING FOR SUSTAINABILITY.
THANK YOU. GREAT KAYLA ROBINSON
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPOST COALITION SUPPORT.
THANKS JORDAN WELLS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. BILL ALLIO
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
OUR OTHER. BETWEEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION, WE STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS, BUT WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR GETTING
ENFORCEMENT AND DTSC GETTING IT
TOGETHER AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE STILL A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WAY COSMETICS ARE
HANDLED IN TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT.
WE'RE WORKING WITH HIS STAFF FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S HEAR
FROM OPPONENTS. ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. COME ON UP. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD
MORNING. MANDY ISAACS LEE OMNI
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL FOR THE
NATIONAL TRADE, FOR THE PERSONAL
CARE AND BEAUTY INDUSTRY, FIRST,
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR AN EXCELLENT AND THOROUGH
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL AND THE
TIME THAT THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF HAS TAKEN TO DISCUSS OUR
ISSUE, AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE THE NON PFAS INGREDIENTS
FROM BEING IN SCOPE AND AB 347,
WE ARE STILL CONTINUING TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INCLUSION OF
COSMETICS IN THIS REGULATORY AND
ENFORCEMENT STRUCTURE. I JUST
WANT TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT ON, ON WHY
IT IS THAT WE HAVE THIS POSITION
, BACK IN 2022, WE NEGOTIATED IN
GOOD FAITH WITH NGOS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AND THE
ULTIMATE CONSTRUCT IN AB 2771
WAS ONE THAT OUR MEMBERS COULD
WORK WITH. WE AGREED TO PHASE
OUT THE, THE USE OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS IN
COSMETICS AND THAT BAN IS
EFFECTIVE JANUARY 1ST, 2025. AND
YOU KNOW, WHAT IS IMPLICIT IN
THIS IS THE AGREEMENT THAT TRACE
AND TECHNICALLY UNAVOIDABLE PFAS
WAS SORT OF GOING TO BE IN OUR
PRODUCTS REGARDLESS OF WHAT
HAPPENED. AND SO THE
INTENTIONALLY ADDED VERBIAGE IN
TWO, SEVEN, SEVEN ONE WAS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. FOR THAT
REASON, TO ENSURE THAT A PRIMARY
INGREDIENT INGREDIENT IN OUR
PRODUCTS, SUCH AS WATER, WHICH
AS WE KNOW, YOU KNOW,
UNFORTUNATELY CONTAINS PFAS
WOULD NOT TRIP US UP FROM A
COMPLIANCE STANDPOINT. AND THE
AUTHOR A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO IN
COMMITTEE TESTIFIED TO THAT
EFFECT. SHE SHE ACTUALLY SAID,
AND I QUOTE, I DON'T WANT THE
MANUFACTURERS TO BE HELD LIABLE
SIMPLY FOR THE INCLUSION OF
WATER IN THEIR PRODUCTS. SO WE
CAN'T BE HELD LIABLE FOR THINGS
BEYOND OUR CONTROL, WHICH IS
WHAT THE ULTIMATE CONSTRUCT OF
2771 ACKNOWLEDGED. IT'S ALSO
BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED THAT PFAS
IS PERSISTENT AND UBIQUITOUS AND
EVER PRESENT EVERYWHERE, IT'S IN
OUR WATER SOURCES. IT'S IN THE
AIR. AND ABSENT A WAY TO
COMPLETELY ERADICATE PFAS, THERE
WILL ALWAYS BE TRACE LEVELS OF
PFAS IN OUR PRODUCTS, I WOULD
ALSO WELCOME ANYBODY ON THIS
DAIS AND THE COMMITTEE TO GO
BACK TO THEIR OFFICES, PULL OUT
YOUR LOTION, TURN IT AROUND,
LOOK AT THE INGREDIENT LIST. AND
WATER WILL BE THE TOP, IF NOT
THE FIRST TWO THREE INGREDIENTS
ON THAT PRODUCT. SO ABSENT A WAY
TO ERADICATE PFAS FROM OUR
PRODUCTS, WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE
TRACE LEVELS IN IT. FURTHERMORE,
UNLIKE THE OTHER PRODUCT
CATEGORIES AS ACKNOWLEDGED IN
PAGE NINE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS, YOU KNOW, OUR OUR PFAS
BAN WAS DIFFERENT. ALL THE OTHER
PRODUCT CATEGORIES, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF COOKWARE, HAD A DE
MINIMIS LEVEL OF ALLOWABLE PFAS
IN THEIR 100 PMS WAS THE
STANDARD, AS YOU CAN SEE. AND SO
WITHOUT THAT, PARTS PER MILLION
APPLICABLE TO COSMETICS, WE'RE
REALLY UNCLEAR HOW DTSC IS GOING
TO DETERMINE INTENT BANALITY. IF
WE ACTUALLY ADDED THE PFAS
INTENTIONALLY AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE
WITHOUT THAT DE MINIMIS PARTS
PER MILLION PRESCRIBED IN OUR IN
OUR STATUTE. AND BECAUSE OUR
STATUTE IS ONLY INTENTIONALLY
ADDED TO PFAS, THAT'S PROHIBITED
FROM OUR PRODUCTS, IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANUFACTURERS OR DEPARTMENT OR
MANUFACTURERS IS GOING TO PROVE
THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
SPECIFICATION. TEST RESULTS WILL
NOT PROVE IF THE PFAS WAS ADDED
INTENTIONALLY. THIS IS ACTUALLY
A DIRECT QUOTE FROM THE FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. SO, YOU
KNOW, FOR THESE REASONS, WE
REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS COSMETICS
IS REMOVED FROM FROM THE
STRUCTURE, YOU KNOW, IT CREATES
A GREAT LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY,
UNCERTAINTY FOR OUR PRODUCTS.
AND FOR THESE REASONS, WE ASKED
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. MANDY.
OKAY BUT GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS.
ROB SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. AND LET ME JUST
START BY SAYING CMTA AND OUR,
OUR COALITION PARTNERS, EXCUSE
ME, ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED, TO THIS BILL FOR
CMTA AND OUR COALITION PARTNERS.
WE HAVE LONG SAID IN ALL OF
THESE ONE OFF PFAS BANS THAT WE
NEED REGULATORY OVERSIGHT AND
GUIDANCE PROVIDED BY ANY NUMBER
OF REGULATORY AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA, IN CALIFORNIA, TO
PROVIDE SOME VERY DIRECT,
MEANINGFUL, CLARITY SURROUNDING
THE REGULATORY ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS, AS WELL AS TESTING
PROTOCOLS SURROUNDING EACH ONE
OF THESE COVERED PRODUCTS. SO,
347, WE CAN CERTAINLY SAY, IS AN
ATTEMPT AT GETTING THERE. IT'S
DEFINITELY COVERING THE BILLS
THAT ARE MENTIONED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BEING AB 1817
RELATED TO TEXTILES, 2007 71 TO
COSMETIC COSMETICS, AB 652 TO
JUVENILE PRODUCTS, AS WELL AS AB
1200 RELATED TO COOKWARE AND
PLANT BASED FOOD PACKAGING.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS FROM COMMITTEE, I
WILL SAY THAT OUR COALITION, AS
YOU KNOW, AS OF THIS MORNING AND
JUST RECENTLY WERE DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE AUTHOR NOT ACCEPTING
THE COOKWARE LABELING
REQUIREMENTS OR THE COOKWARE
AMENDMENTS AS PROVIDED BY THE
ANALYSIS. AS AB 1200 WAS TWO
PARTS, IT WAS A PFAS PROHIBITION
ON PLANT BASED FOOD PACKAGING
WITH AN ACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF 100
PARTS PER MILLION. THE COOKWARE
PROVISIONS IN THAT BILL ARE NOT
A PFAS RESTRICTION, WHICH IS HOW
IT IS CHARACTERIZED AND
CLASSIFIED UNDER AB 347. IT IS A
LABELING REQUIREMENT. IT WAS
PROVIDING CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA THE RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT INGREDIENTS MAY HAVE BEEN
USED IN THE MANUFACTURING OF
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE OF
COOKWARE BAKEWARE. SO NOW WHAT
WE HAVE IS A PROBLEM IN 347, IN
WHICH WHILE THE BILL SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON PFAS AND THE PRESENCE
OF IT, ILLEGAL PRESENCE OF IT IN
VARIOUS CONSUMER PRODUCTS, WE'RE
NOW ENFORCING A LABELING
REQUIREMENT THAT CAN ONLY BE
PROVEN AND DETERMINED UNDER AB
1200 FOR NOT WHAT IS ONLY ON THE
LABEL OR IDENTIFIED BY A
MANUFACTURER, BUT THE LIST IN
AND OF ITSELF ALSO REFERENCES
THE DTSC CANDIDATE CHEMICAL
LIST, WHICH IS OVER 3000
CHEMICALS LONG, SO THE ONLY WAY
BAKEWARE OR COOKWARE IN THIS
BILL CAN BE THOROUGHLY PROVEN OR
JUSTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT AND
MANUFACTURER. FOR NOT CONTAINING
ONE OF THOSE INGREDIENTS IS TO
TEST FOR BOTH WHAT IS LISTED ON
THE LABEL AND FOR THE OTHER
SIDE, OR NOT, AND THAT IS WHY
THAT PARTICULAR AMENDMENT, THAT
PARTICULAR CONSIDERATION, WAS SO
IMPORTANT TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. BEYOND THAT, WE HAVE
CONCERNS AS WELL REGARDING
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS. WE STILL
HAVE ARGUMENTS AND CONCERNS
RELATED TO THE NOTICE OF
VIOLATIONS. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE BILL IS HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE FEEL THAT THE
SCOPE OF IT, HOWEVER, NEEDS TO
BE NARROWED. WE NEED TO WE NEED
TO ENSURE THE VIABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY OF COSMETIC
PRODUCTS. GIVEN THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
HAS JUST RAISED, WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS BUT ARE
WILLING TO WORK WITH WITH THE
AUTHOR ON A PRAGMATIC SOLUTION
THAT CONTROLS COSTS OF
ENFORCEMENT, WE DO NOT HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO THIS. SO
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PREROGATIVE, THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PREROGATIVE, WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE CLARITY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WHAT IS INTENDED
TO BE PUT TOGETHER TO CREATE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
SURROUNDING POTENTIALLY TENS, IF
NOT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
COVERED PRODUCTS, COVERED ANY
COVERED UNDER EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF THE FOUR BILLS. THIS BILL
INTENDS TO COVER. WE ALSO DON'T
YET UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION WILL DEAL
WITH FUTURE BANS ON PFAS
RESTRICTIONS FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS. WE FEEL THE SCOPE OF
THIS IS TOO LARGE AT THE PRESENT
TIME. WE DEFINITELY BELIEVE THAT
COSMETICS SHOULD BE STRICKEN
FROM THIS BILL. WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE COOKWARE
BAKEWARE PROVISIONS REINSTATED
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND FOCUSED PURELY ON THE PFAS
RESTRICTIONS AND COVERED
PRODUCTS. UNDER THE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION, SENATORS. WITH
THAT, OUR COALITION IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE TODAY. WE DO
INTEND TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY, LET'S HEAR FROM OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANT TO WEIGH IN.
THANK BORGES ON BEHALF OF THE
COOKWARE SUSTAINABILITY ALLIANCE
, WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF CMTA,
PARTICULARLY ON THE SUBJECT OF
COOKWARE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SILVIO FERRARA, ON
BEHALF THE ASSOCIATION OF HOME
APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS ALSO
ALIGNED WITH THE COMMENTS ON
COOKWARE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
LAUREN DE VALENCIA, REPRESENTING
THE INTERNATIONAL SLEEP PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION, DO SUPPORT A
REGULATORY PROCESS BUT TO
CONTINUE TO REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS LAUREN AGUILAR, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN APPAREL
AND FOOTWEAR ASSOCIATION, THE
AFFIRM GROUP AND THE JUVENILE
PRODUCTS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN OPPOSING
THIS AMENDED POSITION. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. RANDY
POLLACK, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL, IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT, THE ITEM
IS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS, THOUGHTS AND COMMENTS
. SORRY, SENATOR MITCH, FOR.
SORRY, I'M JUST GETTING
CLARIFICATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BECAUSE I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION YOU WERE TAKING THE
AMENDMENT OF THE COOKWARE, SO
JUST. NO, NO, I, I CLARIFIED IN
MY OPENING STATEMENT THAT I
WE'RE TAKING ALL THE AMENDMENTS
EXCEPT FOR THE COOKWARE
AMENDMENT, AND THEN WE ARE WITH
THE CHAIR'S INDULGENCE. WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO AMEND
COMING INTO THIS HEARING, I WAS
UNDER THE IMPRESSION, I HAVE A
LOT OF CONCERNS, AND I THINK I
AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION ON THE
COSMETICS PART, ESPECIALLY, AND
I KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE REFERRED
TO HEALTH AS WELL. MAYBE THAT'S
WHERE YOU'RE FOCUSING ON. COULD
YOU JUST SHARE A LITTLE BIT
MORE? SOMEONE IN THE BACKGROUND
IS SHAKING THEIR HEAD. SO CAN
YOU JUST CLARIFY THE COMMITMENT?
MAYBE THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
LOOKING TO FOCUS MORE. YEAH,
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED
ON IS MOVING INTO AS WE MOVE
INTO SENATE HEALTH TO FOCUS ON
THAT COSMETICS PORTION, WE
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THE
INDUSTRY'S CONCERN, ESPECIALLY
ABOUT THE INTENTIONALLY ADDED
PART, WE BELIEVE THAT ALSO
WITHIN THE AMENDMENT TAKEN, THAT
IT IS A GOOD FIRST STEP AROUND
THE STATEMENT OF COMPLIANCE,
CERTIFYING THAT THE REGISTERED
PRODUCTS, IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
APPLICABLE PFAS RESTRICTION. AND
SO WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD FIRST
STEP, IN TERMS OF AB 1200 AND
THE COOKWARE, I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH AB 1200. THAT WAS MY BILL,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM, AROUND THE LABELING,
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION ON WHAT THAT IS, WE
DON'T THINK THAT LEAVING THE
WHOLE POINT OF THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY TO ENFORCE LEGISLATION.
SO I THINK IT WOULD BE
IRRESPONSIBLE FOR US TO LEAVE
OUT LEGISLATION THAT I AUTHORED
AND NOT HAVE, SOME ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT, HAVING SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT ONEROUS. HAPPY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW HOW WE CAN STILL
HAVE ENFORCEMENT WITHOUT MAKING
IT, MAKING IT ONEROUS. BUT
AGAIN, WE HAVE WE'RE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH BOTH
GROUPS. AND THIS IS A QUESTION
MAYBE I'LL START WITH YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE AMENDMENT
IS THAT DO YOU LOOK AT THAT AS A
SELF ATTESTATION FROM EACH
MANUFACTURER ON THE STATE OF
COMPLIANCE? I MEAN, THAT THAT'S
MY THAT'S THE WAY THAT WE
INTERPRET IT. AND THÀNH TO THE
OPPOSITION WITH THE SELF
ATTESTATION AND COMPLIANCE, AT
LEAST FOR THE COSMETICS, IF
COSMETICS ATTEST THAT THERE'S
NONE INTENTIONALLY WOULD THAT
SATISFY THROUGH THE CHAIR? THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION, SENATOR, I
THINK OUR CONCERNS WOULD STILL
BE OUTSTANDING BECAUSE ALL THE
OTHER THE THREE OTHER PRODUCT
CATEGORIES HAVE 100 PPM. SO
UNDER THE BILL, DTSC COULD TEST
RANDOM RANDOMLY TEST THESE
PRODUCTS. AND THERE'S A VERY
CLEAR WAY FOR THEM TO DETERMINE
COMPLIANCE. SO IF THEY TEST A
PIECE OF CLOTHING, FOR EXAMPLE,
AND THE TEST RESULTS CAME BACK
TO BE HIGHER THAN 100 PPM,
THEY'RE THE TESTING OF THAT.
CLEARLY INDICATES THAT THAT THAT
PIECE OF CLOTHING IS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. AND THEREFORE, YOU
KNOW, THEY TAKE THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION, REMOVE THE PRODUCTS FROM
THE SHELVES, ETC. SAME THING FOR
THE FOOD PACKAGING PROVISIONS,
SAME THING FOR, THE JUVENILE
PRODUCTS PROVISION. WE DO NOT
HAVE THAT CERTAINTY. SO THE
PROVISION IN THREE, FOUR, SEVEN
THAT ALLOWS FOR DTSC TO TEST OUR
PRODUCTS, WE ARE VERY, VERY
UNCLEAR HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
DETERMINE NONCOMPLIANCE. WITHOUT
THAT, THAT SAME PARTS PER
MILLION, STRUCTURE IN THIS BILL.
AND ACTUALLY THAT WAS DISCUSSED
WHEN WE WERE ORIGINALLY
DISCUSSING AB 2771 WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND WE ALL
DETERMINED THAT BECAUSE OF THE
UNIQUENESS OF OUR PRODUCTS AND
THE FACT THAT WE DO USE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WATER,
WHICH COULD HAVE VARYING LEVELS
OF PFAS, THAT THEY WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT
TRACE AMOUNTS WERE ALLOWABLE.
SO, SO GIVEN ALL THAT AND JUST
TO TAKE A COUPLE STEPS BACK, WE
ARE NOT SURE HOW DTSC IS GOING
TO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE WITH OUR
PRODUCTS. WITHOUT THAT PPM. AND
AS WAS MENTIONED, IT WAS
DISCUSSED AT ONE POINT DURING
THE DELIBERATIONS IN TWO, 771
ABOUT INCLUDING A PARTS PER
MILLION DE MINIMIS LEVEL, AND
THAT WE ALL DETERMINE AND WE ALL
AGREED AND WE WENT NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL, THAT THAT WAS NOT A
FEASIBLE THING FOR OUR PRODUCTS
IN PARTICULAR. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. ANY I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO YOU DON'T NEED TO
RESPOND TO THAT. BUT IF THERE'S
ANYTHING YOU WANTED TO COUNTER
TO KNOW AGAIN, YOU KNOW, YOU
STATED, MY UNDERSTANDING WAS AND
HOPES THAT WE GOT OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
IS REALLY WHERE WE WERE GOING TO
BE FOCUSED ON THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE, WE BELIEVE THAT THE, YOU
KNOW, THAT CERTIFICATION OF
COMPLIANCE WAS A MAJOR FIRST
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH,
OPPOSITION ON THAT. AND WE FEEL
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WE CAN GET THERE
AND ON THE COOKWARE PART,
COOKWARE PART IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO USE? YOU SHARED
IN THE BEGINNING THAT YOU CAN.
SO, SO WITH THE COOKWARE PART
IS, WE, YOU KNOW, HEARD HIS
COMMENTS HAPPY IF HE IF THE
OPPOSITION HAS AMENDMENTS FOR US
OUTSIDE OF A BLANKET EXEMPTION,
I THINK WE'RE VERY OPEN TO
DISCUSSING THEM. YOU KNOW, WHAT
THEY THINK WOULD BE, REASONABLE
ENFORCEMENT THAT WOULD NOT BE
OVERLY ONEROUS OR EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE WE. OKAY, BECAUSE OUR
PROPOSAL WAS A COMPLETE
EXEMPTION, CORRECT? YEAH. THIS
IS A REGULATION. AND I WOULD SAY
AND IT JUST SEEMED TO ME IT
WOULD JUST SEEM ODD TO, TO
AGAIN, HAVE A BILL AROUND
ENFORCING LEGISLATION AND TO
LEAVE THAT PART OUT, EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS JUST A LABELING PIECE.
MR. CHAIR, IF. YEAH, PLEASE.
YEAH, YEAH, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THE ADDED
OPPORTUNITY. SO FOR OUR
COALITION, WE DID, IN GOOD
FAITH, PUT TOGETHER A SERIES OF
AMENDMENTS, QUITE SUBSTANTIAL TO
THE BILL IN PRINT. AND WHAT WE
ATTEMPTED TO DO WAS PROVIDE THE
STRUCTURE AND THE GUARDRAILS,
THE GUIDANCE TO FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO DTSC AS A
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE. NOW,
WITHIN THAT, THE CONCEPTS
SURROUNDING NOTICE OF
VIOLATIONS, THE TESTING
PROTOCOLS, ETC. GETS FURTHER
DILUTED AND COMPLICATED AS YOU
ADD MECHANISMS AND OTHER BILLS
LIKE 2771 THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
THRESHOLD TO INCLUDE THEN A
LABELING REQUIREMENT THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY TESTING
PROTOCOLS, YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY
THEN DESIGNING A PROGRAM, ONE
FOR TESTING FOR PFAS, ANOTHER
ONE STRICTLY FOR ENFORCEMENT.
AND IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME
OR TO US AS A COALITION AS TO
WHY WE WOULD BIFURCATE THE BILL
IF IT IS TRULY FOCUSED ON
CONSUMER PRODUCTS AND THE
PRESENCE OF PFAS. LET'S FOCUS ON
THAT AND LEAVE THE LABELING
PROVISIONS AND OTHER ELEMENTS
OUT OF IT. AB 1200 WOULD STILL
BE ENFORCED WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF COOKWARE. IT WOULD STILL
CONSIDER THE PLANT BASED FOOD
PACKAGING ELEMENTS OF THE BILL
THAT MR. CHING AUTHORED A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
PORTION OF IT. BUT AGAIN, THE
FOCUS OF THIS BILL HAS ALWAYS
BEEN TESTING AND ENFORCEMENT FOR
THE PROTOCOLS THAT ARE THERE IN
STATUTE AND WHY I CAN UNDERSTAND
THE LABELING PROVISIONS OF IT. I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT IS A
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN OUTSIDE OF THIS BILL.
YEAH. OKAY. LET LET ME, LET ME
GO TO SENATOR HURTADO AND I KNOW
SENATOR DOLE HAS QUESTIONS TO.
YES, I LIKE TO EXPRESS THE SAME
CONCERNS AS MY AS MY COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR MENJIVAR. AND I, TOO,
ALSO HAPPEN TO SIT ON THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AS WELL. AND SO
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THERE'S A
COMMITMENT COMING FROM YOU TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES IN THAT COMMITTEE.
YES. NOW REGARDING THE WITH WITH
COSMETICS IN PARTICULAR RIGHT
NOW, REGARDING COOKWARE, I WON'T
BE ACCEPTING THEIR PROPOSAL TO
STRIKE IT OUT. I THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK THE DEPARTMENT
COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO COMPLY
WITH LABELING AGAIN, LABELING IS
THE MOST MINIMAL AMOUNT OF
COMPLIANCE THAT'S NEEDED. SO I
THINK WE CAN WORK ON A WAY THAT,
THEY COULD THEY COULD ENFORCE
THAT MECHANISM WITHOUT MAKING IT
OVERLY ONEROUS. WHAT THAT I'LL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR DOLL, THE
QUESTION IS THAT YOU'RE NOT
TAKING THE AMENDMENT. SO WHY
DON'T WE JUST STRIKE IT OUT HERE
THEN AND SAY THAT IT'S NOT IN
THERE, ARE YOU? WHAT IS THE
PROCESS HERE? OH, WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE CHAIR, ESPECIALLY AS WE GO
INTO THE NEXT COMMITTEE. OKAY.
SO JUST, THIS IS ABOUT I TOTALLY
THINK WE NEED TO WORK. I FIRST
OF ALL, BACK TO I ASKED FOR A
HEARING ON PFAS, AND THEN WE'RE
DOING ONE OFFS. AND HERE NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO GET SOME
REGULATION. IT'S A FRUSTRATING
THING FOR ME. LOOK, WE WANT TO
GET POS OUT OF OUR SYSTEM. WE
UNDERSTAND THE HEALTH RISKS TO
IT, BUT IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING TO
SEE A MANUFACTURER. WE HAVE PFAS
IN IN ASTROTURF, FOR EXAMPLE.
AND WHEN IT RAINS ON IT, IT GETS
INTO OUR WATER SUPPLY AND ENDS
UP IN A MANUFACTURING PLANT
SOMEWHERE. YES. AND WE HAVE
PARTS PER BILLION PARTS PER
MILLION MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE
MANUFACTURING. AND WE'RE TRYING
TO PIN THEM DOWN. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS DOING, TRYING TO
PIN THEM DOWN. AND SO IT'S
CRITICAL THOSE THOSE NUMBERS
MATTER AND LIABILITY ARE WHERE,
YOU KNOW, ON THE MANUFACTURING
PART OF IT. SO THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT, I THINK IT'S
KIND OF IT'S FRUSTRATING THAT,
WE NEED WE NEED TO WE NEED HAVE
SOME CLARITY IN THAT. WHAT IS
THE WHAT IS THAT AMOUNT FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS, UNINTENDED
UNINTENDED AMOUNT. THERE IS AN
AMOUNT FOR THE FOR ALL THE OTHER
PRODUCTS, COSMETICS DOES NOT
HAVE THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT
PART OF THEIR NEGOTIATED BILL.
SO EVERY OTHER EVERY OTHER ITEM
IN THE BILL THERE ALREADY HAS.
ALL THE BILL DOES IS ENFORCING
PREVIOUS BILLS. SO AGAIN, THIS
HAS BEEN WORKING ON FOR TWO
YEARS NOW. SO THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING I THOUGHT UP LAST
MONTH. I'M PRESENTING TO YOU.
THIS HAS BEEN A TWO YEAR PROCESS
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT,
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO AGAIN
NOT PRESENT A NEW BILL, BUT JUST
TO REGULATE PREVIOUS BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW. SO
AGAIN, THERE IS A LINE FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE BUT COSMETICS,
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM, THAT
WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED INTO THEIR BILL. IT
WASN'T MY BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN'S BILL. SO AGAIN, WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO AGAIN, OAN MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS A MECHANISM
TO ACTUALLY SEE. I KNOW, I KNOW,
WE DON'T ALWAYS DO THE BEST JOB
OF FOLLOW THROUGH AT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, BUT THIS IS OUR
EFFORT TO ACTUALLY TRY TO DO
THAT. AND NOW YOU CAN SEE,
SENATOR, HOW HARD IT IS, FRANKLY
, I APPRECIATE THAT. BUT STILL,
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME, ABILITY
FOR THE MANUFACTURER NOT TO BE
HOLD HELD LIABLE FOR SOMETHING
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER. BUT
THAT ULTIMATELY COMES DOWN TO
THE, YEAH. SO YOU'RE YOU'RE THIS
THIS IS THIS SORT OF A QUESTION
OF INTENTIONALITY OR SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES THAT THAT IS THAT
THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING IS THAT
IF YOU HAVE WATER THAT'S
CONTAMINATED WITH PFAS AND YOU
MANUFACTURE SOMETHING AND THE
PFAS GETS IN THERE, YOU'RE HELD
LIABLE, RIGHT? SO THAT'S THE
PROBLEM. SO AGAIN, THAT'S IT'S
BUT THAT WAS ALREADY IT'S ONLY
AN ISSUE WITH COSMETICS. THAT'S
WHY WE HAD THIS WE WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE STATEMENT OF
COMPLIANCE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM. EVERYBODY ELSE THEY
HAVE A THEY HAVE A LINE IN THE
SAND. SO JUST WHAT ABOUT
FEMININE PRODUCTS THAT THAT'S
NOT IN THE BILL, RIGHT. IT'S
COMING NEXT. SO THAT'S MY POINT.
THAT'S WHY I SAID WE NEED TO
HAVE A FAST HEARING. BUT WE SO
AGAIN THE YEAH FOOD PACKAGING,
COSMETICS, JUVENILE PRODUCTS,
TEXTILES. YEAH. BECAUSE IT'S
YOU'RE BASICALLY ENFORCING THE
EXISTING LAWS ON THE EXISTING
LAW RIGHT NOW. THAT PROBLEM THAT
YOU JUST DESCRIBED IS ALREADY
EXISTS. YEAH. YEAH, YEAH. THANK
YOU SENATOR. AGAIN APPRECIATE
THE ADDED TIME, SPECIFIC TO
COSMETICS. YOU KNOW, WHETHER
IT'S A SELF ATTESTATION OR, THE
CERTIFICATE OF COMPLIANCE, THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS EVEN THOUGH AS
A MANUFACTURER, IF YOU DON'T
INTENTIONALLY ADD ANYTHING TO
COSMETIC, WHICH IS THE LAW UNDER
AB 2771, DO NOT INTENTIONALLY
ADD SHOULD A TEST BE DONE AT ANY
TIME AND IT REGISTER A PART PER
TRILLION, A PART PER BILLION, OR
A PART PER MILLION THRESHOLD
THAT TEST DOES NOT DETERMINE
INTENTIONAL INTENTIONALITY? I
GUESS. SO WITH THAT, QUITE
LITERALLY A ONE PART PER
TRILLION, WHICH IS ALMOST
PRACTICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO TEST
FOR THESE PRODUCTS WOULD TRIGGER
A VIOLATION UNDER AB 347. THAT
IS WHY THE THRESHOLD
CONSIDERATION FOR THE OTHER
BILLS MAKES SO MUCH MORE
FUNCTIONAL SENSE IN THE
CONSTRUCT OF WHAT WE'RE
PROVIDING. AND SO FOR A
MANUFACTURER TO DEFEND ITSELF
AGAINST, DID YOU ALLEGEDLY ADD
OR NOT TO THAT PARTICULAR
PRODUCT? IS THE QUESTION. AND SO
IF A TEST OR A CHALLENGE IS
BROUGHT TO THAT SELF-CERTIFY OR
THAT ASSESSMENT FROM THE
MANUFACTURER THAT MANUFACTURE
THEN WOULD HAVE TO PROVE
ESSENTIALLY THAT THEY DIDN'T DO
IT. BUT HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
LIKE, LIKE THAT IS THE STRUCTURE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK IN FOR
A BILL THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
THRESHOLD CONTINUATION PART OF
IT. BUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHY THIS
COMMITTEE ADDED THE AMENDMENT
AROUND THE STATEMENT OF
COMPLIANCE, BECAUSE THAT IS
EXACTLY THE WHOLE POINT OF
INTENTIONALITY. RIGHT? SO IF YOU
HAD THE IT'S LIKE IT'S LIKE
SAYING I'M STATING I'M TRYING TO
FOLLOW THE LAW AND I HAVE EVERY
INTENTION TO FALL IN LAW. AND IF
I HAD AND IF I USED WATER WITH
PFAS, AS THE SENATOR AND THE
OPPOSITION HAVE TALKED ABOUT,
THAT IT WAS NOT MY INTENTION TO
PUT PFAS IN THE PRODUCT. BUT IF
THEN THEY GET TESTED, THEN AT
THAT MOMENT THEY'RE IN VIOLATION
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEY ATTESTED
TO CORRECT WITH YOUR BILL. SO
AGAIN, THAT'S, I THINK, WHERE WE
HAVE TO FINE TUNE IT BECAUSE
BECAUSE UNLIKE THE OTHER BILLS
THAT HAD A PARTICULAR
MEASUREMENT THAT THE FRIEDMAN
BILL DID NOT HAVE A PARTICULAR,
MEASUREMENT. SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE AGAIN, THAT'S WHAT WE
ABSOLUTELY PROMISE TO WORK ON
THAT IN SENATE HEALTH FOR. OKAY.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO
ADDRESS. ABSOLUTELY. YEAH. OKAY
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION. I KNOW SEVERAL OF
YOU. ARE YOU IN HEALTH AS WELL?
YEAH. OKAY. GREAT. SO YEAH.
YEAH, I LOVE IT. SO YOU'LL
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO HOLD YOU
ABSOLUTELY ACCOUNTABLE AS, AS IS
AS AS IS THEIR JOB TOO. YES
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. YES, WELL, WITH
THAT UNDERSTANDING, I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FROM, ONE OF
YOU TO. OKAY, AN AND THEN, YOU
KNOW, ASSUMING GETS OUT, YOU'LL
YOU'LL DO THIS WORK BEFORE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. LET YOU GIVE
YOU OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE AGAIN,
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION, ABSOLUTELY. WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON THE BILL,
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND GUIDANCE AND
RESPECT FOR I VOTE ON AB 347.
OKAY SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB 347 DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HEALTH COMMITTEE. SENATORS
ALLEN I ALLEN I DALLEY. NO.
DALLEY. NO. GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HURTADO I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I
NGUYEN. NGUYEN NO. SKINNER OKAY.
MORE WORK TO COME. OKAY. I HAVE
AND YOU HAVE TWO MORE BILLS. I
HAVE TWO MORE BILLS THAT ARE
MUCH SIMPLER, SO FIRST, LET ME
THANK THE YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE AMENDMENTS ON AB 2244.
HAPPY TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS. AB
2244 WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED, BPA OR
BISPHENOL A IN PAPER RECEIPTS BY
JANUARY 2025 AND ALL
INTENTIONALLY BISPHENOL
CHEMICALS AND PAPER RECEIPTS BY
JANUARY 2026. ACTUALLY, THE VERY
MUCH CONCERNED WITH BISPHENOL IS
THAT ACTUALLY IT'S NOT WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY COME INTO
CONTACT WITH THAT RECEIPT. SO
WHEN YOU GRAB THAT RECEIPT,
YOU'RE ACTUALLY BEING EXPOSED TO
THAT TOXIC CHEMICAL. WE THINK
THERE'S NO REASON FOR THAT TO BE
IN PAPER RECEIPTS. I HAVE NANCY
BIERMAIER FROM BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS TO GIVE
TESTIMONY WITH RESPECT TO VÚI.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS
AND CHAIR NANCY BIERMAIER ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
AND THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TANG FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON AB 2244 TO BAN ALL
BISPHENOLS FROM THERMAL THERMAL
RECEIPT PAPER. BCP IS A SCIENCE
BASED ORGANIZATION WORKING TO
PREVENT BREAST CANCER BY
REDUCING EXPOSURES TO CHEMICALS
LINKED TO THE DISEASE BISPHENOL
A, OR BPA, IS, FOR GOOD REASON,
ONE OF THE BETTER KNOWN
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS, AND TODAY
YOU WILL SEE BPA FREE STICKERS
ON NUMEROUS PRODUCTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, ALL TOO OFTEN,
BPA HAS BEEN REPLACED WITH AN
ALPHABET SOUP OF BISPHENOL
SUBSTITUTES CGRTS, EPS, BPF, AND
SO ON. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WITH THERMAL RECEIPT
PAPERS. A 2023 REPORT FOUND THAT
BPA HAS LARGELY BEEN REPLACED
WITH EPS, A CASE OF A OF A
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTIONS OF THE
RECEIPTS THAT WERE TESTED LESS
THAN 1% CONTAINED BPA AND NEARLY
80% CONTAINED EPS. WHILE THESE
SUBSTITUTES ARE OFTEN LESS WELL
STUDIED, THE MORE WE LEARN, THE
BETTER WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ENTIRE CLASS OF BISPHENOLS HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR HEALTH,
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA AND HYPERACTIVITY IN
CHILDREN AND CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE, FERTILITY PROBLEMS,
OBESITY, DIABETES, AND AN
INCREASED RISK OF BREAST AND
OTHER CANCERS IN ADULTS. BPA AND
ARE BOTH LISTED ON CALIFORNIA'S
PROP 65 AS REPRODUCTIVE
TOXICANTS. BISPHENOLS ARE
ABSORBED THROUGH THE SKIN WHEN
HANDLING THERMAL PAPER RECEIPTS.
THIS EXPOSURE IS CONCERNING FOR
ALL CONSUMERS. HOWEVER, THE RISK
IS GREATEST FOR CASHIER, OVER
70% OF WHICH ARE WOMEN.
OCCUPATION STUDIES HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT BPA AND EPS
LEVELS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
IN IN CASHIERS. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT THE REPORT I REFERENCED
EARLIER ALSO SHOWED THAT 20% OF
RECEIPTS TESTED WERE FREE OF ALL
BISPHENOLS, AS CLEARLY
ALTERNATIVES ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AND IN USE, IT'S TIME
TO REMOVE THIS ENTIRE CLASS OF
TOXIC CHEMICALS FROM THERMAL
RECEIPT PAPER BY PASSING AB
2244. ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL DILLONLIAM FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP. WE
WERE A SPONSORS OF THE BABY
BOTTLE BILL IN 2011 BY BETSY
BUTLER THAT STARTED THIS. WE'RE
REALLY GLAD TO SEE THE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION ISSUE
BEING ADDRESSED. THANK YOU.
HELLO, KAYLA ROBINSON
REGISTERING REGISTERED SUPPORT
FOR CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
THANKS HI ARIANA CREED WITH
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS. ORG IN
SUPPORT. ALSO THOSE IN SUPPORT
OR NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE AND CA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEACE ACTIVIST
AND SAN DIEGO FAX CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE, SONOMA SAS BEYOND
PESTICIDES, YARD SMART MARIN
MOMS ADVOCATING FOR
SUSTAINABILITY, CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
GRANDPARENTS ACTING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
. NO. OKAY. LET'S TURN BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
THOUGHTS, COMMENTS? YEAH. YES.
MR. VICE CHAIR, SO MY ONE
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS THE
PENALTY THAT GETS SIGNED INTO
LAW JANUARY 25. IT GOES INTO
EFFECT AND THEN THERE'S A
PENALTY PHASE. SO FOR THOSE
FOLKS THAT ARE TRYING TO ROTATE
OUT, $10,000 VIOLATION. BUT
AGAIN THE PENALTY PHASE WOULD BE
REALLY, JANUARY 2026 BECAUSE
IT'S THE INTENTIONALLY ADDED BPA
JANUARY 2025. RIGHT THAT'S WHY
WE DID THE JANUARY 2026 FOR THE
UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED SO IF THEY
KNEW THAT THERE'S. BPA IS 2025
VP S 26. YEAH. SO THE SO
ACCORDING TO THE COMPANIES THAT
PRODUCE IT, THEY THEY ATTESTED
THAT FOR THE MOST PART THEY
ALREADY DO NOT HAVE BPA IN THEIR
RECEIPTS. FOR THE MOST PART,
THEY'VE SHIFTED TO EPS. SO THE
CONSUMER THOUGH THAT HAS IT AND
IN THERE HAS A STOCKPILE OF IT.
WHAT HOW IS THAT GOING TO AFFECT
THEM SO THAT THEY, THEY HAVE MY
UNDERSTANDING ACCORDING TO THE
RECEIPT PAPER MANUFACTURERS, IS
THAT THEY'VE ALREADY, FOR THE
MOST PART, TRANSITIONED OUT OF
BPA. SO THIS IS REALLY FOCUSED
ON THE JANUARY 2026 ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. SEE, WE ANTICIPATED
YOUR QUESTION. I'M NOT ABOUT
WE'RE YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TOO LONG TOGETHER, BRIAN
. SENATOR, SORRY. ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS? I'M GLAD YOU
DIDN'T MAKE A STAFFER WEAR A
RECEIPT THIS TIME. I ALWAYS FELT
BAD FOR THAT GUY, OKAY, WELL,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS. AND, AND
YOU'VE BEEN YOU'VE BEEN ON THIS
ISSUE FOR A LONG, LONG TIME AS
AS YOU HAVE ON ON PFAS AND MANY
OTHER THINGS. SO I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WHEN, YEAH.
OKAY. MOVE BY THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU. SIR AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE FOR I
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
2244, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SENATORS
ALLEN I ALLEN I DALLY, I DALLY I
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NGUYEN. AND
SKINNER OKAY I BELIEVE THEY'RE
OPEN. I KNOW SOME OF OUR TEAM
HAS ONE MORE BILL ON CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. IT'S SB 24 2401. THANK
YOU. AB 2401 IS REGARDING CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL. IT MAKES THREE
PRIMARY CHANGES TO OUR CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM. CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL IS REALLY A PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE ADOPTION, ESPECIALLY
FOR MANY MORE MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES. IT CODIFIES THE
RECENTLY EXPANDED STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. IT REQUIRES DATA
COLLECTION TO ALLOW FOR MORE
TARGETED OUTREACH TO THE LOWEST
INCOME CALIFORNIANS DRIVING THE
MOST MILES IN THE OLDEST, MOST
POLLUTING VEHICLES. IT ALSO
ALLOWS AN INCREASED INCENTIVE TO
HELP MOVE MORE OF THESE DRIVERS
TO TRANSITION INTO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. SO QUITE, QUITE
SIMPLY, WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO
DO IS FOCUS A LARGE TRY TO TRY
TO GET A LARGER INCENTIVE TO
LOWER INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
WHO ARE DRIVING LONGER DISTANCES
. WE HAVE MANY SUPER COMMUTERS
WHO COMMUTE FROM SACRAMENTO,
PHÐ, THE CENTRAL VALLEY INTO THE
BAY AREA OR PEOPLE WHO LIVE FAR
OUTSIDE OF LOS ANGELES INTO LA.
IT'S REALLY TRYING TO FIND WAYS
TO INCENTIVIZE MANY OF OUR SUPER
COMMUTERS INTO AND GIVE THEM
HIGHER INCENTIVES TO TRANSITION
INTO ZERO EMISSION CARS. I HAVE
MICHAEL CANALES, WHO'S WITH THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS,
AND TOM KNOX FROM VALLEY CALM, I
GUESS. NO, I DON'T HAVE MICHAEL
MICHELE. I HAVE SOMEONE MUCH
BETTER THAN MICHAEL. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. MY NAME, WESTERN
STATES POLICY ADVOCATE MICHELE.
I'M SORRY. EXCUSE MY EXCUSE. MY,
MY. THIS IS WHY I NEED MY
READING GLASSES. I APOLOGIZE,
MICHELE, I'M SORRY. AND SPONSOR
OF AB 2401 CALIFORNIA HAS
REACHED THIS GOAL OF 1.5 MILLION
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE SALES TWO
YEARS EARLY AND SIGNIFICANT
STATE INVESTMENTS HAS PLAYED A
LARGE PART OF THAT GROWTH.
HOWEVER, THE MAJORITY OF THESE
VEHICLES HAVE YET TO REACH THOSE
THAT WOULD BENEFIT THE MOST LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO FACE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO EV
ADOPTION AND BEAR THE BRUNT OF
AIR POLLUTION. GIVEN THE STATE'S
BUDGET DEFICIT. USING PROGRAM
FUNDING IN A MORE TARGETED AND
INTENTIONAL MANNER COULD
MAXIMIZE THESE LIMITED STATE
RESOURCES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING CLEAN VEHICLE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. FOR
INSTANCE, A REPORT UCS AND
GREENLINING INSTITUTE CONDUCTED
LAST YEAR FOUND THAT PASSENGER
VEHICLES MANUFACTURED BEFORE
2004 EMIT ALMOST THREE TIMES AS
MUCH SMOG, FORMING NOX POLLUTION
AS DO ALL POST 2004 VEHICLES
COMBINED. THESE OLDER VEHICLES
MAKE UP ONLY 19% OF LIGHT DUTY
CARS ON THE ROAD, BUT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR 73% OF ALL NOX
EMISSIONS FROM PASSENGER
VEHICLES. ADDITIONALLY, A RECENT
COLTURA REPORT FOUND THAT JUST
9% OF ALL PRIVATE LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES CONSUME A THIRD OF THE
STATE'S GASOLINE, SPENDING
UPWARDS OF $1,000 MONTHLY ON
FUEL. THE DISTRIBUTION OF
EMISSIONS IS NOT EQUAL AMONG
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES, AND
RETIRING HIGHER EMITTING CARS
THAT ARE DRIVEN THE MOST WILL
LEAD TO GREATER AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS. AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE MODERNIZE THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM WITH AB 2401, EVEN
THOUGH THE PROGRAM ALREADY
TARGETS LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
AND ZIP CODES, THIS BILL UPDATES
AND IMPROVES THE GUIDELINES BY
HAVING CARB PRIORITIZED LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITHIN CENSUS
TRACTS THAT DRIVE A PRE 2004
VEHICLE AND DRIVE LONG
DISTANCES. THE FOCUS WILL ENSURE
THAT WE PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED AIR
QUALITY AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
THE COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED.
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS,
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR,
COLTURA, GREENLINING AND VALLEY,
CAN RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I'M TOM
KNOX OF VALLEY, AND I'M JUST
HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KIM STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF COLTURA,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT. YEAH.
JULIE MALINOWSKI, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT JONATHAN COLE WITH
CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA, ALSO
ON BEHALF OF 350 HUMBOLDT AND
350 SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, AARON TAYLOR WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
STRONG SUPPORT. HELLO, JACOB
EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, MARGIE LEE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MELISSA CÁC WITH
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MELISSA
ROMERO, CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN SUPPORT. ARIANNA WITH
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS. DOT ORG IN
SUPPORT. ALSO THOSE IN SUPPORT
ARE NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE AND CA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEACE ACTIVIST
SAN DIEGO FAX MOMS ADVOCATING
FOR SUSTAINABILITY AND
GRANDPARENTS ACTING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU. ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON
BEHALF OF COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
EYE OPPOSITION. ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OR OPPOSITION, I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
THOUGHTS, SENATOR VENTURA? I
LOVE THIS BILL, I THINK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, I'M ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT THE ACCESSIBILITY. WE
HAVE, ALL THESE GOALS. BUT HOW
FEASIBLE IS IT FOR OUR WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITY, LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY? NOT ABOUT MY
DISTRICT. WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED
AS A COAUTHOR AND MOVE NGUYEN.
AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
ABSOLUTELY. AND SENATOR, THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AFTERWARDS. SO NEXT YEAR
IT'S ALL YOURS. ALL RIGHT,
SEEING NO OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS
, THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED. IF YOU
HAVE ANY, JUST ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB 2401. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO TRANSPORTATION THÀNH SENATORS
ALLEN I, ALLEN I DALLI I DALLI I
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I WIN, I WIN I
SKINNER. ALL RIGHT. FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT I GOT
SENATOR D'OLIVO TWICE FROM MY
BILL. SO I APPRECIATE IT. YES
YES. YEAH. YEAH. TWO TWO OUT OF
THREE. YEAH. TWO OUT OF THREE C.
YEAH. IT'S NOT BAD A GOOD
BATTING AVERAGE. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S, HOPEFULLY SOME QUERIES ON
OUR WAY, LET'S WHY DON'T WE LIFT
SOME. YEAH, LET'S LET'S HAVE
SOME VOTES. LET'S DO SOME VOTES.
SO WE STARTED THE HEARING BEFORE
THE QUORUM WAS MET WITH A COUPLE
OF BILLS, ONE OF THEM WAS
SENATOR GARCIA'S AB 2113 ON THE
MILL FEE. SO IF ANYONE WANTS TO
MOVE THAT, THAT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS. IN NEGOTIATION. IT'S
MOVING BY, SENATOR MENGIBAR
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB 2113. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
SENATORS ALLEN, I ALLEN I DALLI.
DALLI NÓ GONZALEZ HURTADO
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NGUYEN
NGUYEN NÓ SKINNER. ALL RIGHT, 2
TO 2. WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL.
SO LET'S NOW WE'VE DONE ALL THE
TÍNH BILLS TOGETHER AS A GROUP,
HAS EVERYBODY VOTED 1864? YES,
LET'S SAY SO. LET'S GO TO THE
CONNOLLY BILL. YEAH. THAT WAS,
AB 1864, WHO WANTS TO MOVE THAT?
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AB 1864. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I. DALLI.
NO. DALLI. NO GONZALEZ. HURTADO
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN NO. SKINNER 2 TO 2. OKAY.
WHY DON'T WE? I SEE THAT OUR,
OUR ESTEEMED AUTHOR IS HERE.
MAJORITY LEADER, WHY DON'T YOU
COME ON UP AND WE'LL WE'LL START
WITH ITEM FIVE. THAT'S AB 863.
WHERE DO YOU PREFER IT? SORRY.
WELL, THIS IS A WAR SHOCK TEST
THAT REALLY SAYS A LOT ABOUT
YOUR CHARACTER. DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU SIT. YEAH. OKAY.
INTERESTING YEAH. ALL RIGHT. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. I NEED
MY TENNIS SHOES ON TODAY. JUST
LETTING YOU KNOW. OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
SINCE JULY 2011, CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS HAVE PAID A CARPET
STEWARDSHIP ASSESSMENT FEE WHEN
PURCHASING CARPETS SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS FEE FUNDS A
STATEWIDE CARPET RECYCLING
PROGRAM KNOWN AS THE CARPET
AMERICA RECOVERY EFFORT. IN
OTHER WORDS, CARE, WHICH IS A
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
ORGANIZATION DESIGNED AND
IMPLEMENTED BY CARPET
MANUFACTURERS WITH CALRECYCLE
OVERSIGHT. WE NEED TO REFORM
THIS PROGRAM TO PREVENT MORE
CARPET IN LANDFILLS, FOSTER MORE
RESPONSIBLE USE OF CONSUMER FEE
RESOURCES, LESSEN MITIGATION
WITH THE STATE, AND PROMOTE A
MORE ROBUST RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MAJOR
PROCESSES IN CALIFORNIA ARE NO
LONGER IN OPERATION, IN PART
BECAUSE WE NEED TO IMPROVE
MANAGEMENT OF THE SYSTEM. ONE OF
THOSE CLOSED DOWN IN MY
DISTRICT, OPPONENTS HERE TODAY
WILL SAY THAT THEIR RECYCLING
RATES ARE GOING UP AND THAT THEY
ARE MEETING THEIR GOALS, BUT
CARES CURRENT CLAIMS OF SUCCESS
ARE BASED ON RECOVERY OF
CARPETING COMPARED TO THE
DECLINING CARPET SALES, WHICH
INFLATES THE RECOVERY NUMBERS
AND POORLY DEPICTS HOW THE
CURRENT MARKET SHIFT TO OTHER
TYPES OF FLOORING IS REALLY
AFFECTING THE CARPET RECYCLING
PROGRAM. I HAVE SPENT OVER TWO
YEARS LEARNING ABOUT THE STATE
OF CARPET, THE CURRENT CARPET
RECYCLING PROGRAM AND WHERE
DIFFERENT FLOORING ENTITIES ARE
AT WITH RECYCLING EFFORTS. MY
STAFF HAS HAD DOZENS OF MEETINGS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THAT TIME,
INCLUDING DOUBLE DIGIT MEETINGS
WITH CARE AND ITS
REPRESENTATIVES. SHOULD THIS
BILL MAKE IT OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY, I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
COMMITTEE I HAVE AMENDED AB 863
TO WHAT I CAN CONFIDENTLY
PROPOSE AS A WAY TO FIX THE WAY
OF THE CARPET RECYCLING PROGRAM
IS RUN. BUT JUST AS IMPORTANTLY,
THIS BILL WILL ADD OTHER
RECYCLABLE PRODUCTS AS REQUESTED
BY THE ACTUAL RECYCLERS AND
ADDRESS RECYCLABLE LU█T FOR
OTHER FLOORING PROJECTS THAT ARE
THE MOST POPULAR PRODUCTS ON THE
MARKET TODAY. THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A TRUE EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY EPR PROGRAM FOR
CARPET, CARPET PAD AND
ARTIFICIAL TURF, ELIMINATING THE
ASSESSMENT CHARGE TO CONSUMERS.
THE BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT FOR RESILIENT
FLOORING BEFORE BEING ADDED TO
THE PROS PLAN AND EPR PROGRAM,
AND AB 863 WILL IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CARE OR ANY
OTHER CARPET RECYCLING PROGRAM
BY INCREASING CIVIL PENALTIES
FOR VIOLATING RELEVANT,
RELEVANT, RELEVANT LAWS AND
MAKING REPEAT OFFENDERS
INELIGIBLE TO RUN THIS PROGRAM
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS HEIDI
SANBORN, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
. VAL CHESTON, DIRECTOR OF
INSTRUCTION FOR THE JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING FOR
FLOORING WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT. 16, AND MIKE WEST,
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES, OF
CALIFORNIA, GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS HEIDI SANBORN OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL, A
NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES FOR AN
EQUITABLE CIRCULAR ECONOMY. AND
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 863
TO CREATE AN EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM FOR
CARPET, CARPET, PAD, ARTIFICIAL
TURF AND FOLLOWING THE
COMPLETION OF A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, RESILIENT FLOORING.
SINCE JULY OF 2011, CONSUMERS
HAVE PAID A CARPET STEWARDSHIP
FEE, WHICH STARTED AT $0.05 AND
NOW IS UP TO $0.70 FOR BROADLOOM
AND $0.99 FOR, CARPET TILE. WHEN
PURCHASING A CARPET SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH FUNDS THE
STATEWIDE RECYCLING PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT ADVANCED
DISPOSAL FEE PROGRAM AND THE
SUBSIDY FOR RECYCLING, VIRTUALLY
ALL BROADLOOM CARPET CAN BE
RECYCLED NOW IN CALIFORNIA, AND
ONLY CERTAIN CARPET TILE CANNOT
BE RECYCLED, BUT OFTEN CAN BE
REUSED. HOWEVER EVEN USING CARES
DATA CLAIMING 31% RECYCLING RATE
IN 2023 AND APPARENTLY
PROJECTING 41% IN 2024, IF ALL
CARPET IS NOW RECYCLABLE, ONE
MIGHT ASK WHY WE'RE STILL
LANDFILLING OVER 120 MILLION
POUNDS OF CARPET IN CALIFORNIA,
AND MY ANSWER WOULD BE THAT IT'S
DUE TO THE WAY THE PROGRAM IS
RUN. WE'RE CHARGING PEOPLE AT
END OF LIFE TO DISPOSE OF THEIR
CARPET, AND WE'RE NOT PAYING THE
COLLECTORS OF THAT CARPET, FOR
THEIR LABOR, RESULTING IN CARPET
GETTING DISPOSED OF INSTEAD OF
BEING SENT TO RECYCLING. THAT
AND MORE IS WHY AB 863 IS HERE
TO FIX FOR EXAMPLE, THE
CONSERVATION CORPS OF NORTH BAY
REPORTED THAT THEY MUST CHARGE
$35 PER RESIDENTIAL VEHICLE AND
$125 PER COMMERCIAL TRUCK TO
COLLECT CARPET, BECAUSE CARE
DOES NOT PAY THEM FOR THE LABOR
TO COLLECT IT. HENCE THEY DON'T
COLLECT MUCH. CONVERSELY THE
MATERIAL THE MATTRESS RECYCLING
COALITION DOES PAY THEM TO
COLLECT MATTRESSES, AND THEY
COLLECT A LOT OF THEM, AND THEY
DON'T CHARGE THE CUSTOMERS TO
DROP THEM OFF. AND THAT'S WHAT
WORKS. AND THEY LIKE THAT
PROGRAM. THE NORTH BAY
CONSERVATION CORPS HAS TOLD ME
THAT THE OTHER 13 CORES WILL NOT
COLLECT CARPET UNTIL THIS
PROGRAM IS CHANGED. SO WE'RE
VERY MUCH HOPING THAT THE OTHER
14 CORES IN THE FUTURE, SHOULD
THIS BILL PASS, COLLECT THE
CARPET, WHICH WOULD EXPAND
OPTIONS FOR CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PROGRESS MADE
BY CARE SINCE 2010 TO INCREASE
THE RECYCLING RATE HAS BEEN
RELATIVELY SLOW BECAUSE WHEN YOU
START A PROGRAM THAT'S THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT, RECYCLERS LIKE
AQUAFIL HAVE LITERALLY CLOSED
PLANTS LIKE THE ONE IN WOODLAND,
WHICH I WORK PERSONALLY VERY
HARD TO GET HERE INTO CALIFORNIA
WAS HEARTBREAKING. TO LOSE THAT
50 JOBS AND THEY MOVED THAT
CONSUMER FUNDED, EXCUSE ME
EQUIPMENT OUT OF STATE DUE TO
NOT RECEIVING ENOUGH CARPET TO
RECYCLE, WHILE MORE THAN 60% OF
CARPET IS STILL BEING
LANDFILLED, 14 YEARS AFTER THE
ORIGINAL BILL PASSED, AND WITH
THE FOUR REMAINING CARPET
RECYCLERS ALL DESPERATE TO GET
MORE CARPET, THEY'RE LITERALLY
POACHING EACH OTHER'S CARPET
SUPPLIES AT THIS POINT. THAT'S
HOW DESPERATE THEY ARE TO FEED
THESE PLANTS. AB 863 ELIMINATES
THE VISIBLE CONSUMER FEE AND
REQUIRES THE PRODUCERS TO PAY,
WHICH FURTHER INCENTIVIZES THE
PRODUCER TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS
AND DESIGN PRODUCTS WITH COST
EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS AND
ELIMINATES THE HASSLE TO
RETAILERS TO COLLECT THE FEE. IT
ALSO REDUCES THE PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE AT RETAILERS WHERE THEY'RE
BEING ASKED A LOT, WHAT IS THIS
FEE? WHAT IS THIS FEE? I'VE
PERSONALLY ASKED THIS QUESTION.
THE RESPONSE I GOT FROM THE
CLERK WAS IT'S JUST ANOTHER
GOVERNMENT TAX. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT'S FOR. SO THAT'S ANOTHER
PROBLEM. WHEN YOU PUT THAT ON
THERE, IT REALLY DOESN'T EDUCATE
THE CUSTOMER ABOUT MUCH. AB 863
ALSO PROVIDES NEW TOOLS TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIANS GET THE
PROGRAM THAT THEY DESERVE BY
AUTHORIZING CALRECYCLE TO REMOVE
THE PRODUCER RUN ORGANIZATION
FROM MANAGING THE PROGRAM SHOULD
THEY FAIL TO COMPLY THREE OR
MORE TIMES, THE FINES ARE GOING
TO GO UP TO $25,000 PER
VIOLATION, UP TO BASED ON THE
TYPE OF A VIOLATION. THE OTHER
BILLS ARE ACTUALLY AT 50,000.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WE HAD
TALKED TO THEM ABOUT IN
NEGOTIATIONS, ON PAR WITH
NATIONAL TRENDS. THE CARPET
SALES ARE DECLINING WHILE THE
SALE OF PRODUCTS SUCH AS
RESILIENT FLOORING IS GOING UP.
IN FACT, IT EVEN SAYS THAT ON
THE MOHAWK WEBSITE BECAUSE THEY
SELL BOSTON MOHAWK, SELL BOTH
FLOORING. THE RESILIENT FLOORING
AND CARPET AND THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WILL BE REQUIRED IN
AB 863 TO EVALUATE WHAT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO COLLECT AND RECYCLE
THE RESILIENT FLOORING TO INFORM
THE ADDITION OF RESILIENT
FLOORING TO THE STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT NEW YORK DID PASS A CARPET
LEGISLATION THAT IS AN
INTERNALIZED COST AND DOES
INCLUDE THE ARTIFICIAL TURF. SO
WE'RE NOT THE ONLY ONES. NOW
THAT HAVE DONE THIS, WE HAVE HAD
AT LEAST SIX MEETINGS WITH THE
OPPOSITION DATING BACK TO JUNE
OF 2023, AND THEY HAVE HAD THE
PN THAT INCLUDES THE CHANGES
WHICH ADDED THE EPR AND THE
FLOORING TYPES SINCE SEPTEMBER
OF LAST YEAR. UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS TO
FIND MIDDLE GROUND AFTER OVER A
YEAR OF DISCUSSIONS, WE
ULTIMATELY DISAGREE ON SEVERAL
POINTS, INCLUDING THE NEED TO
FUND THE COLLECTORS THAT WORK ON
THEIR BEHALF TO COLLECT THE
CARPET AND GET THE RECYCLING
NUMBERS UP, AND THAT THEY SHOULD
PAY FOR THE PROGRAM. THERE'S
VERY FEW STATES WHO ALLOW PUBLIC
MONEY TO BE COLLECTED, AND THEN
JUST GIVEN TO ANOTHER INDUSTRY
GROUP. THAT'S ESPECIALLY OUT OF
STATE, ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
CONTINUE TO FAIL TO PERFORM. AND
THERE'S A LONG LIST OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AS RECENT AS
IN APRIL, WHERE THEY FAILED TO,
COMPLETE, LET ME SEE. CAL
RECYCLE DID A CONDITIONAL
APPROVAL ON THE REVISED
CONTINGENCY PLAN IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR. BACK IN DECEMBER,
CALRECYCLE DISAPPROVED THEIR
CONTINGENCY PLAN AMENDMENT, AND
IN JANUARY, CALRECYCLE FOUND
THEM NON-COMPLIANT ON THEIR 2022
ANNUAL REPORT. AND THAT'S JUST
THE MOST CURRENT THINGS ON THEIR
WEBSITE. SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
GET YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AND FIX THIS PROGRAM ONCE AND
FOR ALL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS VAL
CHESTER, AND I AM THE LEAD FLOOR
COVERING INSTRUCTOR FOR,
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA,
I'M REPRESENTING DISTRICT
COUNCIL 16 AND THE IUBAT, AS YOU
KNOW, CARPETS MADE OF ALL MOST
OF THE CARPET WERE INSTALLING
TODAY IS SYNTHETIC. IT'S
PLASTIC. WE, BY PROPERLY
TRAINING INSTALLED OWNERS TO
INSTALL THE MATERIAL, THE
MATERIAL HAS A HAS A MUCH LONGER
LIFE LIFESPAN, AND THERE'S LESS
OF IT GOING INTO THE LANDFILLS.
ALSO IF THE CARPET IS INSTALLED
INCORRECTLY, THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE YOU CANNOT EVEN
RECYCLE IT, FOR INSTANCE, USING
THE WRONG ADHESIVE IF IT'S GLUED
DOWN, PUTTING TOO MUCH ADHESIVE,
OPEN TIMES WORK IN TIMES, THE
STUDENTS NEED TO LEARN THAT.
THEY ALSO NEED TO, LEARN HOW TO
HANDLE IT AND WHAT IS EXPECTED
OF THEM WHEN THE WHEN THE
MATERIAL IS TO BE, RECYCLED.
LET'S SEE. YEAH. THANK YOU,
AGAIN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF OF THE
450,000 MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES, INCLUDING OVER 65,000
MEN AND WOMEN IN OUR STATE OF
THE ART APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
MANY OF THESE ARE DISADVANTAGED,
FORMERLY INCARCERATED,
EMANCIPATED YOUTH AND MILITARY
VETERANS. I DON'T HAVE A LOT TO
ADD ON THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF
THIS BILL, BUT I'M CONTINUOUSLY
IMPRESSED BY THE BY VAL AND THE
OTHER INSTRUCTORS ON NEW
PRODUCTS AND STATE OF THE ART
SYSTEMS BEING TAUGHT IN OUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT IT IS MORE THAN
INCONVENIENT WHEN ONE OF THESE
SYSTEMS FAILS, AND A COMPANY HAS
TO MOVE ALL THE FURNITURE OUT
THE CUBICLES, RELOCATE THE
EMPLOYEES IN ORDER TO FIX THE
FALSE FAULTY INSTALLATION, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER FOLKS WANT TO WEIGH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? YEAH
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, WESTERN PLACER
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY, STOP
WASTE, AND THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL, ALL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. JORDAN WELLS, EXPRESSING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF ZERO WASTE
SONOMA CALPIRG AQUAFIL MARIN
SANITARY SERVICE CIRCULAR
POLYMERS, MOJAVE DESERT AND
MOUNTAIN RECYCLING AUTHORITY
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR CHEMICAL
AND TOXIC SAFETY SACRAMENTO
SPLASH, RUSSIAN HILL NEIGHBORS
RISE BUILDING SOLUTIONS,
NATIONAL WASTE RECOVERY,
BROADVIEW, BROADVIEW GROUP,
ARIZONA ALTERNATIVES, APEX
MANUFACTURING, RETAILER
CORPORATION, TRANSPORT TECH,
LOGISTICS, CLOVER PLASTICS,
CIRCULAR STRATEGY, FRANKFURT
PLASTICS, BETTER IMAGE
RECYCLING. SEA HUGGER PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP INSTITUTE AND
REPURPOSE EARTH. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, IT'S A LOT. NICHOLAS
MAZZOTTI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU, KAYLA
ROBINSON, ON BEHALF OF RETHINK
WASTE AND SUPPORT. THANKS, BILL
ALEO EWG. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, NOW, LET'S HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION WHO'S COMING UP.
YEAH, YEAH. THERE'S FOUR OF
THEM. SO MAYBE HEIDI STEPS BACK
FOR NOW. THERE'S FOUR. OH, GOSH.
YEP JUST TRIPPED OVER THE LEG.
OKAY ASSEMBLYWOMAN SAT IN FRONT.
WE TRY TO TELL MY SECRETS. ALL
RIGHT. MAY PROCEED. ONE READY?
OKAY PROCEED. YEAH, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ROBERT PEEPLES
. I'M A PHYSICAL ORGANIC CHEMIST
BY TRAINING WITH 40 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE. I'M ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF CARE AND HAVE SERVED
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SINCE
MY RETURN IN 2012. MY GOAL AS A
SCIENTIST IS TO SHARE FACTS,
EXPERIENCE AND INFORMATION TO
HELP YOU AND OTHERS MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS THAT YOU CAN
MAKE. MY WORK IS DRIVEN AT THIS
STAGE OF MY CAREER BY MY TWO
GRANDCHILDREN, IN THE HOPE OF
PROVIDING THEM A BETTER WORLD TO
GROW UP IN. I AM, IN FACT, PROUD
OF THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE WE HAD BUMPS
AND BRUISES ALONG THE WAY?
ABSOLUTELY. HAVE WE LEARNED FROM
THOSE AND MADE ADJUSTMENTS?
ABSOLUTELY. DID WE START WITH A
BLANK SHEET OF PAPER? YES WE
DID. AND WHAT I MEAN BY THIS IS
THAT WE HAD NO INFRASTRUCTURE
COLLECTIONS, REPORTING SYSTEM
PRODUCTS INTO WHICH TO PUT THESE
MATERIALS. THE DEDICATED TEAM OF
CARE HAS WORKED WITH THE
RECYCLERS TO DELIVER
UNPARALLELED PROGRESS. DESPITE
THE WINDS OF COVID AND THE
TURMOILS OF THE MARKETPLACE THAT
WE HAVE TO OPERATE IN TODAY.
WE'VE ALSO ENROLLED THE BEST
CONSULTANTS IN BUSINESS WHO HELP
GUIDE OUR WORK, IN PARTICULAR,
CASCADIA CONSULTING AND CHRO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE
CONSULTING FIRMS NØ TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND DO A LOT OF
WORK WITH CAL RECYCLE. THEY'VE
HELPED PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
GUIDANCE ON OUR PLANS. IN
ADDITION, WE DO COMMUNICATE
REGULARLY AND OFTEN WITH THE
STAFF OVER AT CAL RECYCLE. I
BELIEVE THE FACTS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES, AND I DO HAVE A
CHART HERE THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE. EXCUSE
ME, A RECYCLING RATE IN Q1 OF
THIS YEAR AT 42% NOW EQUALS THE
OVERALL RECYCLING RATE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OUR TARGET
FOR 2024 IS 34. IN 22, WE HIT
ALL OF OUR GOALS EXCEPT FOR ONE,
AND WE MISSED THAT GOAL BY 12.
SO THE WORLD IS NOT BLACK AND
WHITE, IN 23 WE MET OR EXCEEDED
ALL OF OUR TARGETS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ONE, AND THAT ONE
WE MISSED BY ONLY 5% BECAUSE THE
MARKETS IN Q4 JUST COLLAPSED AND
NOBODY WOULD BUY THE MATERIALS
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO MOVE.
CARE RECYCLERS HAVE DIVERTED
OVER 1.2 BILLION POUNDS FROM THE
LANDFILL SINCE THE PROGRAM
STARTED, AND OUR MICRO GRANTS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A MAJOR SUCCESS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
MUNICIPALITIES. WE DO USE A CAL
RECYCLE APPROVED FORMULA AS WE
CALCULATE OUR RECYCLING RATE.
ARE THERE STILL OPPORTUNITIES TO
GROW AND IMPROVE? ABSOLUTELY AND
CARE WORKS ON THOSE EVERY SINGLE
DAY WITH ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
. UNFORTUNATELY, I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT FOR YOU THAT THE
BRIEFING PAPER YOU HOLD, WHICH
IS MEANT TO INFORM YOUR
DECISIONS, DOES HAVE SOME
FACTUAL ERRORS THAT HAVE BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED, AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE MY THOUGHTS ON WHAT THOSE
ARE WITH YOU IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED. ONE PARTICULAR
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS THAT AN
ELEMENT OF H 63 AROUND THE UNION
FUNDING, WE HAVE TRIED TO WORK
DILIGENTLY WITH DC 16 AND 36,
AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU THE
LONG LIST OF EFFORTS THAT WE'VE
DONE. HOWEVER, WE HAVE DONE,
FREQUENT TRAININGS WITH BOTH
UNIONS. WE HAVE ALL OF THE
TRAINING MATERIALS IN PLACE,
INCLUDING VIDEOS IN BOTH THE
ENGLISH AND SPANISH, WHICH ARE
READILY ACCESSIBLE ONLINE. AND
WE'VE DONE MULTIPLE TRAIN THE
TRAINER PROGRAMS TO PREPARE THE
UNION TRAINERS. WE'VE MET WITH A
LOT OF RESISTANCE FROM THE
UNIONS, THE UNIONS REPRESENT
ABOUT 15% OF ALL THE INSTALLERS
IN IN, IN, IN CALIFORNIA,
THERE'S JUST NO JUSTIFICATION
FOR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, UP TO
10% OF THE BUDGET WHERE WE COULD
USE THOSE FUNDS TO BETTER
SUPPORT THE COLLECTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO BUILD. RECYCLING CARPET FROM
A COLLECTIONS AND TRANSPORT
POINT OF VIEW IS NOT ROCKET
SCIENCE, AND IT JUST DOESN'T
REQUIRE THAT MUCH MONEY TO TRAIN
. WHEN ALL OF THESE MATERIALS
ARE IN PLACE IN CONCLUSION, I'D
LIKE TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CARE IS WORKING BY LOOKING AT
THE METRICS. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. WHY WOULD WHY WOULD THIS
BODY WANT TO DISMANTLE THE
PROGRAM THAT HAS CREATED
HUNDREDS OF JOBS AND RECYCLED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF POUNDS
OF CARPET INTO INNOVATIVE AND
NEW PRODUCTS, WITH A NEW PROGRAM
STARTING FROM SCRATCH WITH NO
PROOF THAT IT WILL WORK. SO
AGAIN, I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND JUST LEAVE YOU
WITH ONE LAST THOUGHT. SYSTEMS,
LOGISTICS ANALYSIS TELLS US THAT
WHEN YOU TRY TO CHANGE SOMETHING
FASTER THAN A SYSTEM CAN
ACCOMMODATE THE CHANGE, IT LEADS
TO CHAOS AND LACK OF EFFICIENCY
IN MANY CASES, THERE'S BEEN
EFFORTS TO TRY TO CHANGE WHAT
WE'RE DOING FASTER THAN THE
SYSTEM CAN ABSORB. THOSE CHANGES
AND RESPOND TO THOSE CHANGES. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ANTHONY
SAMPSON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
RESILIENT FLOOR COVERINGS
INSTITUTE. RFCI IS A TRADE
ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF
RESILIENT FLOOR COVERING
PRODUCERS AND MANUFACTURERS THAT
MANUFACTURE VINYL COMPOSITION
TILE LUXURY TILE, SOLID VINYL,
TILE, SHEET, VINYL TILE, RUBBER
TILE, AND OTHER TYPES OF
RESILIENT FLOORING. LET ME FIRST
START BY THANKING THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, AGUIAR-CURRY AND HER
STAFF FOR REACHING OUT AFTER THE
BILL WAS INTRODUCED AND
EXPRESSING A WILLINGNESS TO MEET
WITH RFCI TO DISCUSS THEIR
CONCERNS. WITH THIS MEASURE.
WHILE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING IN THAT DIALOG, I WOULD
BE REMISS NOT TO RAISE SOME
PROCESS RELATED CONCERNS WITH
HOW THIS IS ALL UNFOLDED. I
TYPICALLY SHY AWAY FROM RAISING
THOSE TYPES OF CONCERNS BECAUSE
LATE STAGE AMENDMENTS ARE JUST A
REALITY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS, BUT IN THIS CASE, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN RFK'S HOPE AND
EXPECTATION TO ENGAGE IN SOME
LEVEL OF DIALOG BEFORE A BILL OF
THIS MAGNITUDE WAS PUT INTO
PRINT. SO BASICALLY, AB 863 IS
AMENDED JUST LAST WEEK, NOW
REQUIRES CAL RECYCLED TO PREPARE
A NEEDS ASSESSMENT FOR RESILIENT
FLOORING AND GIVES CAL RECYCLED
UNFETTERED AUTHORITY TO COMPLETE
AND APPROVE A PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PLAN THAT
INCLUDES RESILIENT FLOORING. WE
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WILL NOW
REQUIRE CAL RECYCLE TO CONSIDER
WHETHER OR NOT RESILIENT
FLOORING SHOULD BE INCLUDED. IT
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN ITS OWN
PRO OR PART OF AN EXISTING ONE.
BUT EITHER WAY, AB 863
PRESUPPOSES THAT RESILIENT
FLOORING WILL BE PART OF THIS
MASSIVE NEW PROGRAM IN SOME WAY,
SHAPE OR FORM. RFCI UNDERSTANDS
AND APPRECIATES THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONDUCTING A NEEDS ASSESSMENT
BEFORE ESTABLISHING A PROGRAM.
BUT KEEP IN MIND THAT RESILIENT
FLOORING ENCOMPASSES SEVERAL
TYPES OF FLOORING PRODUCTS WITH
A BROAD RANGE OF PHYSICAL
PROPERTIES AND APPLICATIONS.
INDEED, DIFFERENT TYPES OF
RESILIENT FLOORING FACE DISTINCT
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNICAL AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ASSOCIATED WITH RECYCLING.
FOR THIS REASON, WE BELIEVE THAT
UPON COMPLETION OF A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT, CAL RECYCLE SHOULD
INSTEAD ISSUE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE AS TO HOW TO
ESTABLISH THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM POSSIBLE TO ADDRESS END
OF LIFE MANAGEMENT OF RESILIENT
FLOORING RFCI WOULD STAND READY
AT THAT TIME TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAR CURRY AND
THIS COMMITTEE THROUGH THE
COURSE OF A FULL LEGISLATIVE
SESSION, TO ESTABLISH A PROGRAM
THAT WORKS FOR MANUFACTURERS,
CONSUMERS AND RECYCLERS AND
OTHER ENTITIES THROUGHOUT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. RFCI AND ITS
MEMBERS HAVE DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE IN TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA,
ESTABLISHING A NEW PROGRAM OF
THIS MAGNITUDE ON A NEW PRODUCT
CATEGORY WILL REQUIRE EXTENSIVE
DIALOG BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND OUR TECHNICAL
EXPERTS. BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT DOING SO WITHIN THE SHORT
TIME FRAME THAT WE HAVE LEFT
WILL BE EXTRAORDINARILY
CHALLENGING AND WILL LEAD TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
UNNECESSARILY FLAWED PROGRAM.
THANKS FOR CONSIDERING OUR
COMMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED DIALOG WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
GREG HERNER, ON BEHALF OF THE
SYNTHETIC TURF COUNCIL, WE
REPRESENT THE MANUFACTURERS,
INSTALLERS, ALL THE COMPANIES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THAT HANDLE
AND INSTALL SYNTHETIC TURF. I'M
ALSO VERY, FAMILIAR WITH THE
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
PROGRAMS, HAVING HELPED DRAFT
SOME OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE. AND I
WORK ON COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CALRECYCLE ON ON PLANS AS WELL,
WE HAVE I'M REALLY CONFUSED,
THOUGH, BECAUSE FIRST WE HAVE
THE SUPPORTERS SAYING THE CARPET
PROGRAM DOESN'T WORK AND THEN WE
HAVE THE INDUSTRY SAYING IT
DOES. WELL IF THE CARPET
PROGRAM'S NOT WORKING, WHY DO
YOU WANT TO ADD US TO IT?
ESPECIALLY WITHOUT ANY
DISCUSSION. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO SOME OF ANTHONY SAMPSON'S
CONVERSATIONS. WE WERE OFFERED A
THREE HOUR BLOCK OF TIME THE DAY
BEFORE THIS HEARING, AS THE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CONSULTATION ON THIS. IF THERE
WAS AN RN FLOATING AROUND FROM
SEPTEMBER, WE NEVER SAW IT. WE
NEVER SAW THE BILL UNTIL IT WAS
IN PRINT. SYNTHETIC TURF IS USED
IN DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS. IT IS
NOT USED. IT'S NOT SWAPPABLE FOR
CARPET. IT'S MADE OUT OF A
DIFFERENT CHEMICAL COMPONENT.
POLY ETHYLENE INSTEAD OF
POLYPROPYLENE. IT CANNOT WHEN
YOU WHEN THEY RECYCLE, THEY HAVE
TO BREAK IT DOWN INTO ITS
COMPONENT PARTS. THE LARGEST
CARPET RECYCLER IN LOS ANGELES
HAS STATED THAT THEY CAN'T
RECYCLE SYNTHETIC TURF. THE
INDUSTRY IS NOT OPPOSED TO
WORKING ON RECYCLING, BUT WE
DON'T HAVEN'T EVEN HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIND OUT WHETHER
WE SHOULD BE IN THE CARPET
PROGRAM OR SET UP OUR OWN
PROGRAM, AND WE'VE NEVER GIVEN
THE COURTESY OF THAT DISCUSSION.
SO WE ALSO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
REUSE COMPONENT, ONE OF THE
LARGEST COMPANIES THAT DOES TURF
REUSE IS IN THE AUTHOR'S
DISTRICT. THAT REUSE IS NOT EVEN
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THIS BILL. SO
WE ARE. THERE'S OTHER COMPONENTS
ON THIS THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE
COSTS, SUCH AS LIKE SAYING YOU
HAVE TO HAVE DRY STORAGE,
SYNTHETIC TURF. IT'S IN ATHLETIC
FIELDS. ONE OF THE PURPOSE OF
IT, IT'S MADE TO GET WET. WHY DO
YOU HAVE TO BUILD EXTRA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND COST INTO A
PROGRAM FOR SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE KEPT THAT
WAY? THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THIS PROGRAM THAT ARE
JUST PICKED UP AND DROPPED IN
FROM OTHER PROGRAMS. WITHOUT
LOOKING AT THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
THE OF THE ADDITIONAL TYPES OF
FLOORING, BOTH RESILIENT
FLOORING AND SYNTHETIC TURF THAT
THAT THERE'S NOT TIME. YOU CAN'T
JUST DO THAT IN THESE PROGRAMS.
THERE HAS TO BE A MORE
THOUGHTFUL, DELIBERATIVE
PROCESS, AS THE CHAIRMAN KNOWS,
WHO SPENT YEARS WORKING ON SB
54, IT TAKES THAT MUCH EFFORT TO
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT ARE UNIQUE TO
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS AND MAKE
SURE IT WORKS. I ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN CONSULTING WITH A COMPANY
THAT WANTS TO START A RECYCLING
FACILITY IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE NOW WITH THIS BILL
BEING INTRODUCED. THEY'RE LIKE
CONCERNED ABOUT SHOULD THEY MAKE
THOSE CAPITAL INVESTMENTS OR
NOT? BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THIS PROGRAM IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE FOR ADDITIONAL YEARS.
THAT'S GOING TO DELAY
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE TURF
INDUSTRY TO DO RECYCLING. PLUS,
WE ALSO HAVE THE INFILL AND
OTHER COMPONENTS THAT WE
RECYCLE. IT'S NOT JUST THE TURF.
AND SO WHEN THE INDUSTRY IS
TALKING ABOUT RECYCLING, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT HOLISTICALLY
AND SO RESPECTFULLY. WE SEE NO
REASON, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT EVEN INCLUDED IN THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. LIKE WHY WERE YOU
YOU'RE JUST ADDING THIS TO THIS
PROGRAM WITHOUT A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT OR EVEN LOOKING AT
OUR INDUSTRY? THANK YOU. SO WITH
RESPECT, WE'D ASK TO BE
WITHDRAWN FROM THE BILL. THANK
YOU. OKAY. WE'RE WE'RE BOTH
SIDES ARE OVER TIME. NOW WE HAVE
A FOURTH PERSON. SO IF YOU COULD
KEEP IT I'LL BE ONE MINUTE.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING RANDY
POLLACK ON BEHALF OF THE CARPET
AND RUG INSTITUTE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM, I
JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
GOALS DEFINE THE SUCCESS OF A
PROGRAM. IT SHOULDN'T BE THE
STRUCTURE. AND LET'S LOOK WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE. CARE HAS A PLAN
THAT GOES THROUGH AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT THEN GOES TO
CALRECYCLE THAT IS APPROVED. SO
EVERYBODY HAS INPUT THAT WAS
APPROVED ON APRIL 1ST, 2023,
THEIR LAST FIVE YEAR PLAN. THEY
ARE MEETING GOALS OF THAT PLAN.
SO FOR SOME OF THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL SAYING, WELL, YOU
AREN'T MEETING GOALS, YOU NEED
TO DO OTHER THINGS. YOU'RE
SWITCHING THE RULES ON US. WE
ARE ABIDING BY WHAT'S IN OUR
PLAN, WHAT HAS BEEN SET OUT. AND
AS MR. PEEPLES INDICATED, WE MET
12 OUT OF THE 13 GOALS AND WE
MISSED THE ONE BY 5. AND I CAN
TELL YOU EVERY YEAR, EVERY
PROGRAM, YOU AREN'T GOING TO
MEET ALL YOUR GOALS. I MEAN, YOU
WOULD LIKE TO, BUT ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS. LASTLY, I'LL JUST
ADD WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT THE
RECYCLING RATE, IF YOU WANT TO
DEBATE HOW THE RECYCLING RATE
SHOULD BE CALCULATED,
UNDERSTANDABLY, BUT LOOK AT THE
WAY IT'S BEEN GOING OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS, IT CONTINUES TO
INCREASE EVERY YEAR. THAT'S WHAT
SHOULD BE LOOKED UPON. AND IF
YOU COMPARE US TO THE MATTRESS
PROGRAM, OUR 41% WOULD BE AT 75.
SO PLEASE JUST DON'T LOOK AT
SAYING WE AREN'T RECYCLING
ENOUGH. LOOK AT THE SCALE OF THE
WAY IT'S HAPPENING. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
LET'S HEAR FROM OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO WEIGH IN IN OPPOSITION
FROM THE MIC. HELLO, SILVIO
FERRARA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, OPPOSITION, ROB
SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION, JOHN
MOFFATT, ON BEHALF OF SHAW
INDUSTRIES AND THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION IN
OPPOSITION. CARPET IN THE CARS,
TOO. ALL RIGHT. GOSH. WELL, LET
ME, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU TO
THE AUDIENCE FOR GIVING US EXTRA
TIME FOR EVERYONE TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION, WHICH I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE. I
MEAN, THIS WAS A IT THIS THIS IS
A BIG BILL THAT IS BROUGHT TO US
VERY LATE. AND THAT DOES CREATE
A CHALLENGE. NOW, I DO WANT TO
THANK, THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
INPUT FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE HERE. READY TO ENGAGE, WE DO
KNOW THAT CARPET SALES ARE GOING
DOWN AS MORE OFFICES AND
BUSINESSES SWITCH OVER TO
RESILIENT FLOORING, AS THEY CALL
IT, SO, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW THERE
ARE NEEDS FOR CHANGES GIVEN
CHANGES IN MARKET TRENDS, AND I
WILL SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, I DO AT
LEAST CONCEPTUALLY, VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR, NOT JUST
LOOKING TO REFORM THE CURRENT
EPR PROGRAM FOR CARPETS, BUT
ALSO LOOKING AHEAD TO CHALLENGES
COMING DOWN THE ROAD BY
INCLUDING OTHER FLOORING TYPES
IN THE BILL. I KNOW THAT'S NOT
WITHOUT CHALLENGE. YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES THAT I
THINK HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPONENTS TODAY, THE PROCESS IS
HEIDI KNOWS VERY WELL, AND THE
AUTHOR KNOWS TOO, BECAUSE SHE
WAS ABLE TO WE TALKED MANY, MANY
TIMES OVER THE YEARS AS I WAS
TRYING TO GET SB 54 ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE. THIS, THESE, THESE
THINGS TAKE A LOT OF WORK AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF UNIQUE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH EVERY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY AND EVERY
DIFFERENT PRODUCT, NOW, SO, YOU
KNOW, I KNOW WE BASICALLY BY
ALLOWING THIS BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD, WE'VE RUINED A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE'S SUMMERS,
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT
OF WORK OVER THE RECESS, QUITE
FRANKLY, TO SEE IF YOU CAN PULL
SOMETHING TOGETHER THAT'S GOING
TO MEET ALL OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED. AND I
JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER
IS TO THAT. I'M CERTAINLY
WILLING TO GIVE YOU THAT
OPPORTUNITY. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, I WE'LL SEE WHAT
THE COLLEAGUES. BUT BUT, IT'S
GOING TO IT'S GOING TO BE A
TOUGH, NEGOTIATION. AND, THAT
INCLUDES A LOT OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS. I MEAN, IT INCLUDES,
YOU KNOW, HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT
WE ADEQUATELY FUND THE LABOR
PROGRAMS, BUT ALSO KEEP THOSE
COSTS WITHIN REASON, GIVEN ALL
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO FUND, WITHIN THE, THE
PROGRAM. SO I DO, I THINK THAT
THERE'S A, A DECENT SHOT THAT,
THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT SOMETHING
GOOD HERE, WE KNOW THERE'S A
NEED, I'M A, YOU KNOW, STRONG
BELIEVER IN EPR, OBVIOUSLY, AND
I, YOU KNOW, I HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN MISS SANBORN'S
WORK, WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER ON 54. BUT I ALSO KNOW
HOW CHALLENGING EVERY
INDIVIDUAL, A NEW PRODUCT, A NEW
PROGRAM IS. AND SO THOSE ARE MY
THOUGHTS ON THIS, BUT I KNOW I,
I HOPE, YOU KNOW, THANKFULLY,
THE MAJORITY LEADER LIVES CLOSE
TO SACRAMENTO BECAUSE, SHE'LL BE
HERE FOR LOTS OF MEETINGS. MR.
VICE CHAIR, THANK YOU. SEE YOU.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. SO I HAVE, MAYBE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT TAKE. I
ACTUALLY HAVE THE I DON'T KNOW
IF WE I DON'T KNOW THE NEW
DISTRICT LINES, BUT I HAVE THE I
WENT AND TOURED THE RECYCLING
PLANT IN MY DISTRICT, WHICH IS
RIGHT OUT OF SACRAMENTO HERE. SO
THEY DO THE, THE, TURF. THEY I
BELIEVE WE SAW TURF THERE AS
WELL. SO THAT WAS A MAYBE 15
MONTHS AGO. I THINK I WENT
THROUGH THE PLANT, LOOKED AT THE
PROCESS. IT'S HAPPY TO SEE IT.
SO FIRST OF ALL, JUST MY
CONCERN. FIRST, NUMBER ONE IS
THIS IS VERY LATE IN THE GAME.
GOTTEN THEM IN LIKE FOR ME
SEEING IT. AND I KNOW THAT I
HEARD THAT FROM THE OPPOSITION
AS WELL. SO MAYBE HAVE SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT TIMING, THE
OTHER THING IS, IS THAT I KNOW
THERE WAS A PLANT MOVED OUT. I
STILL BELIEVE THEY'RE IN ARIZONA
OR SOMEWHERE, AND THEY'RE TAKING
CALIFORNIA RECYCLABLES AND STILL
RECYCLING. MAYBE BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY HARD TO DO BUSINESS HERE.
YEAH, WELL, I'M NOT HAPPY ABOUT
THAT. BUT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER
DISCUSSION ON HOW WE DO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA, UNFORTUNATELY.
SO, BUT THE REAL POINT I WANT TO
GET OUT IN THIS BILL. I THINK,
IS WHAT THOSE CONCERNS OUT THERE
IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO A
PRODUCER PAY SITUATION. AND SO
THAT GETS INCORPORATED INTO THE
CARPET. AND THE CONSUMER AT THE
IT'S EXPENSIVE TO DO ANYTHING IN
CALIFORNIA. HOUSING IS GOING UP.
EVERYTHING'S GOING UP AND
INPUTS. AND THIS IS GOING TO
CAUSE THOSE INPUTS TO GO UP. AT
THE SAME TIME, I'M NOT CONVINCED
THAT WE'RE REALLY DOING THAT BAD
OF A JOB YET. I THINK THAT THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT IS THAT WE
MAY NOT HIT THE TARGET YOU WANT.
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT, WE'RE
ADDING OTHER PRODUCTS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN VETTED OUT AND HOW
WE SHOULD GET THERE. SO THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT WITH THIS BILL
AT THE PACE AND SCALE WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE. SO THAT'S I
THINK NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT. AND
THE OTHER THING I'M REALLY
FRUSTRATED WITH IS THAT NO
OFFENSE TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
UNION WORLD, BUT THIS IS LIKE A
GRAB. AND AGAIN, THEY'RE GOING
TO GET MONEY THAT NOBODY ELSE
GETS TO TRAIN AND DO IT. BUT THE
UNIONS HAVE GOT A POWERFUL
INFLUENCE HERE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, I DON'T THINK
THAT'S FAIR, TO ALL THE PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT WORK AND REMOVE
CARPET, THIS IS A CARVE OUT FOR
UNIONS. SO THOSE ARE THE THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. I
THINK IT NEEDS A LOT MORE WORK.
AND I THINK THAT JUST PUSHING IT
THROUGH GETS US TUNED IN WHERE
WE DON'T REALLY GET GOOD. LOOK,
WE WORKED ON 54, AND IT TOOK A
LONG TIME AND WE GOT WE GOT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THAT. IT
WAS A HUGE DEAL. AND YOU KNOW,
JUST THIS YEAR WE SAW PEOPLE
COMING BACK AND MESSING WITH
THAT PROCESS. AND IN LEGISLATION
. AND I WAS FRUSTRATED ABOUT
THAT. LOOK, WE WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. WE WANT TO KEEP THE
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO
RECYCLE. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, YOU CAN'T. I THINK IT'S
UNFAIR TO MOVE IN THIS TYPE OF
FASHION. SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I
WON'T BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND I HOPE THIS BILL, IT NEEDS A
LOT MORE WORK. I THINK IT NEEDS,
YOU KNOW, I WON'T BE HERE NEXT
YEAR, BUT AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'LL BE HERE, I THINK YOU'LL
BE HERE NEXT YEAR. BUT ANYWAY, I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS, SLOW DOWN AND DO
THE RIGHT THING HERE. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. OKAY. THANK
YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR. OTHER
QUESTIONS, THOUGHTS? I MEAN, I
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING
TO BE WE'VE GOT OUR COMMITTEE
HAS A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS
SPACE LESS THAN CARPET
OBVIOUSLY, BUT A LOT OF DNEPR,
AND, IF THE BILL DOES PASS OUT
TODAY, THERE'S GOING TO BE
ABIDING INTEREST BY THE
COMMITTEE KIND OF FOLLOWING AND
BIRD DOG IN THE NEGOTIATIONS
HAPPENS, WHICH I THINK WILL BE
ROBUST AND INTENSE. I MEAN, I'D
LOVE TO ACTUALLY JUST ASK YOU,
MADAM MAJORITY LEADER, ABOUT HOW
YOU SEE, GIVEN ALL THE
CHALLENGES AND CONCERNS AND THE
TIME FRAME HERE, HOW YOU SEE
THESE NEGOTIATIONS GOING OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. WELL, I'M
NOT GOING TO LIE ABOUT IT, BUT
WE'VE BEEN THIS IS A TWO YEAR
BILL, SO IT WASN'T A GUT NAMIN.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
NONSTOP. WE'VE MET WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS, WE'VE MET WITH
INDUSTRY, WE'VE MET FOR TWO
YEARS, WE'VE MET SO PEOPLE BEING
SURPRISED AT SOME AMENDMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO COME OUT THERE
SHOULD NOT BE VERY SURPRISED AT
ALL. SO IN MY FRUSTRATED.
ABSOLUTELY. BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN TO A LANDFILL
LATELY OR YOU TALK TO RECYCLERS,
THIS IS STILL AN ISSUE NOW.
YEAH, MAYBE WE'RE MOVING TO
OTHER PRODUCTS OUT THERE.
ABSOLUTELY. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT? I
NEED TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING AS A
VISION BECAUSE IT'S TAKEN THIS
MANY YEARS TO GET THIS FAR. CAN
YOU IMAGINE HOW LONG IT'S GOING
TO TAKE TO ADD THE OTHER
PRODUCTS? SO LET'S PUT IT IN
THERE. LET'S DO IT RIGHT. LET'S
MOVE ON. BUT THIS HAS BEEN TWO
YEARS THAT WE HAVE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION. SO I'M FRUSTRATED
THAT IT'S NOT A GUT AND AMEND AT
ALL. THIS WAS GOING RIGHT
THROUGH. WE'VE HAD PEOPLE IN AND
OUT OF MY OFFICE TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT. SO WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, I JUST WANT TO SAY IS
THAT OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT, BUT THE
FACT IS THIS IS NOTHING NEW TO
ANYONE. YOU KNOW, I JUST, THE
CARE PROGRAM HAS FAILED US MANY
TIMES, AND YOU CAN GO OUT TO THE
RECYCLERS AND THEY WILL TELL YOU
THE SAME THING. LET'S NOT LOOK
AT CONSULTANTS, LOOK AT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THE WORK
THAT ARE OUT THERE. SO, I MEAN,
I DO RESPECT TO THE OPPOSITION,
BUT THIS I MEAN, HOW LONG ARE WE
GOING TO LET THIS HAPPEN? WE'RE
TRYING TO CLEAN UP THE LANDFILLS
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND THIS IS
JUST ONE OF THE MANY PIECES. AND
I THINK THERE ARE SOME GOOD
PROJECTS THAT WE'VE DONE WITH
THE MATTRESS RECYCLING THAT
WORKED. SO DO WE BUILD OFF OF
THAT? YOU KNOW, SO I THINK THAT
TELLING ME THAT IT'S LIKE
GETTING A MEND AND THAT WE'RE
NOT THINKING ABOUT IT IS FAR
FROM THE TRUTH. SO YEAH, BUT
THAT'S NOT MY CLOSE. I'LL CLOSE
IT. ALL RIGHT. BUT BUT HOW DO
YOU SEE THE, NEGOTIATIONS
PROCEEDING, NEXT MONTH? YEAH. I
MEAN, WE'RE ALL IN TO NEGOTIATE
WITH EVERYONE TO GET THIS THING
DONE THIS YEAR. THIS IS OUR
THIRD AND LAST ATTEMPT AT
CLEANING UP THIS PROGRAM. WE'VE
CLEANED IT UP TWICE IN 2017 AND
2019. WE COULDN'T GET THE
LEGISLATURE TO GO WITH EPR. WE
ENDED UP IN NONCOMPLIANCE. WE
ENDED UP LOSING A FACILITY. WE
ENDED UP LOSING JOBS. WE
LITERALLY WE HAVE THIS RIGHT AT
THE EDGE AND WE CAN FIX IT. WE
CAN FIGURE IT OUT. WITH THESE
MANUFACTURERS, WE'RE HAPPY TO
TALK WITH EVERYONE WHO SHOWED
UP. WE HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH
ARQUETTE. ARQUETTE OWNS 70% OF
THE MARKET IN CALIFORNIA ON TURF
. WE HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH
MOHAWK AND SHAR. THEY BOTH ARE
MAJOR SELLERS OF LVRT. THEY KNEW
THIS WAS COMING. WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS MONTHS AND MONTHS AGO. THEY
WANTED TO KEEP TELLING US HOW
GREAT THEY WERE DOING, AND WE
KEPT SAYING, THAT'S GREAT. WE DO
HEAR YOU WHAT'S GOING WELL? BUT
THERE'S THINGS THAT ARE NOT
GOING WELL AND THERE'S ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF RECYCLE TIME GOING TO
OVERSEE THIS PROGRAM. SO WE
WOULD LIKE THE TIME TO WORK WITH
THEM. AND I'M WILLING TO NÓ
VACATION. I'M HERE. LET'S GO.
LET'S DIG INTO THE DETAILS.
BECAUSE REALLY, WE DO NEED TO
GET THIS DONE. AND I KNOW WE CAN
DO IT. WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE AND
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN. WELL, FROM
THE LOOK ON THEIR FACES, THEY
WERE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE VACATIONS. BUT, I GUESS
GONNA HAVE TO BE IN THE FALL.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THOUGHTS OR
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS? SENATOR DO YOU
INTERESTED IN MOVING THE BILL?
OKAY, ALL RIGHT, SO WE'LL GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
SENATORS KERRY'S REPEATEDLY
FAILED TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM
EFFECTIVELY AND EQUITABLY AND AS
REQUIRED OVERSIGHT AND REPEATED
ENFORCEMENT BY CALRECYCLE
RECYCLERS AND COLLECTORS HAVE
LEFT THE STATE OR GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS DUE TO THE LACK OF
FEEDBACK WHILE CARPET IS STILL
BEING LANDFILLED, THEATRICS BY
OPPONENTS DO NOT CHANGE THE FACT
OF KERRY'S PERFORMANCE. THIS
BILL ADDS OTHER RECYCLABLE
FLOORING TYPES, AS REQUESTED BY
THE RECYCLERS THAT REMAIN IN OUR
STATE, AND IT SETS RESILIENT
FLOORING ON A PATH TO
RECYCLABILITY BY ASKING
CALRECYCLE TO STUDY WHAT THE
PROGRAM NEEDS FOR THESE PRODUCTS
, WHAT THESE PRODUCTS MIGHT BE,
IT IS SILENT ON WHAT THAT
PROGRAM WILL LOOK LIKE OR WHERE
IT WILL BE HOUSED. IT ALSO
INVESTS IN WORKER TRAINING. SO
WE INCREASE THE RATE OF
RECYCLING THROUGH PROPER
INSTALLATION AND REMOVAL, SHIFT
TO INTERNALIZING THE COST OF
THIS PROGRAM STEERS INDUSTRY
TOWARDS RESPONSIBLY SPENDING
THEIR MONEY ON RECYCLING, AND
ELIMINATES THE BURDEN ON
CONSUMERS. AND LASTLY, THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT FOR RESILIENT
FLOORING GIVES THE INDUSTRY THE
TIME THAT THEY NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY CAN BE PART OF THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THIS
PROGRAM IS EFFECTIVE AND
IMPLEMENTABLE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. I VOTE.
OKAY, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
ROLL AB 863. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. SENATORS ALLEN I
ALLEN I DALLY NØ. DALLY NÓ
GONZALEZ. HURTADO MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NGUYEN OAN. SKINNER
OKAY, WE LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
ARE YOU DOING THE GRAYSON BILL,
OR ARE YOU? OR DID WE OR SHOULD
WE LET IT HAPPEN OR WHAT'S
GREAT. WHAT'S GOING ON? IS HE
GOING TO. DO YOU WANT ME TO SIT
NOW OR LATER? I DON'T KNOW, IT
DEPENDS ON. WHY DON'T YOU WORK
IT OUT WITH YOUR COLLEAGUE?
SORRY HEY. WE'RE SUPPORTING YOU.
YEAH. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY. IT'S A QUICK SUPPORT.
SUPPORT? SO IF YOU WANT TO DO
IT. I MEAN, Þ GRAYSON. FOR YOUR
VOTE TO MOVE THE BILL, THAT WILL
HELP ME OUT. OKAY OKAY. I'LL TRY
TO MAKE THIS QUICK FOR YOU.
OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON THIS BILL. I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AB 2091 IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT WOULD HELP EXPEDIATE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO OPEN SPACE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA UNDER THE
SEQUA. MOST AGENCIES, INCLUDING
PARK DISTRICTS, ARE REQUIRED TO
CONDUCT A SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR ANY
PROJECTS OR ACTIONS THAT WOULD
HAVE AN ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT,
UNLESS AN ACTION IS
CATEGORICALLY EXEMPTED.
CURRENTLY A CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTION EXISTS THAT ALLOWS A
PARK DISTRICT TO ACQUIRE LAND
FOR THE PURPOSES OF PRESERVING
OPEN SPACE WITHOUT NEEDING TO
PERFORM A REVIEW. UNDER SEQUA,
HOWEVER, NO EXEMPTIONS EXIST FOR
CHANGES OF USE, SUCH AS A PARK
DISTRICT WOULD LIKE TO OPEN A
REQUIRED LAND FOR PUBLIC ACCESS,
EVEN IF THE ACQUIRED LAND
ALREADY HAS EXISTING ROADS AND
TRAILS THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE
ACQUISITION. AB 2091 WILL EXEMPT
THE OPENING OF EXISTING ROADS
AND TRAILS FOR SPECIFIED
NON-MOTORIZED RECREATIONAL USES
TO THE PUBLIC ON OPEN SPACE
PROPERTIES OWNED AND OPERATED BY
AN AGENCY. THIS LIMITED
EXEMPTION WOULD ONLY APPLY TO IN
SCENARIOS WHERE ROADS AND OTHER
DISTURBED AREAS EXISTED PRIOR TO
PUBLIC AGENCY ACQUISITION, AND
WHERE NO SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS ON OPEN
SPACE OR PARK LANDS.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL WOULD
HAVE NO IMPACT ON EXISTING LAND
COVENANTS THAT WOULD APPLY SUCH
A GRANT. AGREEMENTS,
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS, AND
PLANS, OR LONG TERM MANAGEMENT
PLANS AND THE PARK DISTRICTS
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING MANAGEMENT POLICIES
THAT PROTECT SPECIES AND HABITAT
. IMPORTANTLY, THIS BILL WILL
ALSO HELP SAVE PARK DISTRICT
RESOURCES BY CLARIFYING WHEN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW MUST TAKE
PLACE AND HELP OPEN UP PUBLIC
ACCESS TO ACQUIRED LANDS IN A
QUICKER MANNER. ADDITIONALLY,
THE AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL WILL
LIMIT THE BILL TO FOUR
INDEPENDENT PARK SPECIAL PARK
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
ADD GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE THAT
SENSITIVE HABITATS ARE PROTECTED
. TODAY TO TESTIFY AS GAIL,
GAIL, JENNIFER GALEHOUSE,
REPRESENTING EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARKS. AND, THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE,
VOTE FOR MR. GRAYSON WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. HI, I'M
JENNIFER GALEHOUSE ON BEHALF OF
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK, THIS
BILL IS REALLY ABOUT AN
AMBIGUITY AMBIGUITY IN SEQUA
REGARDING WHETHER A CHANGE IN
USE FOR PUBLIC ACCESS IS A
DISCRETIONARY ACTION, IT'S ABOUT
A POINT IN TIME. IT DELAYS SEQUA
UNTIL THERE'S ACTUALLY A
PHYSICAL ALTERATION TO THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT, SO THERE
WILL BE A FULL ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS WHEN SOMETHING'S DONE
TO THE PARK, SUCH AS THE
ADDITION OF BATHROOMS OR CAMPING
GROUNDS, THINGS LIKE THAT, I
WILL SAY THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONFUSION WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
SOME OF THEIR ARGUMENTS. MAY
LEAD YOU TO THINK THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY CITING TRAILS OR
CHANGING TRAILS IN SOME WAY.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE USE OF
EXISTING TRAILS AND ROADS.
NOTHING WILL BE DONE THAT ALTERS
THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT, SO WITH
THAT, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. OKAY, FOLKS WHO
WANT TO WEIGH IN SUPPORT ETHAN
NAGLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS NICHOLAS MAZZOTTI ON
BEHALF OF MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. GREAT
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION. HEY, MATT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATORS MATTHEW
BAKER, PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE, AND I WANT TO CLARIFY, I
AM ONLY SPEAKING FOR PCL TODAY,
NOT FOR THE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAD SIGNED ON TO THE
OPPOSITION LETTER THAT WE
ORIGINALLY SENT. WE WERE
ORIGINALLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL,
AND OUR FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED
THE IDEA OF REMOVING SECRET
REVIEW FROM A Ã THE ACTION OF
INCREASING ACCESS TO, TO OPEN
LANDS. I MEAN, WE THINK THAT IT
COULD LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT, VERY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS, AND IT
WARRANTS REVIEW, BUT SINCE WE
THE TIME THAT WE SENT THAT
LETTER, WE, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
WE'VE MET WITH THE SPONSORS, WE
GOT TO UNDERSTAND THE PARTICULAR
PREDICAMENT THAT THEY WERE IN,
AND REALIZED IT WAS SINCERE AND
ALSO GOT TO REALIZE, YOU KNOW,
HAD HAD A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE KIND OF PLANNING,
MANAGEMENT PLANNING AND
RESOURCES THEY HAD IN PLACE, TO
BE ABLE TO, TO HANDLE THIS
EXEMPTION RESPONSIBLY, WITH THIS
INCREASED ACCESS. AND WE REALLY
WORKED WE WITH OUR PARTNERS ON
THE LETTER, WE REALLY WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
COME UP WITH AN ALTERNATIVE THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR ENTITIES THAT DO
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE MANAGEMENT
PLANNING AND RESOURCES IN PLACE
TO DO THIS RESPONSIBLY, TO ALLOW
THEM TO DO IT, AND TO LIMIT THE
BILL TO THAT SCOPE AND THAT
SPIRIT OF THAT. YOU KNOW, WE
TALKED WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE, AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS AND THE
THOUGHTFULNESS THAT THEY HAVE
BROUGHT TO THIS ISSUE. AND WE,
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND WE
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO TAKE
THOSE AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THAT
COMMITMENT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT
IN FULL SUPPORT YET. THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT WE CONTINUE ON
TO TRY TO TALK ABOUT AND CLARIFY
, BUT WITH THE COMMITMENT FOR
THE COMMITMENT TO THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY, WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. AND, HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION. SO
THANK YOU. GREAT. NO, I
APPRECIATE IT, THIS IS THIS IS A
ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION OR CONCERN? YEAH.
THIS WAS A KIND OF A TRICKY ONE
FOR OUR COMMITTEE BECAUSE I, YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, THE END OF THE
DAY, YOU KNOW, THIS IS ABOUT,
OPENING UP TRAILS AND USE OF
EXISTING TRAILS AND THE PARKS
FOLKS WHO ARE WHOSE AGENDA WE
VERY MUCH SHARE, WHICH IS
WANTING TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS FOR FOLKS, SO, ANYWAY,
YOU KNOW, WE TRY TO TAKE A
MIDDLE GROUND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND, YOU KNOW, WE
NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THE, OF
THE EXEMPTION TO, TO APPLY TO
FIVE INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. AND, WE HAD LANGUAGE
ABOUT TRIBAL RESOURCES AND OTHER
PHYSICAL IMPACTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND IT HAS THE
CHANGE HAS TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REGIONAL PLAN. ANYHOW,
AND I KNOW ALSO THERE WAS A
NOTICE IN, NOTICE AND HEARING
REQUIREMENT AS WELL FOR THE
EXEMPTION. SO BUT I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK. IT'S
GOING TO GO OVER NOW TO, I KNOW
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS HERE
EARLIER AND HE HAD TO LEAVE. SO,
BUT I ASK YOU TO PLEASE,
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND LET'S SEE IF WE
CAN GET CLOSER TO CONSENSUS AS
THE BILL GOES. GOES ALONG. I
WANT TO REEMPHASIZE, I REALLY
THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE A
GREAT IMPROVEMENT, AND WE ARE
REALLY HAPPY TO KEEP ON TALKING.
SO GREAT. GREAT, WONDERFUL.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, LET'S, MOVE BY
SENATOR DARLEY, LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. AB 2091. DO PASS. TWO.
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
DARLEY I, DARLEY I, GONZALEZ
HURTADO, MENGIBAR NGUYEN SKINNER
. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE
SOME HAPPY NEWS HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2515. WELL I WAS GOING TO
START WITH GOOD MORNING BUT I'LL
MAKE IT. GOOD AFTERNOON I KNOW.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE, FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A BILL THAT IS A
PERSONAL IMPORTANCE TO ME. AB
2515, THE TAMPON ACT, WHICH
STANDS FOR TAKE ALL MENSTRUAL
PRODUCT, FAS OUT NOW TAMPON.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
IMMEDIATE REMOVAL OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS FROM
THE MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS, FROM
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS, AND SET A
THRESHOLD OF TEN PARTS PER
MILLION FOR UNINTENTIONALLY
ADDED PFAS STARTING IN 2027. SO
WE'VE GOT A PHASE IN FOR THE
UNINTENTIONAL. WE'VE SEEN
MULTIPLE BILLS COME THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE RECENTLY, AND I KNOW
TODAY AS WELL, THAT ADDRESS PFAS
IN VARIOUS PRODUCTS AND FOR GOOD
REASON. THESE FOREVER CHEMICALS
ARE UBIQUITOUS AND CAUSE SEVERE
HEALTH PROBLEMS, INCLUDING
HORMONE AND IMMUNE SYSTEM
DISRUPTION, KIDNEY AND LIVER
DAMAGE, AND, OF COURSE, CANCER.
HOWEVER I'M HERE TO MAKE THE
CASE THAT MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS ARE
DIFFERENT. THESE PRODUCTS ARE
USED IN THE MOST INTIMATE WAY
POSSIBLE, IN AN AREA OF THE BODY
THAT IS DELICATE AND HIGHLY
VASCULAR. BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THESE PRODUCTS, ANY HUMAN
THAT HAS A UTERUS AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT'S NOT THE TWO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESENT, BUT
ANY ANY HUMAN THAT HAS A UTERUS
MUST USE THESE PRODUCTS FOR 3 TO
7 DAYS OUT OF EVERY MONTH FOR
ROUGHLY 40 YEARS OF THEIR LIFE.
IMAGINE THE DAMAGE THAT CAN BE
DONE FROM SUCH INTIMATE AND
REPEATED EXPOSURE. AB 2515 IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF A SIMILAR BILL
I CARRIED LAST YEAR, AB 246,
WHICH MADE IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK BUT WAS VETOED, AND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MESSAGE HE ASKED THAT
WE WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL DTSC, SO
THAT THE BILL HAD A DEFINED
REGULATORY AGENCY AND WE'RE
DOING JUST THAT. I'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS, AND
WE'VE BEEN HAVING GOOD
CONVERSATIONS AND I REMAIN
HOPEFUL THERE'S A PATH FORWARD.
FINALLY, MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF ON ALL POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ARE FIRST WE HAVE NANCY
BURGMEIER, AND SHE IS DIRECTOR
OF PROGRAM AND POLICY WITH
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS. AND THEN AFTER THAT,
WE'LL HAVE MELISSA ROMERO WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT VOTERS.
GREAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. AND
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BABIN, FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
2515, WHICH WOULD ELIMINATE
TOXIC FOREVER CHEMICALS, IN THE
MOST INTIMATE OF PRODUCTS.
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IS A SCIENCE BASED
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO PREVENT
BREAST CANCER BY ELIMINATING
EXPOSURE TO CHEMICALS LINKED TO
THE DISEASE. PER AND
POLYFLUOROALKYL SUBSTANCES, OR
PFAS, ARE A LARGE CLASS OF
HIGHLY PERSISTENT CHEMICALS THAT
BUILD UP IN OUR BODIES. THEY ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH CANCERS,
INCLUDING BREAST CANCER,
REPRODUCTIVE HARM, INTERFERENCE
WITH VACCINES, CHILDHOOD
OBESITY, AND OTHER HARMS TO
HUMAN HEALTH. ACCORDING TO THE
CDC, 97% OF US HAVE PFAS IN OUR
BLOOD, AND THESE CHEMICALS ARE
ALSO FOUND IN PLACENTA, MATERNAL
CORD BLOOD AND BREAST MILK.
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE TO PFAS. INDUSTRY HAS
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE TEN
PARTS PER MILLION THRESHOLD IN
THE BILL, CITING THE UBIQUITOUS
NATURE OF PFAS IN OUR PRODUCTS
AND THE ENVIRONMENT. TODAY
HOWEVER, INDUSTRY HAS KNOWN
SINCE THE 1970S HOW HIGHLY TOXIC
THESE CHEMICALS ARE. YET DESPITE
THAT KNOWLEDGE HAS PROLIFERATED,
THE USE OF PFAS TO LITERALLY
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
PRODUCTS. SO YES, NOW
CONTAMINATION IS A HUGE PROBLEM,
BUT IT'S ONE THAT INDUSTRY HAS
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS
THROUGHOUT THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN.
THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT IS OUR
BODIES DON'T KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN INTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS
AND PFAS CONTAMINATION. ANY
DETECTABLE LEVEL OF PFAS ARE OF
CONCERN BECAUSE PFAS IS EASILY
ABSORBED THROUGH THE MUCOUS
MEMBRANES, THAT THESE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS ARE EXPOSED TO. YOU
HAVE HEARD OVER AND OVER HOW
EXTREMELY TOXIC THESE THESE
CHEMICALS ARE AT EXTRAORDINARILY
LOW LEVELS, LEVELS BELOW PARTS
PER TRILLION ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE
LOWER THAN THE TEN PARTS PER
MILLION THRESHOLD IN THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA IS FALLING BEHIND ON
THIS ISSUE. OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY ACTED TO BAN PFAS FROM
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS FOR THE
HEALTH OF US ALL. UTERUSES ARE
NOT. IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
FINISH THE JOB THIS YEAR BY
PASSING AB 2515. I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA
ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2515. I WANT TO
SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS AS TO WHY
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
, SO THE PRESENCE OF PFAS IN
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING DUE TO
THEIR DIRECT PATHWAY TO THE
HUMAN BODY, BUT ALSO SUBSEQUENT
DISPOSAL INTO OUR WASTE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS. SO WHEN
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS CONTAINING
PFAS ARE DISCARDED, THEY
EVENTUALLY MAKE THEIR WAY INTO
LANDFILLS, INTO WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANTS. AND THIS IS
WHERE THE PROBLEM GETS WORSE.
PFAS LEACH INTO SOIL, INTO
GROUNDWATER, AND LAND FROM
LANDFILLS CONTAMINATE DRINKING
WATER, GIVEN THE STABILITY OF
THESE CHEMICALS, THE PFAS CAN
PERSIST IN THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
MANY YEARS, AND IT POSES A LONG
TERM HEALTH RISK FOR COMMUNITIES
AND PARTICULARLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY WE CONVENTIONAL
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PROCESSES
ARE ACTUALLY NOT DESIGNED TO
REMOVE PFAS, AND AS A RESULT,
THESE CHEMICALS ARE PASSING
THROUGH THESE TREATMENT PLANTS
AND ARE DISCHARGED INTO RIVERS,
LAKES, OCEANS. SO THIS NOT ONLY
AFFECTS AQUATIC WILDLIFE, BUT IT
ALSO REENTERS THE HUMAN BODY
THROUGH CONTAMINATED WATER AND
FISH, CAUSING THE CHEMICALS TO
FURTHER BUILD UP IN OUR BODIES.
DELICIOUS, THE REMOVAL OF PFAS
IS A HUGE CHALLENGE, SO THE
CURRENT TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE
FOR PFAS REMEDIATION ARE REALLY
COSTLY. VERY ENERGY INTENSIVE
AND NOT ALWAYS EFFECTIVE. SO
GIVEN THOSE CHALLENGES, IT IS
SUPER IMPORTANT THAT WE PREVENT
PFAS FROM ENTERING THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AS A FAR MORE PRACTICAL AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY THAN RATHER THAN
CLEANING THEM UP AFTERWARDS. SO
BY PASSING THIS BILL, AB 2515,
WE CAN SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF PFAS INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS WHICH ARE USED BY
MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS MONTHLY,
DO NOT CONTRIBUTE TO THE PFAS
POLLUTION PROBLEM. SO WITH THAT,
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
. GOOD AFTERNOON, DE QUINTANA
HERE FOR THE IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. SARAH BOUDREAU WITH
THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE IN SUPPORT
. GOOD AFTERNOON, AARON TAYLOR
WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS, AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ETHAN NAGLER I'M
HALF THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA AND
SUPPORT TAYLOR BENSON,
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR WOMEN'S
VOICES FOR THE EARTH, CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
SANITATION AGENCIES. THANK YOU.
JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ARIANA CREED WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS. ORG IN SUPPORT. ALSO
THOSE IN SUPPORT OR NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE AND CA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEACE ACTIVIST
SAN DIEGO FAX, CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE SONOMA SAS BEYOND
PESTICIDE YARD SMART MARIN MOMS
ADVOCATING FOR SUSTAINABILITY,
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND GRANDPARENTS ACTING
TOGETHER. THANK YOU. IT WAS ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS. YES. OH
COOL. ALL RIGHT. SO NOTHING GETS
AWESOME, OKAY, LET'S CALL UP THE
OPPOSITION. THE OPPOSITION. COME
ON. DON ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, DON
KOBQ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. CMTA
FINDS ITSELF IN REGRETTABLE,
OPPOSITION TO AB 2515, TO BE
VERY CLEAR, RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATE, OUR MANUFACTURERS DO NOT
INTENTIONALLY ADD PFAS CHEMICALS
TO THESE PRODUCTS FOR ANY
PURPOSE WHATSOEVER. IF THERE ARE
ANY PFAS ELEMENTS WITHIN THESE
PRODUCTS, IT'S A RESULT OF TRACE
CONTAMINATION THAT MANUFACTURERS
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO CONTROL FOR,
AND THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS THE
BASIS FOR OUR OPPOSITION TODAY,
IT SHOULD BE NOTED, WE HAVE
CONTINUED AS THE AUTHOR HAS
SUGGESTED, TO TRY TO WORK
THROUGH THE CONCERNS, WE
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
TEN PARTS PER MILLION THRESHOLD
WITHIN THE BILL FOR
UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE AUTHOR, AND FOR
THAT REASON, ALTHOUGH IT
CERTAINLY GIVES OUR MEMBERS A
SIGNIFICANT HEARTBURN, WE HAVE
NOT CONTINUED TO ADVOCATE FOR
CHANGING THAT, RATHER REALLY
JUST FOCUSING ON TRYING TO
RIGHTSIZE THE ENFORCEMENT
PENALTIES AND LIABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT ANY
ELEMENTS OF PFAS WITHIN THESE
PRODUCTS IS TRACE CONTAMINATION,
THAT, IN VIRTUALLY ALL CASES, IS
UNAVOIDABLE. ALL THAT SAID,
WE'VE CONTINUED TO TRY TO WORK
TOGETHER. WE'VE PROVIDED OVER 20
DIFFERENT SETS OF AMENDMENTS AND
CONCEPTS TO TRY TO MITIGATE
THOSE CONCERNS IN GOOD FAITH, IT
IS NOT TAKEN LIGHTLY BY CMTA OR
ITS MEMBERS TO BE IN THIS,
REGRETTABLE POSITION OF
OPPOSITION, BUT NEVERTHELESS, WE
DO FIND OURSELVES STRUGGLING TO
FIND COMMON GROUND ON SOME OF
THESE ENFORCEMENT LIABILITY
PROVISIONS. NOW, CERTAINLY, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE PARTICULAR
CONCERNS ARE NOT NECESSARILY
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WE DO FEEL IT REALLY
IMPERATIVE JUST TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT WE DO NOT AGREE OR DO NOT
DISAGREE WITH THE INTENT OF THE
BILL. WE DO NOT HAVE
MANUFACTURERS ADDING THESE
CHEMICALS. THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
RIGHTSIZING THE ENFORCEMENT
LIABILITY PENALTIES WHEN IT
COMES TO POTENTIALLY UNAVOIDABLE
TRACE CONTAMINANTS. SO I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING AND TRYING TO GET THERE
WITH THIS AUTHOR. IT IS OUR
PREFERENCE TO DO SO AND WE WILL
CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE HER
WILLINGNESS TO DO SO AS WELL. SO
WITH THAT, REGRETTABLE
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF CMTA,
BUT AGAIN, HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT ENFORCEMENT
CONVERSATION IS HAPPENING WITH
JUDICIARY. YES, WE ARE INDEED IN
CONVERSATION WITH JUDICIARY.
YES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS LAUREN
AGUILAR. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
BHP, WHICH IS THE CENTER FOR
BABY AND ADULT HYGIENE PRODUCTS.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE. WE ARE A TRADE ASSOCIATION
THAT REPRESENTS ALL ABSORBENT
HYGIENE PRODUCTS, BABY DIAPERS,
ADULT INCONTINENCE PRODUCTS, AS
WELL AS MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. OUR
MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT 85% OF
THE MARKET FOR PERSONAL
ABSORBENT HYGIENE PRODUCTS IN
NORTH AMERICA, AND PROVIDE ABOUT
10,000 DIRECT JOBS IN THE UNITED
STATES. UNFORTUNATELY, TODAY,
WE'RE ALSO TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2515. WE FULLY
AGREE WITH AND SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL, AS OUR OUR
MEMBERS DO NOT INTENTIONALLY ADD
PFAS TO THEIR MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS, OUR CONCERNS WERE WITH
THE LANGUAGE RECOVERED REALLY
WELL BY DAWN, AND MOST WILL FALL
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHERE THIS
BILL IS HEADED TO NEXT, BUT IN
TERMS OF EC ISSUES, THERE WAS
ONE MORE ISSUE THAT I JUST
WANTED TO ADDRESS QUICKLY AND BE
ON THE RECORD FOR WAS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THIS BILL
AND AB 347 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHING, WHICH WAS OBVIOUSLY HEARD
EARLIER TODAY, AND AB 1817
WITHIN AB 347 COVERS TEXTILE AND
APPAREL AND REUSABLE BEALL
MENSTRUAL UNDERGARMENTS ARE
TECHNICALLY UNDER 1817, AS WELL
AS 2515. SO JUST SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE HOPING TO GET CLARIFIED AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD AND LIKE,
LIKE DAWN SAID, WE REALLY DO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUED DIALOG. LOTS AND LOTS
OF CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL.
AND MORE AND MORE TO COME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, YEAH.
RANDY RANDY POLLOCK, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL, IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASON STATED. THANK YOU. OKAY,
GREAT. DISCUSSION, I KNOW, YEAH.
SENATOR DARLING. WELL, I'LL JUST
SAY I WANT TO VOTE FOR THIS SO
BAD, AND YOU'RE. I LAID OFF OF
IT LAST. I LAID OFF THE BILL
LAST YEAR, AND I BEGAN. THIS IS,
LIKE, THE RIGHT THING TO DO. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, HOW CLOSE ARE
YOU? I MEAN, THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOME COMMON GROUND HERE. I KNOW
THAT PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IS
IN THIS BILL WASN'T IN THE LAST
BILL, SO I DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE AT IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS,
BUT I REALLY WANT TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL. BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT
TO PUT, AS I STATED, UNDER THE
TÍNH BILL EARLIER, I DON'T WANT
SOMEBODY WHO'S TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING, WHO'S NOT ADDING
THE PFAS TO THEIR PRODUCTS, GET
STUCK FOR SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T
INTENTIONALLY DO. THEY'RE JUST
USING THE WATER OR WHATEVER TO
MANUFACTURE, AND IT GETS IN THE
PRODUCT. SO THAT'S WHERE I'M AT.
I JUST THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
WAY WE CAN FIGURE THIS OUT THAT
WE GET TO A HAPPY PLACE FOR
EVERYBODY. SO THAT'S WHAT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THIS SHOULD BE DONE. AND I THINK
BOTH SIDES SEE THAT. BUT BUT
THERE IS ALSO LIABILITY AND
LIABILITY IS A HUGE PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA FOR, FOR
MANUFACTURING AND FOR BUSINESS.
SO WHERE ARE WE HEADED? SO I
THINK ON THE ENFORCEMENT PART,
WE HAVE SOME VERY GOOD
DISCUSSIONS GOING TO WORK OUT
WHETHER THERE SHOULD BE A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION OR NOT,
AND HOW DO WE REPLACE IT AND HOW
DO WE WORK WITH THE DTSC. SO
THAT THEY, AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
AGENCY, CAN ENFORCE? AND ONE OF
THE GOOD THINGS ABOUT THIS BILL
THAT WASN'T IN THE LAST BILL
DEALS WITH THE SCOPE OF THE
ENFORCEMENT. AND WE'VE LEFT IT
TO DC DTSC TO DO A, YOU KNOW, A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF SAMPLING.
SO THAT THEY CAN DETERMINE IF WE
HAVE OVER TEN PARTS PER MILLION,
HOW EXTENSIVE IS IT? AND THEN
FROM THERE THEY HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT PROCEDURE THAT THEY
CAN ENFORCE. SO THAT ANSWERS THE
FIRST QUESTION. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AFTER
TODAY. THINGS GO WELL, AS IT
RELATES TO THE INTENTIONAL AND
THE UNINTENTIONAL TOTALLY HEAR
YOU, WHICH IS WHY WE DID A TWO
YEAR PHASE IN ON THE
UNINTENTIONAL SO THAT THERE IS
SOME ABILITY TO KIND OF GET INTO
IT AND LET'S FIGURE OUT, IS
THERE SOME PLACE WHERE THINGS
MIGHT BE COMING THAT WE MIGHT
ACTUALLY HAVE CONTROL OVER? SO
THAT'S WHY I THOUGHT IT WAS ONLY
REASONABLE TO GIVE SOME RUNWAY
INTO WHEN THE UNINTENTIONAL WILL
BE ENFORCED. SO THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE BACK TO THAT. AND LET ME
JUST UNINTENTIONAL IS
UNINTENTIONAL. IF YOU THE WATER
AGENCIES ARE HERE SUPPORTING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A PROBLEM,
THEY HAVE PFAS IN THEIR WATER
AND WE'RE ALL CONSUMING IT.
OKAY. SO THAT'S UNINTENTIONAL.
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO HARM US.
BUT IT'S HAPPENING. AND WE HAVE
THIS IS A HUGE SUBJECT. AND I
YOU KNOW A COUPLE MONTHS I WON'T
BE HERE ANYMORE. AND I ASKED FOR
A HEARING TO TALK ABOUT PITFALLS
BECAUSE IT IS SO START OUT WITH
THE FIREFIGHTERS AND I'VE
SUPPORTED ALL THOSE BILLS. AND
HERE WE ARE NOW TALKING ABOUT
PFAS IS IN A LOT OF THINGS. IT'S
IN POPCORN BAG, MICROWAVE
POPCORN. I'M NOT EATING IT
ANYMORE. I USED TO EAT IT. NOW I
DON'T EAT IT BECAUSE IT'S IN
THAT BAG AND IT'S EVERYWHERE AND
IT'S IN OUR WATER SYSTEM. AND SO
TO HOLD SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE,
THAT'S THE POWER TO HOLD
SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE. I DON'T
CARE IF YOU GIVE THEM A RUNWAY.
THERE'S A CLIFF AT THE END OF IT
THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT. SO
IT WON'T CHANGE THE INTIMACY OF
THIS USE. AND THAT HALF THE
POPULATION HAS TO USE IT FOR 40
YEARS, SEVEN DAYS A WEEK, I GET
IT. SO AT SOME POINT YOU MAY NOT
BE HAPPY WITH THE UNINTENTIONAL,
BUT IN THIS USE YOU GOT TO BE
LIABLE AT SOME POINT. AND SO
THAT'S WHY I SAY YOU GOT TO LOOK
AT THIS BILL MUCH DIFFERENTLY
THAN ANY OTHER PFAS BILL,
BECAUSE IN THE BEGINNING, I WANT
TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL. AND I
WELCOME YOUR VOTE, MR. CHAIR.
MAYBE THEY JUST WON'T MAKE THE
PRODUCTS ANYMORE BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH LIABILITY. THAT'S THE
POINT, MAYOR. THANK YOU. THROUGH
THE CHAIR, SO IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTION, SO WE HAVE BEEN GOING
BACK AND FORTH, CERTAINLY ON
AMENDMENTS, A VARIETY OF THEM
OVER 20, TO TRY AND GET THERE ON
THIS. I THINK, AGAIN, IT COMES
DOWN TO WHAT IS AVOIDABLE, AND
NOT EVEN IN THE ANALYSIS BASED
ON SOME TESTING DONE. I THINK IT
WAS BY MOM AVIATION AND REPORTED
IN ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH NEWS.
THEY FOUND CONCENTRATIONS THAT
ARE ABOVE TEN PARTS PER MILLION
FOR THESE PRODUCTS. NOW, PERHAPS
THERE ARE COMPANIES THAT ARE NOT
CMTA MEMBERS THAT ARE ADDING
THAT. BUT I CAN TELL YOU FOR
CMTA MEMBERS, THEY DO NOT ADD
THESE CHEMICALS. AND SO EVEN IN
THIS PARTICULAR ANALYSIS THAT
CITES TO THEIR TESTING DATA, IT
IS ABOVE TEN PARTS PER MILLION.
SO EVEN THOUGH YOU KNOW, OUR
MANUFACTURERS WILL COMMIT TO
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
WIPE DOWN THEIR LINES, TO DO
BETTER SOURCING OF THE RAW
MATERIALS, WHAT HAVE YOU, THERE
MAY BE A SCENARIO SO WHERE WE
CAN'T AVOID 11 PPM, AND YET THAT
PUTS US IN A POSITION OF
LIABILITY SUBJECT TO
ENFORCEMENT, EVEN THOUGH IT'S
UNAVOIDABLE. WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING AND DUE DILIGENCE. SO
I THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
ISSUE COMES DOWN TO. IF IT WAS
OUR PREFERENCE, I MEAN, THESE
THIS WOULDN'T BE AN ISSUE,
RIGHT, BUT THERE ARE SERIOUS
CHALLENGES TO THAT. AND SO EVEN
AS PART OF SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE GONE BACK
AND FORTH ON, CERTAINLY WE'RE
OPEN TO ENFORCEMENT REVIEW BY
DTSC SAMPLING OF THE PRODUCTS
ACROSS THE MARKET. CERTAINLY,
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
PRODUCTIVE ON THAT. I THINK THE
ISSUE DOES COME DOWN TO, THOUGH,
IF IT IS UNAVOIDABLE TO HOLD US
LIABLE AND POTENTIALLY REQUIRE
THAT THESE PRODUCTS CAN'T BE PUT
INTO THE MARKET AND SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA IF THEY'RE IN
VIOLATION, EVEN IF IT'S
UNAVOIDABLE AT 11 P.M, IT WILL
INEVITABLY AFFECT THE
AVAILABILITY OF THESE PRODUCTS,
MUCH LESS JUST THE LIABILITY
THAT THE MANUFACTURE OWNERS WILL
INCUR. SO WAS THE TESTING THAT
WAS DONE? WAS THAT ON A
DIFFERENT BRANDS AND WAS ONE
BRAND HIGHER THAN THE OTHER? MY
APOLOGIES, SENATOR VICE CHAIR, I
DO NOT HAVE THE DATA. I'M JUST
REFERRING TO WHAT WAS CITED
WITHIN THE ANALYSIS, FROM A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDED SOME TESTING DATA THAT
WAS REPORTED IN THE MEDIA. I
DON'T HAVE THAT. WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK INTO IT AND
FOLLOW UP, BUT THESE NUMBERS
CERTAINLY ARE ABOVE THE
THRESHOLD WITHIN THIS BILL. AND
FOR CMTA MEMBERS WHOSE PRODUCTS
MAY HAVE BEEN INCLUDED AS PART
OF THIS, NOT INTENTIONALLY ADDED
. OKAY, I SOME ADDITIONAL WORK
TO BE DONE ON ON NEGOTIATION. I
KNOW, I KNOW, SOME OF IT'S
ALREADY VERY MUCH UNDERWAY, BUT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS
FROM THE MEMBERS MOTION FROM
SENATOR VENTURA? OKAY, WILL,
WILL, WILL WE'LL CALL THE ROLL.
WE'LL GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLOSE. I'M SORRY. JUST THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY HERE,
AND I AND I APPRECIATE THE
DISCOURSE, AND I AND I, I WILL
REPRESENT TO YOU THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT MEANS OF
ENFORCEMENT, THAT THAT DOES MAKE
IT SUCH THAT IT IS COMMENSURATE
WITH THE SCOPE OF A, OF A
VIOLATION. SO WE'RE WORKING VERY
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT, THAT WE
HAVE SOME, SOME SIMPATICO
BETWEEN WHAT MIGHT BE
UNINTENTIONAL BEALL AND HOW DOES
IT GET ENFORCED BY THE DTSC. SO
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE, AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE LIVELY EXCHANGE.
GREAT. ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL AB 2515. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. SENATORS ALLEN I
ALLEN. I DALLY NOT VOTING.
GONZALEZ. HURTADO MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I NGUYEN SKINNER OKAY,
SO LEAVE THE ROLL UP IN FOR
FOLKS DOWN. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. I SEE JUAN CARRILLO HERE.
HE'S BEEN VERY PATIENT, LEARNING
ABOUT MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. COME
ON UP. GET ANY BETTER PEOPLE?
VERY DIFFERENT SUBJECT. THIS
ONE, AB 3179. YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I
HAVE TO SAY THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I'M IN THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM. AND IT'S A BEAUTIFUL ROOM
THAT BEHIND YOU. IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
YEAH. ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 3179, BUT BEFORE I BEGIN, I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I AM
COMMITTED TO TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS DESCRIBING THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I KNOW WE'RE
STILL WORKING OUT THE SPECIFIC
WORDING WITH STAFF TO MAKE SURE
WE ACCOMPLISH THAT OUTCOME, AND
I UNDERSTAND THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE ADOPTED IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE SHOULD IT PASS TODAY.
SO I'M COMMITTED TO DO THAT,
AGAIN, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND
YOUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY STAFF ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AB
3179 IS A NECESSARY MEASURE THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR A NARROW
EXEMPTION SPECIFICALLY FOR
BUDGET BUCKET TRUCKS. EXCUSE ME.
BUCKET TRUCKS AND CELL ON WHEELS
TO THE CARB ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET
REGULATIONS. AS BUCKET TRUCKS
PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN PERFORMING
AERIAL MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS
ON TELECOMMUNICATION LINES AND
SHERM CONNECTIVITY FOR EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SIMILARLY, CELL ON
WHEELS ARE DEPLOYED TO RESTORE
CELLULAR COVERAGE SWIFTLY IN
TEMPORARY LOCATIONS DURING
EMERGENCIES OR OUTAGES, ENSURING
THAT ESSENTIAL COMMUNICATION
CHANNELS REMAIN OPERATIONAL FOR
EMERGENCY CALLS AND SERVICES.
WITHOUT THESE SPECIALIZED
VEHICLES, TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS WOULD FACE SIGNIFICANT
DELAYS IN RESTORING SERVICES
DURING EMERGENCIES, POTENTIALLY
ENDANGERING LIVES AND
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY.
THERE ARE NO MANUFACTURERS THAT
PROVIDE RELIABLE BUCKET TRUCKS
OR CELL ON WHEELS VEHICLES THAT
MEET THE CURRENT ACF REGULATION.
THESE VEHICLES FACE CHALLENGES
IN ADOPTING ZERO EMISSION
ELECTRIC VEHICLES DUE TO THEIR
HEAVY DUTY NATURE REQUIRING HIGH
POWER AND LONG RANGE
CAPABILITIES. ADDITIONALLY RAPID
DEPLOYMENT NEEDS, ENSURING THE
NEEDS DURING EMERGENCY IS OFTEN
AREAS WITH LIMITED OR COMMERCIAL
POWER FURTHER COMPLICATES THE
FEASIBILITY OF ELECTRIC OPTIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD HAS RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANT ROLE EMERGENCY
VEHICLES PLAY IN TIMES OF
CRISIS, AND EXEMPTING THEM FROM
THEIR ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET
REGULATION. UNFORTUNATELY TÊ
EXISTING EXEMPTIONS AND OFF
RAMPS ARE NOT VIABLE OPTIONS FOR
PRIVATELY OWNED
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS AS
THEY ONLY APPLY TO PUBLICLY
OWNED VEHICLES. WITH THE
UNPREDICTABILITY OF NATURAL
DISASTERS, WE MUST REMAIN
PREPARED AND READY TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
PROVIDED WITH RELIABLE
CONNECTIONS TO ENSURE SERVICES
IN CASES OF SEVERE WEATHER,
WILDFIRES OR FLOODS. JOINING ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
AMANDA VALDERRAMA WITH CARL
BRANDT AND TERRY MAHLE WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. AMANDA
CALDERON WITH CAL BROADBAND
PROUD SPONSORS OF AB 3179. I
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
HIS STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS TO
ENSURE THE LANGUAGE REFLECTS THE
INTENT. AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STATED, THIS BILL WILL ALLOW FOR
VERY NARROW EXEMPTION TO THE
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET REGULATIONS
FOR BUCKET TRUCKS AND CELL ON
WHEELS TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS ARE ENTRUSTED WITH
MAINTAINING THE NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE. CRUCIAL FOR
FACILITATING 911 AND EMERGENCY
ALERT COMMUNICATIONS. THIS
INCLUDES PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL AS THE NECESSARY
SOFTWARE AND PROTOCOLS TO DIRECT
EMERGENCY CALLS TO THE
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT OR EMERGENCY
DISPATCH CENTER. THEY MUST ALSO
COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO 911 SERVICES. THIS INCLUDES
ENSURING THE ABILITY FOR USERS
TO REACH EMERGENCY SERVICES BY
DIALING 911, ENSURING THAT
EMERGENCY DISPATCHERS
AUTOMATICALLY RECEIVE THE
CALLER'S LOCATION INFORMATION.
NOTIFYING 911 CALL CENTERS OF
OUTAGES, AND CERTIFYING THE
RELIABILITY THAT RELIABILITY
MEASURES ARE TAKEN AS STATED,
BUCKET TRUCKS AND CELL ON WHEELS
ARE SPECIALIZED VEHICLES THAT
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
UTILIZE WHEN PERFORMING
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS TO THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LINES, OR
UTILIZE TO TEMPORARILY RESTORE
CELL SERVICE SWIFTLY DURING
EMERGENCIES OR OUTAGES. THE
TRANSITION TO FULLY ELECTRIC
SOLUTIONS REMAINS IMPRACTICAL
FOR THESE TWO TYPES OF VEHICLES,
MAKING THESE EXEMPTIONS CRITICAL
FOR MAINTAINING THE RELIABILITY
AND AVAILABILITY OF EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEREFORE IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
PASS THIS BILL TO ENSURE THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS CAN
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES AND RESTORE CRITICAL
SERVICES PROMPTLY. I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIRMAN, TERRY MCHALE WITH
AARON REED AND ASSOCIATES, THANK
YOU FOR THE HOSPITALITY. AND
IT'S NOT MY FIRST TIME IN THIS
ROOM. I FEEL LIKE I'M GETTING
OLD ENOUGH. I REMEMBER WHEN THAT
WAS PAINTED ALMOST. HAHA, WE'RE
VERY PROUD. CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL IS VERY PROUD TO BE A
CO-SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY SPECIFIC
VEHICLES. WE'VE ALL SEEN TRUCKS,
BUT I'LL BET NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
HAS BEEN IN A BUCKET TRUCK.
WE'VE ALL SEEN COWS, BUT I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US HAVE SEEN CELLS
ON WHEELS. THESE ARE VERY
SPECIFIC VEHICLES USED FOR VERY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS. THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL IS
VERY PROUD OF THE FACT THAT IT
IS. IT TAKES A WHOLE CREW OF
PEOPLE, NOT JUST PUBLIC SAFETY,
TO RESPOND DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES. YESTERDAY, THREE
STRIKE CREWS WERE SENT OUT TO
FIGHT FIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE EARLIEST THAT
THREE STRIKE CREWS HAVE BEEN
SENT OUT IN RECENT MEMORY. AND
THAT INCLUDES THE NIGHTMARISH
YEARS OF SIX AND SEVEN YEARS
AGO. WHEN THEY GO OUT, THEY MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNICATION PART
OF THAT EQUATION IS TAKEN CARE
OF. AND IT TAKES THE BRAVE MEN
AND WOMEN, YOU KNOW, WHO WORK IN
BROADBAND, WHO ARE THERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT COMMUNICATION IS
TAKEN CARE OF. I'LL CLOSE BY
JUST READING WHAT ONE OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS WROTE, HE SAID. NOT
ONLY DO FIREFIGHTERS RELY ON
ELECTRIC POWER, INTERNET AND
CELLULAR CONNECTIVITY TO RESPOND
AND TO SAFELY MITIGATE
WILDFIRES, BUT THE PUBLIC ALSO
SUFFERS PROFOUNDLY WHEN THESE
SYSTEMS FAIL THESE THIS IS A
GOOD BILL. WE ALSO AGREE THAT
THE SUNSET GIVES TIME TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE RESOLVED
AND THE TECHNOLOGY WILL CATCH UP
WITH IT. AND SO WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. THE FOLKS WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YOLANDA BENSON WITH
US TELECOM. THE BROADBAND
ASSOCIATION ALSO CO-SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL. AND OBVIOUSLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE. PAM LOOMIS, ON
BEHALF OF THE SMALL RURAL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES THAT
COMPRISE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT JOHN MOFFATT ON BEHALF
OF COMCAST, NBC UNIVERSAL IN
SUPPORT. STEVE CARLSON FOR CTIA,
WHERE THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE WIRELESS TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT. DAMON
CONKLIN, ON BEHALF OF CAL CITIES
, AS WELL AS CSAC, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY
OPPOSITION FOLKS WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL? OKAY.
MR. VICE CHAIR, THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL. COMMON SENSE. BILL,
I'D MOVE IT. OKAY. BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED. ANY QUESTIONS? COMMENTS?
I WILL LET YOU CLOSE IN A BUCKET
TRUCK TO. I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AB 3179. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATORS ALLEN Ã ALLEN. I DALLY
A DALLY I GONZALES HURTADO
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NGUYEN
NGUYEN I SKINNER. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL UP
AND I WILL GET MY GLASSES CLOTH
BACK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YOU'RE LOOKING GOOD. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S NOW, I, SENATOR
DALLY, WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ITEM
20. THAT'S, SOME MEMBER WOODS AB
2902. WE HEARD THAT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE DAY. IT WASN'T
A QUORUM AT THE TIME. SO HE'S
MOVING THAT. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS ITEM 20, AB 2902
WOULD. AB 2902. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS ALLEN,
I ALLEN I DALLY A VALLEY. I
GONZALES, HURTADO, MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I WIN, I WIN I SKINNER.
OKAY SO THAT'S 420. WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLL OPEN. SO LET'S LIFT
CALLS FOR FOLKS AS WE HAVE.
SENATOR BRIAN'S ON HIS WAY.
OKAY. GREAT. SORRY FOUR, FIVE
AND SIX. OKAY. FIVE AND SIX.
FIVE AND SIX. OKAY. SO SIX WAS
PULLED. SO ITEM SIX, AB 2514 WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR JUST FOR
FOLKS TO KNOW. THAT'S
AGUIAR-CURRY. BUT LET'S, LIFT
THE CALL NUMBER FIVE, ITEM FIVE.
THIS IS, AB 863. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. GONZALEZ
HURTADO NGUYEN NGUYEN NØ.
SKINNER. ALL RIGHT. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER VOTES THAT WE
NEED. FOLKS. FOLKS NEED TO CAST
NUMBER 13. THAT'S GRAYSON, AB
2091, ITEM 13. GRAYSON 2091. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER, THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 0. GONZALEZ HURTADO
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NGUYEN I
NGUYEN I SKINNER. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
THAT. ANY OTHERS THAT WE'RE
WAITING FOR, FOLKS ON? ALL
RIGHT, LET'S TAKE A BRIEF RECESS
WHILE WE WAIT FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ARE RECONVENING THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
TO HEAR OUR VERY LAST ITEM. THIS
IS ITEM 22. IN YOUR PACKET.
THAT'S A B 3265. SO LET'S
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MISTER
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT, AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED,
A B 3265, A BILL THAT WILL BE A
CATALYST FOR SUSTAINED JOB
GROWTH BY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS FOR RENOVATING SOUND
STAGES AND UPDATING PRODUCTION
FACILITIES TO INCORPORATE THE
LATEST GRAPHICS AND AUDIO
TECHNOLOGY. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY TEAM, AND I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A RICH, RICH
HISTORY AS THE ENTERTAINMENT
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. IN RECENT
YEARS, THE LEGISLATURE HAS TRIED
TO REAFFIRM THAT REAFFIRM
CALIFORNIA'S STATUS AS THE
PREFERRED CHOICE FOR FILM AND TV
PRODUCTION WITH LEGISLATION AND
VARIOUS TAX CREDITS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CONSTRUCTION
OF SOUNDSTAGES IN CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT KEPT PACE WITH THE RECENT
GROWTH IN THE PRODUCTION OF
FILM, SCRIPTED TELEVISION AND
STREAMING CONTENT, WHICH IN TURN
FORCES MORE PRODUCTION OUTSIDE
OF THE STATE. AB 3265 WILL HELP
KEEP PRODUCTIONS IN STATE WHILE
MAINTAINING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS. THIS BILL WILL MEET
THE HIGHEST ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS SET BY OTHER
STREAMLINING BILLS, AND ALSO
INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT WILL
ASSURE THE CREATION OF HIGH
ROADS, GOOD PAYING JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE PROJECT THROUGH LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENTS, THESE PROJECTS WILL
GENERATE THOUSANDS OF FULL TIME
JOBS DURING CONSTRUCTION AND
THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT JOBS ONCE THEY ARE
CONSTRUCTED AND OPERATING.
TODAY, WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
KATHLEEN GALGIANI, REP, FOX
STUDIOS. THIS BILL HAS ALSO
MOVED THROUGH TWO COMMITTEES AND
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND EVEN ON
CONSENT AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE PROVING THAT THERE
IS LIFE AFTER THE SENATE. YES.
KATHLEEN GALGIANI THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
ALSO TO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THE AMENDMENTS HERE, WHILE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY LANGUISHES,
THERE IS A GROWING NEED FOR
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND INVESTMENT
. AND THE BILL BEFORE YOU WILL
EXPEDITE THE INVESTMENT OF
NEARLY $2 BILLION WITH THE
EXPANSION OF THE HISTORIC FOX
LOT IN CENTURY CITY, THIS BILL
INCORPORATES THE BEST AND MOST
ADVANCED ENVIRONMENTAL PRACTICES
FROM PRIOR SUCCESSFUL BILLS TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND TO REDUCE TRAFFIC AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. IN ADDITION, FOX IS
PROUD TO PARTNER WITH THE LOCAL
AND STATE BUILDING TRADES
THROUGH THE SIGNING OF A PROJECT
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT. IN
2021. THE LEGISLATURE
ACKNOWLEDGED THE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS AND
NEW SOUND STAGES WITH PASSING
THE SOUND STAGE FILMING TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM, WHICH ALLOCATED
$150 MILLION TO INCENTIVIZE
CONSTRUCTION AND RENOVATION OF
CALIFORNIA SOUND STAGES, AS WELL
AS THE REPURPOSING OF SPACE INTO
SOUND STAGES. AB 3265 WILL
COMPLEMENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
EFFORTS TO PROMOTE CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS BY STREAMLINING THE
SEQUEL PROCESS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP. MEDIA CAMPUS
PROJECTS, WHICH ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
AND GENERATE NEW LIVING WAGE AND
PREVAILING WAGE JOBS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY, LET'S HEAR FROM
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO WEIGH
IN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL,
OPPOSITION WITNESSES OR FOLKS
WHO WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS.
OKAY, WE'LL BRING THAT IN BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, THOUGHTS, SENATOR
MENGIBAR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY, IS THIS
ONLY FOR FOX STUDIOS OR FOR ALL
STUDIOS? ALL STUDIOS IN LA
COUNTY, FOX STUDIOS IS CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING THIS PROJECT IN
CENTURY CITY. I ALSO PERSONALLY
REPRESENT, SONY STUDIOS IN
CULVER CITY, AMAZON AND MGM
STUDIOS IN CULVER CITY. BUT I
KNOW THAT, THIS ENTIRE INDUSTRY
IS BASED IN OUR HOME REGION. AND
SO WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY COULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS WORK. PERFECT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. JUST CLARIFYING, BECAUSE I
ALSO HAVE STUDIOS IN MY
DISTRICT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY. ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR THOUGHTS, MOTION FROM SENATOR
MENGIBAR. WE'LL GIVE YOU
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE, THE FILM
AND TELEVISION SCREENING
INDUSTRY IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA AND LOS
ANGELES GREAT. I'M VERY PROUD TO
BRING THIS MEASURE FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS THRIVING. AND
HERE, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. OKAY. GREAT LET'S CALL
THE ROLL, SORRY, SENATOR.
APOLOGIES, WITNESSES ARE EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO IT.
WE DIDN'T. WELL, I MEAN, WE HAD,
SENATOR GALGIANI HERE FOR IN
SUPPORT. OKAY. FOX. YEAH, I KNOW
THERE'S SOME IN THE PRIMARY.
THAT'S ALL I MEANT. I MEAN,
THERE'S LISTED, YOU KNOW,
JUDICIAL COUNCIL RAISED CONCERNS
LIKE STREAMLINING, AND BUT
THEY'RE NOT HERE, RIGHT? OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT I JUST WANT. YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY, OKAY, LET'S
CALL THE ROLL AB 3265. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SENATORS
ALLEN, I, ALLEN I DALI, GONZALEZ
HURTADO MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
NGUYEN NGUYEN I SKINNER I
SKINNER I. GREAT. THAT'S 4 TO 0.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN. OKAY.
SO WHERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GUYS. WE NEED LENA TO COME ON
DOWN. YEAH. SHE'S COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW. OKAY. THANK FINISHING
UP YESTERDAY. I WAS PULLED BACK,
SO I NEEDED TO MAKE SURE I
DIDN'T MISS ANYTHING. I WENT ALL
THE WAY TO MY OFFICE AND THEY
CALLED ME BACK. I AM GOOD. OH,
THERE'S ONE MORE. NO, YOU GOT
IT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
LIFT SOME CALLS. LET'S LIFT SOME
CALLS. LET'S START RIGHT AT THE
TOP WITH SENATOR GARCIA'S AB
2113. THIS IS THE MILL, THE MILL
BILL THAT'S BEING NEGOTIATED, AB
2113. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 2, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
ALL RIGHT, ITEM TWO. THAT'S.
YEAH. SO THAT'S 3 TO 2. WE'LL
HOLD THAT OPEN FOR SENATOR
GONZALEZ, AB 347 BY TING. OKAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
. SENATORS GONZALEZ. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE. OKAY, LET'S NOW GO
TO ITEM THREE AB 2244. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WITH THE CURRENT VOTE
FOR TO ZERO. SENATORS GONZALEZ
NGUYEN SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. THAT IS, FIVE VOTES
FOR, WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
LINA AB 2401. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WITH THE CURRENT VOTE AS 5 TO 0.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. OKAY, THAT'S SIX
ZERO. NOW WE'LL LEAVE IT UP FOR
GONZALEZ, AB 863. I GET CURRY.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 2, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. HURTADO. SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. 3 TO 2. ALL RIGHT.
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE NEED,
SENATOR SKINNER TO ADD ON. OKAY
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
FILE ITEMS SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE,
14, 15, TÍNH, 16, 17, AND 19.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. OKAY ITEM 18. ITEM
1018 ABC 1864. CONNOLLY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO SENATE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 2, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
GONZALEZ, HURTADO, SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. OKAY. THAT'S 3 TO
2. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN,
FRIEDMAN'S AB 1963 ITEM 11. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED TO
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 2, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. ALL RIGHT. 3 TO 2.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN, AB 2552.
FRIEDMAN. ITEM 12. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 3, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS GONZALEZ,
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. OKAY. 3
TO 3. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
ITEM 13 AB 2091. GRAYSON THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO, SKINNER.
SKINNER I OKAY, LET'S GO TO
SENATOR. SENATOR POPPINS, AB
2515. ITEM 18. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 2
TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
HAPPENS, MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS FOR
SPILL. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE UP TO
NOW. YEAH. SENATORS. DALY
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO Þ I
NGUYEN SKINNER. SKINNER OR I
THAT'S 4 TO 0. WILL WILL GO TO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR LINA,
AND THEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOODS AB
2902. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
SKINNER THAT'S 2903 2902
SKINNER. AYE. OKAY NOW WE GO TO
ONE CARILLO AB 3179. ITEM 21.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO Þ HURTADO. AYE.
SKINNER SKINNER. AYE. AND THEN
I, AB 3265 BY BRIAN. ITEM 22.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
SENATORS DASH, LEE, GONZALEZ
HURTADO. HURTADO I MOVE THAT
OPEN. I THINK DÍAS IS A NO VOTE
ON THAT ONE. OKAY. SO LET'S
LET'S GO THROUGH THE LIST. I
THINK SENATOR SKINNER IS ALL
SET, BUT FOR SENATOR HURTADO'S
EDIFICATION, LET'S DO ITEM FIVE.
THIS IS AB 863 AGUIAR-CURRY.
THIS IS THE CARPETING EPR BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. THAT'S 4 TO 2.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, I
THINK WE'VE GOT. LET'S SEE, MR.
CHAIR, WOULD I BE ABLE TO CHANGE
MY VOTE ON SATELLITE? OF COURSE.
YEAH FINAL ITEM TEN. THAT'S
CONNOLLY, AB 1864. OKAY AB 1864.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HURTADO, THAT
THIS CAN GO FROM HÌNH TO TWO. SO
WE HAVE YOU AT NÓ VÆ. I HAD YOU
AT. YEAH. OH, DO YOU WANT TO
KEEP THAT NOT VOTING. OKAY YEAH
WE'LL KEEP THAT. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO ITEM 11, SENATOR
FRIEDMAN'S AB 1963. THIS WAS THE
PARAQUAT, PROHIBITION. OKAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. HURTADO. NO.
OKAY. THAT'S 3 TO 3. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN, OKAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON'S AB 2091. THIS IS THE
SECRET PARKS ONE. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS TO SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 5 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO HURTADO I ALL
RIGHT, I THINK THAT'S GOT YOU
COVERED, SENATOR. SO THANK YOU.
YEAH. WHAT'S, SENATOR GONZALEZ
STATUS? SHE LOST BY 100. OH,
GREAT. OKAY GREAT. OKAY, SO FOR
22. ALL RIGHT. YEAH.
WE ARE. WE ARE PLEASED TO HAVE,
SENATOR GONZALEZ HERE, SO LET'S
GO THROUGH THE ROLE, IF THAT'S
OKAY. WE WILL START WITH AB
2113. THIS IS THE MILL FEE BILL,
THAT, THAT IS WORKED ON BEING
WORKED ON RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK.
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY.
2113, THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE OKAY, THAT'S 4 TO 2, WE ARE
GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL. LET'S
GO TO ITEM TWO. AB 347 BY TING.
OKAY. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ
I, I WILL CLOSE THE ROLL 5 TO 2,
SIMILAR THINGS. AB 2244 THE
BISPHENOL A BILL. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 5 TO 0. SENATOR GONZALEZ
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. THAT IS,
620. WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
ROLL, ITEM FOUR TINGS AB 2401
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0 6 TO 0. SENATORS
GONZALEZ. AYE. SEVEN ZERO.
THAT'S OUT. UNANIMOUS. OKAY. WE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLL THAT AB 863
AGUIAR-CURRY CARPET EPR. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATOR GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I HAVE TO TWO. WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL THAT IS OUT NEXT.
WE HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE CALENDAR. GONZALEZ I, I
SORRY, SENATOR GONZALEZ I'M LIKE
THERE'S TWO OF US HERE. AWESOME.
SENATOR GONZALEZ MINE. THEN ALL
HIS I, I, ALL RIGHT. WE'LL CLOSE
THE ROLL. THAT'S A UNANIMOUS
WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, OKAY.
CONNERLY'S AB 1864, ITEM TEN AB
1864. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO
2. SENATOR GONZALEZ. AYE. SALAS.
AYE. OKAY. THAT IS 4 TO 2. WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL NEXT. WE HAVE, AB
1963. FRIEDMAN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 3 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
. GONZALEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
ALL RIGHT. SO THAT IS 4 TO 3.
CLOSEST VOTE OF THE DAY, WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT ITEM. 12
AB 2552 FRIEDMAN THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 3 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATOR GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I BOARD OF THREE. OKAY
4 TO 3. WE'LL CLOSE THAT, ITEM
13 GRAYSON AB 2091. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0. SENATOR GONZALEZ
I GONZALEZ I ALL RIGHT, 7 TO 0.
THAT IS OUT. WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLL. NOW WE HAVE PAPINES AB
2515. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0. SENATOR GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
OKAY, THAT'S OUT WITH A50 VOTE,
NOW, SENATOR WOODS 2902. THAT'S
ITEM 20. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6
TO 0. SENATOR GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I OKAY, SEVEN ZERO.
THAT IS OUT. WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLL, JUAN CARLOS AB 3179. ITEM
21. THE CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0.
SENATOR GONZALEZ OKAY. NOT
VOTING. SO THAT WAS WILL CLOSE
THE ROLL ON THAT. THAT IS 6 TO
0. AND THEN FINALLY ISAAC
BRIAN'S AB 3265. ITEM 22 THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HI. GONZALEZ. HI. OKAY.
6 TO 0. AND THAT DOES IT. THANK
YOU. YEAH. APPRECIATE IT OKAY.
WE WILL NOW ADJOURN THE HEARING.